HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY ARE WE DO NOT YET HAVE
A CORE BUT WE ARE GOING TO GET
STARTED- WE'RE GONNA START AS A
COMMITTEE. SUBCOMMITTEE LET ME
JUST COUPLE OF INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS FIRST I WANT TO JUST TAKE
A MOMENT AND THANK ALL OF OUR
STAFF OF MADE A RETURN TO OUR
CAPITAL POP TO CONDUCT THE
BUSINESS OF OUR LEGISLATURE.
ARE DUE TO THE STATE HOME OR-
IN IN THE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING WE HAVE
LIMITED PHYSICAL SPACE IN THIS
ROOM FOR PEOPLE TO WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON AND STILL
PRACTICE OF DISTANCING SO WE
HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
I'M GONNA NOTE THAT FOR THE
HOUSING CAN BE SINCE THE
COTTMAN PRACTICE OF THE HOUSES
FOR PEOPLE TO BE PROPERLY HIRED
TEARING WHERE IN ASKING THE
REQUIREMENT FOR IMPROPERLY
ATTIRED FOR COMMITTEE. FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. TODAY IN
ROOM FOURTEEN FORTY TWO OH TWO
WE ARE CONDUCTING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANCE IN PERSON HEARING.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS IN THIS
HEARING ROOM WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THE
MINIMUM CONTENTION OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
AND SIX FEET OF SPACE IN. THERE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOL FOR THE POP ENTER AND
LEAVE. FOR THE DAY IN THE- IF
ANY MEMBER IN THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE JUST RAISE YOUR HAND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. ASK ROADS
THE MICRA. I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO SEAT.
PLEASE BE SURE TO SERVE
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR VIDEO CONFERENCE OF
WITNESSES IN ADDITION TO
TESTIFYING FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SEVERAL
WITNESSES WERE MAKING USE OF
OUR WITNESS CONFERENCING ROOMS
WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. AS WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND CAN ALSO ASK QUESTIONS
OF THE WITNESSES. ALSO WILL
HAVE DIALED WITNESSES- WERE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESSCAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING. SHOULD ON THE
TELEVISION IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN IT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE ONE. ACTS CO ONE THE ONE
FOUR FOUR TWO OH TWO. AGAIN.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH.
YOU CAN FIND NUMBER ON THE EAST
SIDE AS WELL AS OUR TOP. YOU
FOR CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
THAT IS YOUR TESTIFIED FOR HIS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS HOW TO BE
PLACED IN A QUEUE. BASED ON
WHAT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE ON AN- A MINUTE
ALL. WHY IS THIS INCLUDE
COMMUTING LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
IN YOUR SMARTPHONE DEVICES TO
REDUCE SOUND DISPERSION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU'RE
A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A BILL
YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIFELINE
AND WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF
AND- ALL THE- IF YOU'RE- ANY
PROBLEMS WITH MOB. THE PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL MY STAFF
AT THE COMMITTEE. AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT FIVE. MY STAFF WILL BE
READY TO HELP. I ALSO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING. MONEY THROUGH
THE POSITION LETTER POLL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING PATIENT
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT NEW
METHODS FOR CONTINUING TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. OF ALL THAT WE FACE. WE
WILL HAVE TO ME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TO IN OPPOSITION.
EACH MAIN WITESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO TESTIFY. AND I STILL
SEE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE WILL PROCEED I ALSO WANT
TO JUST ANNOUNCED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING THAT
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WILL BE
CONSIDERED I HAVE BEEN APPALLED.
SEVEN I AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY TWO MULLIN.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT KANSEN CHU. AND
ITEM TWENTY AB NINETEEN OH FIVE
WHICH IS MINE DAVID CHIU. SO
WITH THAT I THINK WE HAVE OUR
FIRST BILL AUTHORED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AB TWENTY FOUR OH
SIX FILE ITEM ONE WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK
YOU REALLY BE HERE TODAY. YOU
KNOW I ASSUME THIS WILL BE SAID
QUITE A BIT THIS COMMITTEES
TODAY BUT- IF NEEDS BE
UNDERSCORED THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FACE IN TERMS OF
OUR- IN CRISIS AND ARE THE
STATE FACED WITH GIVEN THE
COVER NINETEEN ECONOMIC FALL
OUT. PART OF THE SOLUTION THERE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL RESOURCES
FROM THE STATE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE FORM OF
FINANCIAL AID FOR LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS WHICH I FULLY SUPPORT.
THE WITH EIGHT ALSO BECOME ALSO
CRITICAL AS ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES. AND THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE AN ONLINE
PORTAL THAT WILL COLLECT RENTAL
DOT INFORMATION. AB TWENTY FOUR
SIX FOR LANDLORDS TO REGISTER.
IF THEY ARE ACCEPTING STATE OR
FEDERAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE A
RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
WHICH I BELIEVE IS A REASONABLE
ASK OF LANDLORDS. LANDLORDS
SAVING THESE RESOURCES-
TENANTS- MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS-
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
WILL ALSO BE ALLOWED TO
VOLUNTARY SUBMIT THE DATA
SHOULD THEY SO CHOOSE. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL TO WRITE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR LENDERS
RECEIVING RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTING RESIDENTS FROM
EXPERIENCING HOW DO TO COVER
NINETEEN. THIS YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE'S LOOKING AT SOME
OF THESE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE AS
WELL AS MYSELF- IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING THAT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. HOWEVER AB TWENTY
FOUR SIX IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW
BILLS HOLDING LIMITS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR RECEIVING. SUCH
A SYSTEM. REQUIRING LENS PLAY
TO SUBMIT BASIC RENTAL DATA
INFORMATION IS NOT TIME
CONSUMING. FOR EXAMPLE THE CITY
OF LA'S RENTAL REGISTRY IS TWO
PAGES. TAKES AT MOST MAYBE TEN
MINUTES. I APPRECIATE THIS
QUESTION AMONG MY COLLEAGUES
AND ADVOCATES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT CESSATION
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. AND THIS BILL. IN ITS
CURRENT FORM FRANKLY NEEDS MORE
WORK AND- I HAD EARLIER VERSION
OF THIS BILL WHICH WE BASICALLY
GOT IT- THINKING THROUGH WHAT'S
ACTUALLY THAN THIS MOMENT IN
TIME GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION THAT WE'RE FACED
WITH. AND WANT TO BE MORE
THOUGHTFUL BUT HOW WE APPROACH
OUR POLICIES WERE GIVEN OUR
CURRENT REALITY SO THERE WILL
BE CHANGES TO THIS BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD FOR EXAMPLE. GET
PLACER TWENTY. TO THE- THAT
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED. WE'RE ALSO
POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT HOUSING
THIS ONLINE PORTAL THROUGH- U.
S. C. OR C. S. YOU- RESEARCH
BASE ENTITY HOUSING THIS PORTAL
AND ON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY WILL
REDUCE. THE COST WILL ALSO I
CAN IMPORT ELEMENT TO FIGURE
OUT. HERE GIVEN ARE ON BUDGET
SITUATION. HI AND AS I SAID
IT'S STILL WORK IN PROGRESS I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL HAVING SOME
LIGHT IN TRANSPARENCY OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT- IS IT IS GOING TO BE KEY
AS WE THINK ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY OF COVERT NINETEEN AND
I WOULD FOR THESE REASONS THAT
AB TWENTY FOUR SIX MOVE FOR
TODAY IN ORDER TO ALLOW
DISCUSSIONS TAKE. TEST THE PORT
IS. EVE FROM TECH EQUITY. AND
MARK STIVERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS- I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I'M GONNA
ASK MODERATOR TO CONNECT US
FIRST WITH THE FIRST WITNESS
AND THAT IS- IT IAN EVE PERRY
FROM TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE.
OKAY THEN AT THE END. A LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. COULD YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE.
MEMBERS ARE ON THE- ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE YOUR PLEASE. THE OKAY.
AND. RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. A LOT
OF. MY THE MIKE ON. FOR EXAMPLE
OF THE RIVER EXCUSE ME COULD
YOU HOLD ON FOR ONE MOMENT LET
ME ASK THE SERGEANTS IS THE
MICROPHONE ON OR TROUBLE IN THE
WIND. GO TO WORK TO. TRY TO
WORK THAT OUT. THANKS OKAY
COULD YOU LIFTED IMPOSSIBLE TO
LIFT IT UP TO SEE COULD SPEAK
RIGHT INTO IT OR MAYBE ****
SERGEANTS OF FINANCES YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THIS IS NEW
FOR EVERYONE. AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PROJECT THROUGH THE
MASKS HOLLOW NOW ONE ANGLER
THOUGHT IF WITH EVERYONE'S
INDULGENCE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
START OVER AGAIN. JUST ABOUT.
OKAY SO CHAIRPERSON SHE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY AND YET YOU PARTY POLICY
MANAGER FOR TECH EQUITY
CLEVERNESS WE ARE A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION THAT EDUCATES
ACTIVE SYNC. THOUSANDS OF TIMES
CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TECH INDUSTRY CAN AND SHOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO BROAD BASED
GROWTH. THE BENEFITS EVERYONE
ENDING THE HOUSING CRISIS IS A
CRUCIAL PIECE OF OUR MISSION.
THAT'S TECH WORKERS WE KNOW
THAT RELIABLE DATA KEY ELEMENT
OF AFFECTED DECISION MAKING IN
CREATING SOLUTIONS TO THE
CRISIS IS NO DIFFERENT. THIS
WEEK COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
ECONOMIST PUBLISHED A STUDY
STATURE. IT THANKING PANDEMIC
PRIEST ALMOST TWELVE BY TWELVE.
THAT IS NOT OVER STAGGER WAS
THIS CRISIS. GIVEN A INCREASED
URGENCY BOTH THE DRY THE HOME
GRAY AND ENSURE. EFFICIENT
STEWARDSHIP OF THE STATE
LIMITED FUNDING NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE DATA TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS. ABOUT HOW
TO TARGET RESOURCES. AND
LANDLORDS WHO. ASSISTANCE ARE
NOT CONTRIBUTING TO INCREASE.
AND HOME. THE FORTY TREAT THIS
LIKE. ANTI DATA ON THIS OF THE
RIGHT TO HOUSING OR DOESN'T.
THE DAVID DOES EXIST PROVIDE
RESOURCES LIKE FILL OUT. SKEWS
TOWARD THE HIGHER PRICED
TORSION OF THE RENTAL MARKET
SHE DOES NOT ALLOW FOR ANALYSIS
OF RENT DYNAMICSLOWER PRICE
RENTALS. WHICH ARE MORE LIKELY
TO HOUSE VULNERABLE LOW INCOME
RENTERS. THE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SURVEY FROM THE US BUREAU WITH
MORE REPRESENTATIVE. OF THE
ENTIRE RENTAL MARKET BUT THE
DATA AT THE NEIGHBORHOOD OR
SMALL CITY LEVEL IS ONLY
ACCURATE WHEN USING FIVE YOUR
PURCHASE. WHICH RESPOND TO THE
RAPID CHANGES IN THE HOT. WHAT
RENTAL. POLICY MAY STOPPED HERE
DOLLARS ARE BEING TARGETED
EFFECTIVELY TO MID THE AND OF
THE CODE NINETEEN CRISIS ON OUR
MOST VALUABLE RESIDENTS. HI
STAND WITH THE FAMILY SIX AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. WE
URGE YOU TO PASS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ACT. MUCH ARE SO
ONE MISUNDERSTAND STONE VERSUS
HERE IN THIS ROOM. IF NOT I'M
GONNA ASK MODERATOR IF MR
STIVERS IS ON. THE CALL. I AM
GOING TO CHECK JUST ONE MOMENT
I CHECKING. I'M NOT SHOWING-
MARKS DIAPERS ARE LISTED ON THE
CALL AT THIS TIME OKAY- IF NOT.
I'M GONNA ASK IF THE MODERATE
COULD OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY- SUPPORT. OKAY AND THAT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE- SUPPORT FOR
BILL EIGHTY TWO FOUR OR SIX WE
WOULD LIKE YOU TO PRESS STAR IN
PAN. EURO SUPPORT BILL AB TWO
FOUR ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS STAR
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
JUST A MOMENT. I HAVE SEVERAL
COMING YEAR IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU SURE
THING THANK YOU. JUST READ THE
INSTRUCTION IF YOU'D LIKE TO
GET INTO THE YOU AT THIS TIME
YOU WILL PRESS. STAR AND THEN
ZERO. VIEW HERE IN SUPPORT YES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RAN
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. GREAT AN OPEN LINE
FOR LINE NUMBER FORTY SIX JUST
TO LET YOU KNOW. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT I HAVE L<c.cyan>G FORTY SIX</c>
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THE- LEVEL
ON BEHALF OF THE- CALIFORNIA-
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICE THE- ONLY BE OUT COLD.
THE OFFICE VERY YEAH ABOUT CORE
ALL FOR THE BILL FOR. THIS WEEK.
ALL MODERATOR OTHER SUPPORTERS.
MOMENT PLEASE. THE. ONE OF THE
MOST. IN A LINE FOR NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE FIFTY FIVE ALIGN IS OPEN.
MR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DAVID AND DOG ABOUT THE TALK
SHOW HAPPY TO BE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR IT'S
REACHED. COMING UP TO YOU I'M
GOING TO BE UP THE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND I LIVE IN SAN FOR A LITTLE
WHILE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
LEGISLATORS MY NAME IS TERRA
OGILVY AND I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M WITH SAN
FRANCISCO AGAIN BE ACTION AND
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. YOU ARE GOING
TO BE OPENING LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY TWO THAT SEVEN TWO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANKS SEVENTY
TWO THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SEVENTY TWO. HI
IS THAT ME. YES IT IS PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY THIS IS LAURA FROM
YOU IN THE ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT THING WOULD BE LÏNG
OPENING UP MY NUMBER EIGHT ZERO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE EIGHT ZERO. THANK
YOU HELLO THIS IS GIOVANNA
MORALIS FROM LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. Q.
NEXT I'M GONNA BE OPENING LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN THAT EAT
SEVEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE EIGHT SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LOUIS MARON FAE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YEAH BE- URGING OR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR TWENTY FOUR SICK
THIS MORNING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL NINETY FOUR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NINETY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
JAMES FOLEY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CLEAR RICHMOND TEXAS
GOVERNOR URGING STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TIME OPENING
THE LINE FOR NINETY SIX ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE I
THINK THERE WITH THE OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT. YEAH.
OKAY I DO
HAVE ONE NINETY SIX OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NINETY SIX. BOB.
I JUST MOMENT PLEASE. I DO
APOLOGIZE WERE JUST TRYING TO
GET LÏNG NINETY SIX OPEN ONE
MOMENT. A NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY ABOUT THAT OKAY I
DO HAVE NINETY SIX OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR STATEMENT.
BY NINETY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN
JUST A MOMENT. PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINETY SIX APPARENTLY THE THEY
DO NOT WISH TO COMMENT WE'RE
GONNA CLOSE THAT LINE I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE- THANK YOU- IF
IT'S OKAY MISTER SERVICES HERE-
TO PRESENT ON BEHALF THE BILL
LIKE TO GIVE HIM TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MARK. GET A LITTLE
CLOSER THE MICROPHONE MARK
STIVERS CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP MY APOLOGIES ARE
BEING TARGETED IN CASE THE TIME
CHANGE- BUT THAT WE'RE FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL YOU KNOW
RENT INCREASES FICTIONS. LEAD
TO HOMELESS. SUPERHEATED HOW
MARKET LIKE THIS. AT THE STATE
IS ABOUT A NUMBER OF TIME
LIMITED RENTER PROTECTIONS BUT
LACKS DATA ON RENT CREASES AND
TERMINATIONS TO DEVELOP
TARGETED DATA INFORMED. SEIZE
ANY DISTINCT SETS THE OUR
PROPRIETARY EXPENSIVE AND NOT
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC. THIS
BILL IS THE FIRST STEP TO
CREATING A STATE WIDE BY UNIT
RENTAL HOUSING DATABASE. AT THE
INFORMATION NEEDED HOUSING
POLICY CHOICES. TWENTY FOUR OH
SIX TODAY THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH. AT THIS TIME WHEN WE
NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO WITNESSES ON
THE LINE- IF THE MODERATOR
COULD FIRST CONNECT US TO THE
FIRST WITNESS AND THAT IS DEBRA
CARLTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. GO AHEAD
DEBORAH KERR ON THE LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DIFFICULTY THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT A
FIFTY THOUSAND FOR PROFIT AND
NONPROFIT HOUSING PROVIDERS
THOSE ARE SINGLE AND MULTI
FAMILY. WE KNOW ABOUT THE-
IDENTIFIED ALREADY THAT AB TWO
FOUR OH SIX A MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT LAST YEAR WAS
PREDICTED AT TWENTY MILLION
WITH THAT EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION START UP AND SEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION ANNUALLY.
AND EVEN OUT I CONTRACTORS BILL
AND- CERTAINLY EGGS ARE.
BUILDING THE ON THE BACK OF AN
ALL THE STRESS SYSTEM WITH THE
PROJECTED BUDGET OF FIFTY FOUR
MILLION IS JUST NOT GOOD
POLICY. BE THE OWNERS TO ACCEPT
MONEY FOR RENT SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ITS USE. IT IS
NOT THE VEHICLE NOT TO MENTION
THERE ARE DISINCENTIVES FOR
OWNERS TO ACCEPT FUNDS- WITH
THE BILL FOR ALL POLL AND OWNER
WHO WANTED TO HELP ONE OR TWO.
HUNDRED YOU BRING. ALL UP MIGHT
BE FOR IF THEY HAVE TO TIMES
STAFF TO REPORT INFORMATION FOR
ALL THE UNITS IN THE BUILDING
THIS IS JUST NOT PRACTICAL.
THERE ARE OTHER VEHICLES FOR
REPORTING IF AN OWNER RECEIVES
MONEY WE HAVE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TEN TO PROVIDE DOLLARS
IT WILL REQUIRE OWNERSHIP RIGHT
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE U. AB
TWO TWO SEVEN ONE THE RECALL
COURTS TO REPORT ADDED.
INFORMATION ABOUT EVICTIONS AND
WE DO HAVE ACCEPTABLE PUBLIC
OUR DATABASES THAT CAN'T BE
LIKE WITH AND MUCH. LESS COST
AND WHAT IT HERE. AND FINALLY
IF AB TWO FOUR SIX WERE TO
BECOME LAW ON IT WOULD TAKE A-
AFTER PROPERTY OWNERS HAVE
RECEIVED ROLE LOOK. THANK. THE
PRICE PROPERTY OWNERS WITH AN
EXTENSIVE LIST OF INFORMATION
AND THE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
HERE KNOWING THAT THAT WILL
ALSO BE MADE PUBLIC FAR AFTER
OWN HAVE RECEIVED THAT FUNDING
AND FORTY REASONS QUESTION NO
VOTE TODAY I THANK YOU SO. MUCH
META MODERATE GO TO WIN
ASSEMBLY TO A CREAM GREASY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. ADD CREAM THREE C. AS
A LINE IS OPEN PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS- CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FOUR OH
STICK. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO A STAFF. REGISTRY
WITH INTEREST DICTION. TWENTY
FOUR A IT TARGETS RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS ADVERSELY
IMPACTED BUT NINETEEN CAN MAK
THAT REQUIRING THEM TO ANNUALLY
REGISTER CONTINUALLY UPDATED
PERPETUITY A MULTITUDE OF
PERSONAL PROPRIETARY. REGARDING
UNIT. HE ARE. BUT WILL RECEIVE
FEDERAL WOULD NINETEEN REMAINS
ADDITIONALLY AB TWENTY FOUR
INCLUDE REQUIRED EIGHT NOT
CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE COMPANY
CREATE AND ADMINISTER THE
REGISTRY MANDATED BY THE BILL.
NUMBER THEN DELEGATION EIGHT
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY TO A
PRIVATE COMPANY AS FOR THE BILL
RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
FAILED- READ AND ACCIDENT. TO
AMONG OTHERS ISSUE A NOTICE FOR
ADDICTION EVEN IF IT IS DUE TO
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. FINAL
ANALYSIS OPEN NINETEEN RELIEF
AN UNRELATED ONEROUS REGISTRY
WHICH WOULD BE ON TOP OF THE
PAPER WORK ALREADY REQUIRED FOR
COULD NINETEENTH BELIEVE.
CONCERNING ISN'T THAT THE
VERTICAL TERRIERS MUCH NEEDED
FINANCIAL. AB TWENTY FOUR OH
SIX ENTERS PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
UP STOCKS ARE SEEKING OR WILL
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN RELEASE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO
KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH AFFECTED US MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN UP TO- COMES
FROM THE PUBLIC. WHO OPPOSED
THE BILL. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL- PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN. AGAIN THE INSTRUCTION IS
TO PRESS ONE AND THEN TWO ZERO
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE WINE
EIGHTY EIGHT OPEN AGAIN THAT'S
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ROLL MONEY CHAIR NUMBER
YOU COMMITTEE ADAM WRIGLEY WE
CAN'T CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. ALL LET DEADLINE BUT
WE ARE POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO BE JUST A MOMENT
HERE- FOR NEXT PERCENT. IF WINE
EIGHTY NINE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE EIGHTY NINE. A
MEDICARE MEMBERS STEVE CARLTON
CITY APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER PHILLIPS- FOR THE
REGULATING APARTMENT OWNERS
IT'S GONNA DO NOTHING BUT
EXACERBATE OUR EXISTING
PROBLEMS- PLEASE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. BUT HE LINE FORTY ONE
THAT'S LINE FOR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR NUMBER DIGGER CEELO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
THAT'LL WORK HOW WE- IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO FOUR
ZERO SIX THANK YOU. A LINE
EIGHTY FOR THAT LINE EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRIS BY TALKING WITH THE
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION- WE
ALSO APOLOGIZE FOR A LATE
LETTER PERFECT WE- READ THAT
THIS IS BAD POLICY. VIRGIN OF A.
Q. NEXT WE GO TO LINE NINETY
TWO AGAIN THAT IS LINE NINE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TEACHER
MEMBERS MORAN. ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE OTHER BUT WHEN
YOU'RE RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED THANK YOU. CAN CAN YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
ANALYSTS OR ANY OTHER MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC LET'S BRING WHO WISH
TO SPEAK LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION
COLLEAGUES AT. QUESTION. I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR THE BILL
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS I KNOW
THIS IS BàN. OR MORE A PART
YEARS I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
AS WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE
POLICIES FOR SOME OF SEVENTEEN
MILLION TENANTS IN CALIFORNIA
WE OFTEN LACK DATA SCOPE
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM. AND UP ARE YOU GLAD TO
SEE POLICY PROPOSALS MOVING
AROUND DATA COLLECTION TO
PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT. PARTICULARLY APPS
THERE ARE PROPOSALS FOR
CALIFORNIA SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE FOR. TO SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EXPLORE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE POLICIES
MOVING FOR. I KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE JOSH. THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED
TO CONSIDER WE SHOULD MOVE THIS
BECAUSE MONEY MIGHT MOVE FOR
BEFORE THIS BILL DOESN'T AFFECT
ITS MIGHT BECTIVE THAT. STATE
IS GONNA HAVE ANY. WITH THIS WE
OUGHT TO. COLLECT UNDERSTAND
OUR WHO IS RICH IN THIS DATA
AND ENSURE THAT- WERE WHO IS
RECEIVING FUNDING AND ENSURE
THAT- FUNNY IS BEING TO BEST
USE SO- I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER POLLUTION
THIS BILL I KNOW. BROADER BILL
THEY CAME TO US. I THINK. FOR
THIS AGE OF CRIME THIS MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE OF YOU'VE
STRUCTURED IT. I ALSO THINK OF
THE WAY YOU TREATED- GIVES THE
UPPER EIGHTY TO REALLY REDUCE
COSTS SO APPRECIATE YOU DOING
THAT AND- WITH THAT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT. SELECT STERN. ONCE
THROUGH. JUST RESPECT. OKAY
SINCE NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET WE
CAN MAKE A MOVE BUT AS AS WE DO
WILL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. AND REMEMBER AND
WHO IS OUR EXPERT IS APPARENTLY
IN LABOUR COMMITTEE SO WE ARE
EXPECTING- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AUTUMN BURKE TO SHOW UP
IMMINENTLY. AND UNTIL. WE WILL
HANG OUT. MAJOR YEAH YEAH. THE.
AND. RIGHT I'M GONNA ASK FOR
ALL STAFF OF MEMBERS WHO HAVE
BILLS THAT ARE IN OUR COMMITTEE
TODAY IF YOU COULD PLEASE- LET
YOUR MEMBERS KNOW THAT- THAT
ARE DIFFERENT COMMITTEES ARE
STUCK AND OTHER MEMBERS TAKEN
UP MANY SAID. IT WAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE. MEMBERS DOWN
PERCENT BILLS THANK YOU.
MR
STONE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
WHEN WE NOW GO TO FILE ITEM
ELEVEN. AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO. AND APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON SHORT NOTICE GIVEN THAT-
NUMBER AUTHORS ARE MISSING. THE
CATCH MY BREATH THANK YOU IN
FACT EIGHT TO BE PRECISE SO
APPRECIATE YOU WATCH. SURE SO
THIS BILL MEMBERS. IS INA LINE
OF BILLS WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
WORK WITH THAT DEAL WITH MOBILE
HOME PARK CAN. AND CLOSURES AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT THAN
LAST YEAR'S BILL. BUT WE'RE
REALLY JUST TRYING TO DO HIS.
IMPROVE THE NOTICED THAT
RESIDENTS GET THAT THE- UNIT
OWNERS GET THAT THE- BILL ALSO
CLARIFIED THE POWER OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PROTECT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY ACTUALLY
ASKING THEM TO MAKE BINDING OF
APPROVAL BEFORE AND TO CONVERT
TO PREVENTING THE CONVERSIONS
BUT WHERE YOU LOOK AT YOUR
OPTIONS TO MAKE A FINDING IT
TAKE A LOOK AT THE- STOP.
PORTABLE IN THEIR JURISDICTION
AND THE VILLAGERS THAT THE
DISPLACED HOMEOWNER WILL
RECEIVE THE IN PLACE MARKET
VALUE OF THEIR LOST HOME. HE
OBTAIN ADEQUATE HOUSING IN
ANOTHER MOBILE HOME PARK AND
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
SEEN WITH THESE CONVERSIONS.
OFTEN TIMES THE HOME OWNER GETS
DIMINISHED VALUE FOR THEIR UNIT
IN THESE CONVERSION
TRANSACTIONS SO IT'S TOOLS FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IT'S BETTER
NOTICED. OWNERS AND IT'S- IS
THAT THE HOMEOWNER IS GOING TO
GET A FAIR MARKET VALUE FOR
THEIR UNIT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ISLAND.
GIVEN OUR ONE WE NOW GOOD. THE
MAIN WITNESSES. I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE ON THE TELEPHONE THE FIRST
WITNESS FOR THIS BILL I'LL ASK
A MODERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN
UP THE LINE FOR BRUCE STANTON-
FROM A DISMAL. STAND IN YOUR
LIFE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THE
STAFF CLICK GENERAL CAL OR
KIOSKS OF A WELL WHAT I
TESTIFIED. THE BILL
COMMENTATORS IN COURTS HAVE
RECOGNIZED THAT MOBILE HOMES
ARE NOT REALLY ALL POLL AT ALL
THERE REALLY AMPLE POOL HALL
WILL BE THE MOBILE HOME PARKS.
AT DO YEARS EXCEL OF LOCAL
PARKS WELL AT THAT DEBATED OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND SPACES HAVE
BEEN LOST SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THAT THE DATA SHOWS ONLY. FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EAST
ASIANS BILL CORRECT THE STAMP.
RED RED WITH THESE CLOSE THEIR
VOCAL ALL AGREE THERE MOST.
ASSET IS PLACED AT RISK BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WERE TO MOVE THE
HOME. THE VAST MAJORITY OF PARK
SEPT NO AT SPACES. AND MORE
ALLOW YOU ARE HOME AND YOUR
ROOMS LOCATE THEIR- ALSO AT THE
MANAGE ABOUT. OR THEIR- I SO
YOUR PROTECTION NEEDED TO THESE
PRESS OVER THE STUFF RIGHT GET
BACK IT WAS MISTER SCANT IF YOU
COULD IF COULDN'T STAND AND IF
YOU COULD A PROP TURN OFF YOUR
LIST TO DELAY IT WHEN. YEAH I
HAVE NOTHING ELSE ON THE
ACTUALLY OKAY. IF OTHERS CAN
ONLY ASK OTHERS ON THE LINE
PLEASE MAKE YOUR PHONE THANK
YOU. SO WHAT SORT OF VENOM OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STANDARD FOR A
MOBILE HOME PARK IT VERSION
PROCEDURE THAT TAKING. WE ARE
DISPLACED RESIDENTS. THE
EXISTING STATE LAW REQUIRES
GOVERNMENTS DO WITHOUT THE
METAPHORS POLICIES RIVER.
YOU'RE ABOUT WELL WHAT COME A
PORTABLE HOUSING STOCK IN THAT
RESTRICTED BY THIS BILL AND
IMPORTANTLY AREA QUICKLY. IT
WILL I HATE ANY LOCAL STATE I
COMES TO READY FOR PARKWAY.
MANY OF THE FIFTY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE ENACTED
THESE THESE CONVERSION ORDERED
HIS REQUIRED THE CONVERTED PARK
OVER TO PURCHASE THE RESIDENTS
TOPIC MARKET VALUE. RELOCATE IS
NOT AN OPTION A WEEK AT THE ASK
YOUR- IT'S A CREEK. THOSE
ORDINANCES THAT THIS BILL
ALTHOUGH GOVERNMENTS FOLLOW IN
THIS REGARD MR DAN IF I CAN ASK
HIM THAT WAS IF I COULD ASK YOU
UP THAT WOULD BE GREAT. HOW WE-
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU AND
LET ME AS A MODERATOR TO.
PLEASE ALLOW SON DO TO SPEAK
AND AGAIN EVERYONE HAS TWO
MINUTES I'M TRYING TO GIVE
PEOPLE TIME IF YOU'RE AT TO BE.
OF SOME CATION CHARGE UT THANK
YOU FOR A- TO THE TWO MINUTE
LIMIT. OKAY SANDOVAL LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MARK
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS UNDER- I AM HOME ALL OF
THE INCLUDED AYE INTERNAL WILL
AND A REPRESENTATIVES
REINVENTED RESIDENT CASE. AND
PRESIDENT OP ORANGE DRUG MOBILE
HOME READ FELICIA. CALIFORNIA
MOBILE HOME RENDON ASH
DESPERATE NEED AB TWO SEVEN
EIGHT TO ACT GREEN LANTERN WE
HAVE A HUNDRED THIRTY MOBILE
HOME NEXT. WE HAVE A SEVENTY
WILL BE HOME PARK AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE MOBILE HOME UNIT. B. TWO
SEVEN EIGHT TWO BACK ON UP US
BY BUYING OUR OWNER TO PAY US
FAIRLY FOR OUR- IS THE AND
AFTER A CLOSER. IN TWO
THOUSAND. WE THE CLOSER ABOUT
PARKS WE LEARNED PARK ON ALL
OFFERS TWENTY FIVE A STAND OF
THE MARKET VALUE TO OUR OUR
HOME. DO YOU DO ABOUT DO DO ALL
TECHNICALLY. HOW SHOULD BE
EARLY STOP THE PROPOSED WORLD
BUT STILL I WE MAIN OF US I
REALLY OLD 7% OFF THE HOUSE ARE
VERY LOW. IN MY CHAO AT ALL
MOST B. L. AND ARE LIMITED
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS. I CANNOT
AFFORD TO BUY AND THE MOBILE
HOME IN WEST NEWS- IF THE BILL
DID NOT ASK ALSO KEEPING PEOPLE
IN COMMUNITY IS SO YOU. MAY
NEED A LAND LINE OR IS IT OUT.
IS A MATTER PEOPLE. BUT BARBIE
IS IN THE HEART OF NEEDED SIDE
BEEN AND IT DOES I ALLOW US
RELY ON A OTHER AND DO STEVE
THE THIS IS THE MAYES TAKING
OFFICE ALL BY OUT NOW.
DIFFERENT AND THAT. TACK THAT
ARE COMING WILL BE. AND NOT BE
ABLE TO CARE FOR OUR CELL. WHAT
DO THE- I ARE EXPECT FORTY
EIGHT HOURS YOU TO PASS A. TWO
SEVEN EIGHT TWO TO PROVIDE
HOUSING. NEED TO BOOK BACK
COMMUNITY WELL I MIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR MUCH. WANT WE
OPEN UP I MEAN FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. OPERATOR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN INSTRUCTION PORT FOR THE
BILL. ONE AND THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD THANK YOU.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT. YOU
ARE WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
AGAIN THAT'S LINE ONE TWO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN AGAIN
THE- CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PLEASE
THE COACH BONTA SPELL ON VIRGIN
I'VE OUT. WE GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX THAT'S LINE ONE TWO
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YOUR CHEN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO. HERE WE GO NEXT TO
LINE EIGHTY DEADLINE EIGHT ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
GIOVANNA MORALIS FROM
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO. NEXT WE GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE THAT'S LINE ONE
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE ONE WE DO HAVE YOUR LINE
OPEN YOU WANT TO MAYBE JUST
CHECK IF YOU HAVE YOURSELF
YOU'D. AGAIN LINE ONE THIRTY
ONE WE DO HAVE YOUR LINE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY ONE WE
DO HAVE A LINE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND SPEAK. OKAY WE'RE NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE FROM ONE ONE
THIRTY ONE AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NOW GO TO THE
OPPOSITION I KNOW WE HAVE. TWO
WITNESSES IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM SO WE WILL. PAY
THAT TO THAT SETTING- THE
FIRST. INTER GOVERNOR FROM THE
WEST THE FACTORED. PLEASE
ASSOCIATE AND IF WE COULD NOT
ACCESS UP MISTER GOVERNOR'S
TESTIMONY THANK YOU. NO I DON'T
THINK HE'S GOING AT THE END.
ENTER GOVERNOR ON THE TOP OF
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION-
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE- OF WMA AS OPPOSED TO
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO FOR THE
FOLLOWING. REASONS FIRST AND
FOREMOST. LOW GOVERNMENT HAVE
BILL EIGHTY TO ACT AND FOR
THESE REGULATION TO RELOCATION
COSTS. THEY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE MEDIC THAT RESIDENTS NEED-
HE'S GOT CAN TAKE. DO FREE. I'M
THEIR CLOSURE STARTING ABOUT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT'S STILL.
HUNDRED AND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO YOU CAN SEE
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ABLE.
SO WE'RE CHEN OR SUCH A RUSSIAN
PARK CLOSURES WE WOULD ASSUME
THAT WE WOULD HAVE SEEN OVER
THE PAST FIFTEEN MONTHS AND
WE'RE ASIAN THAT WE WERE SEEING
THESE TAP. TEEN ALL THESE YEARS
WHY WE GETTING A BILL THAT'S
NOT URGENT IT'S NOT NEEDED AND
THERE'S NO DEFICIENCY THEY LAW
FOR THIS FINALLY I WOULD STAY
ON A LOT OF THE UNITS I'M JUST
BECAUSE SOMEBODY DOESN'T BUILD
MORE INTENSE I MEAN I WAS A OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE ANALYSIS
DOESN'T RECORD SEVEN DOLLARS SB
TURNED INTO. STANDS THE- GO
CLOSE HOME PARK THAT WAS ON AN
S. AND THEY DID NOT- BUILD LOW
INCOME OR MODERATE HOUSING AS A
RESULT IT WAS SIMPLY TO PROVIDE
SOMETHING BACK TO THE PUBLIC
FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD. UNDER THE-
I'M HAPPY. OKAY A PART AND CAN.
THAT WAS A MOBILE HOME PARK AT
THE STATE CLOSE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE PUBLIC FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. THAT WOULD NOT
RESULT IN MORE LOW INCOME OR
MODERATE HOUSING. YOU BELIEVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND HOUSING
ELEMENT TO STOP IT OVER MANY
YEARS. ABOUT THE SITE HOUSING
IF. WENT PROOF IS TYPE OF HOUSE.
THAT DOES AFTER BEING TO FISH
ON THEIR SERVICE TO. SO FOR
THESE READ WE DON'T BELIEVE THE
BILL'S SAYS THERE EIGHT WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. ONE WE
PROCEED TO THE NEXT WOULD
STRAYS HIKER FROM. THE HEALTH.
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
SPECIFIC ALLIANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON
OCCURRED WITH THAT'LL STEAM
GILBERT ROBESON SPENT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME
PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE I JUST I
WILL REPEAT MISTER SAID WELL
BUT JUST FOR ADDITIONAL YOU
KNOW. OPPONENTS NOTED LOST OVER
FIVE. AND SEVENTEEN SPACES IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. AT
TWENTY ONE ACTUALLY TO BE
PRECISE- THE REALITY IS THE-
EXCUSE ME AT THE REALITY IS
THAT. AT SIGN WHEN YOU CONSIDER
WHAT THE BILL REQUIRES IT IF WE
HAVE LOST THAT MANY PARKS AND
WE HAD WE DON'T HAVE THEY CAN
SEE AN PARKS GOING FORWARD AS
THE PROPONENT THAT- THE REALITY
IS THE REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL
THAT I HOPE A PARK HONOR BEFORE
CLOSING. COMMENTS EVERY AT
PRESIDENT THE IN PLACE MARKET
VALUE OF THEIR HOME IT IN
REALITY THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
AS A PRACTICE MATTER DO PRETTY
MUCH EVERY HOME. IF YOU ARE A
CO OWNER. ABLE OPERATE AND MAKE
A PROFIT ON YOUR YOU ARE NO
LONGER ABLE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
YOUR BUSINESS HAVE MAKE MONEY
FOR YOU THAT LEAVES THE ONLY
REAL OPTION IN ORDER THE
CLOSURE PARK AS BANKRUPTCY. AND
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY POINTS OUT
THERE MANY BUYERS WAITING IN
THE WINGS PRIVATE EQUITY FIRMS
AND INVESTORS WHO ARE LOOKING
TO PURCHASE MOBILE HOME PARKS
AND THEY HAVE A PLAYBOOK- THEY
ARE READY TO MEANT THEY WANNA
MAXIMIZE PROFIT THEY'RE NOT
LOOKING FOR THE- STATE BY. PARK
LOOKING DELETE TRYING. OUT OF
AND- CAN NOT OFF IN A WAY
THAT'S A- FOR THEMSELVES OR THE
RED AND SO. WHAT WE SEE A L. AS
THE PRACTICAL IMPACT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO IS THAT
THERE WON'T REALLY BE. A GOOD
OPTION OR REAL OP FOR PARK
OWNER WAS THERE PARKS AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE. WE ARE ACTUALLY
ENABLING SOME OF THE TERMS TO
ACT THE PROBLEM. LEE WAS THE
BILL QUESTION. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH OUT WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
CORE AT THIS TIME SO IN THE ASK
HER CIRCLE IF YOU COULD STOP
SCORE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILL
HERE CHIU HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DEEP. DEEP HERE GABRIEL GLORIA
GLORIA HERE KILEY KILEY HEAR ME
MOAN MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA HERE WE HAVE CORPS
OF LET'S GO BACK TO OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY THANK YOU TO THE MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- TO THE
MODERATOR OPEN IT UP TO OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO. PRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU TO IT
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL PRESS
ONE THEN FZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO THANK YOU. THE. AND WE
HAVE A PERSON THANK YOU IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE THREE ZERO THAT'S LINE ONE
THIRTY I WILL BE OPENING YOUR
LINE MOMENTARILY THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE THREE
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRMAN
CHIU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARGARET
NADA I AM AN ATTORNEY I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING IN THIS AREA THE LAW
FOR FORTY YEARS I HAVE BEEN-
COUNSEL FOR. TIME AND I HAVE
ALSO- I HAVE DONE I HAVE BEEN
LEAD COUNSEL IN A NUMBER OF
CLOSURES. FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO SAY I THINK IT JUST TWO
POINTS I WANT TO MAKE THE FIRST
IS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT MOST
CITIES WITH EIGHT WITH MOBILE
HOME PARK POPULATION ALREADY
CAP IN PLACE CLOSE YOUR
ORDINANCES. WHICH ARE GREATLY
RESTRICT AND THE PROFITS OF
CONVERGENCE OF MOBILE HOME PARK.
AND DO REQUIRE. OF MOBILE PAUL
AT IN PLACE ABOUT. ADDED IN OF
VALUE IS CONSIDERED THE FOR THE
AT THE CLOSE SO IT'S NOT A BIG
YOU GET A LETTER. BE THE PARK
IS CLOSING ITS CRAZY. UP QUITE
QUALIFY CREATE AT THE THAT THE
AND NOW OF. AT THE END OF WHICH
WOULD BE IF THE PARK NOT CLOSE.
THE THING IS THAT I COULD.
SOMEWHAT OF A YEAH THE IN THE
SENSE THAT. REALLY WHAT THE
WHAT PEOPLE OF THE FOCUSED ON
IS YOU KNOW THAT PURCHASE A
HOME AT A- FAB WHAT WHAT REALLY.
YOU SHOULD LOOK AT AT THE- IS.
WHAT THIS BILL TAKES AWAY FROM
CITY GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF THE
EFFORT. OF THEIR DISCRETION IN
THEIR OWN HOUSING ELEMENT PLAN.
IF WE'RE- TO MAKE A CONCLUSION
TO PUT THE BALL IN THIRD ACT AS
IF CERTAIN LAYING. IN ALREADY
THERE HOUSING ELEMENT PLANNED
ABOUT PORTABLE HOUSING AND
REPLACE OF MOTHER HOME PARK AND
SECONDLY TO. TO AND RIGHT NOW
THE GOVERNMENT CODE. THESE
NORMALLY DO NOT LIKE AND TO
DETER A DEVELOPMENT APPLICATION
FORM AT THE SAME TIME AS HE
CONSIDERED THE MOBILE HOME
PARK. SURE AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT THE FOCUS SHOULD
BE ON THE CLOSURE AND THE
MITIGATION ASSISTANCE FOR THE
RESIDENTS NOT WHAT THE FUTURE
DEVELOP BUT IT'S GOING TO LOOK
LIKE YOU WANT TO DO IS TO MAKE
SURE THE REST HAND. CATER TO.
THESE ARE PART AND- CURRENT
TRENDS MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD ON SITE REPLACEMENT
HOUSING AT PARK LOOK AT
WINCHESTER IN SAN JOSE- AND
OTHER PARK THAT IS WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THEY'RE GOING TO
BUILD THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A
PORTION. PARK BILL BUT REPLACE
HOW. THE DIRECTION IN WHICH BE
MOVING NOT YET WE CLOSE
HANDICAP THE CITY. THANK YOU
FROM. THANK YOU FOR MUCH LET'S
GO TO OTHER UPON. ONCE AGAIN OF
FOR UP- POSING A PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF I COULD
JUST ALSO MAKE CLEAR FOR THIS
PORTION OF THE OPPOSITION
PEOPLE COULD JUST REFLECT YOUR
NAME. PLEASE STAND AND- THE-
YOU. MAIN DISHES ARE HAPPEN
THROUGH HE EARLY WORK THE
EARLIER WITH US. NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE. RIGHT LET'S BRING
BACK FOR COMMITTEE DISCUSSION
COLLEAGUES ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS BILL. SEEN ON I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW THIS
HAS BEEN A BILL THAT HE'S
WORKED ON FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS- AND I KNOW IT TOUCHES
ON. A MIDDLE IS RUN PROPERTY
RIGHTS AND ABOUT BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN HOMEOWNERS AS WELL AS
PART INTERESTS. MEANS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. REALLY TRIES
TO STRIKE A- BETWEEN CREATING A
STANDARD. FOR COMPENSATE OWNERS
WHO LOSE THEIR RESIDENT STUDIO
PARK CLOSURE CONVERSION-
APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT THE
AUTHORS LOOKING TO PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITY.
IN THE- END UP I WILL BE STE
THE BILL. GIVE ANY COMPETENT
COMMENTS. THANK YOU I WOULD
JUST LIKE ADDRESS ACTUALLY. THE
OPPOSITION REALLY MAKE THE CASE
FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF CITIES ACCORDING TO
THE- AND- THEY DO THIS DASH.
THAT THE REPLACEMENT COST
NOTICED EVERYTHING THAT WERE
OCCURRING IN THE BILL IS IN
FACT. NOT ONEROUS THERE ARE
CITIES HOWEVER THAT DO NOT DO
THIS AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RECORD FOR CONVERSIONS. OFF
CONVERTED TO HIRING CONDOS AND
TOWNHOUSES AND OTHER THINGS
THAT THE THAT THE PARK
RESIDENTS. OUT OF FOUR TO LIVE.
SO IT WILL BE DISINGENUOUS TO
MAKE THAT ARGUMENT THAT THIS
BILL IS SO ONEROUS WENT THERE
ARE NUMBER CITIES TO DO THIS
ALL THIS BILL REALLY DOES. HE
CREATED. ASKED SATE FOR WHAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS LOOK AT TO
DO THESE CONVERSIONS WERE NOT
ASKING THEM TO NOT DO THE
CONVERSIONS WERE NOT ASKING
THEM TO DO ANYTHING THAT'S
OWNERS OTHER THAN TO THAT ONE
FINDING IT LOOKING AT THE END
PORTABLE. POSITIVE THE
CONVERSION MOVE AHEAD I THINK
THAT GIVEN ECONOMICS CURRENTLY
IN CALIFORNIA THERE WILL BE
INCREASED PRESSURE CONVERT
MOBILE HOME PARKS AWAY FROM
BEING MOBILE HOME PARKS AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY BRIDGER'S. THAT
EITHER. FOR TAKING THE- DRESS
THEIR HOUSE THANK. AND I HAVE A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SO
THERE'S BEEN A WITH BILLS ARE
SET. I WILL SAY BILL MATTER.
CLERK COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SHE'LL I. Q. I DEEP. DEEP NO
GABRIEL GLORIA GLORIA AYE KILEY
KILEY NO WE MOAN MAIENSCHEIN
QUIRK SILVA. BUT I THANK YOU
YOUR BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU BYE GREAT- I THINK OUR NEXT
PRESENTER IS- IS BURKE FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL I WILL SECOND IT.
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL AND I KNOW
YOU PRESENTED JUST. OUT I HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION AND A
SECOND I THINK THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
ON A AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO AB TWENTY
TWO. I AM REALLY I THINK WE ALL
KNOW WHAT IT DOES- THE BILL I
AUTHORED AND CAMINO PAST
JANUARY CALIFORNIA. NEEDS TO
BUILD ON HOUSING THE HOUSING
PRICES DURING THE GROUND OF
OURS PANDEMIC IN RECOGNIZE IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO SHELTER
INDIVIDUALS. AB TWENTY OH FOUR
OH FIVE EMPHASIZES. THAT
PERMANENT HOUSING IS THE ONLY
WAY. WE CAN AND PROMISES AND
PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK OUTLOOK
BEST PRACTICES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTING. ME
FROM LOSING THEIR HOMES IN THE
FIRST PLACE. PROVIDING
EMERGENCY ACCOMMODATIONS WAS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. SHOULD A
FAMILY. HOME AND ADDITIONAL.
WITH HIM TO PERMIT HOUSING
FOSTER A CULTURE OF DIGNITY AND
RESPECT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
THIS BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES
GREATER CARNATION ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
STREAMLINE AND INTEGRATE
POLICIES AND SERVICES THAT
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS. I THINK IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING I THINK
AROUND ON THIS COMMITTEE IS
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THIS BILL SO
WITH THAT I AM ALSO GOING TO
USE MY TESTIMONY FROM MY
PREVIOUS WITNESSES AS MY
TESTIMONY FOR AT THIS HEARING
SO WITH THAT I REQUEST BUCKLEY
A QUESTION I WILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU-
SAVING THE COMMITTEE'S TIME
GIVEN THAT WE DID HERE WITNESS
TESTIMONY ON THIS- THE LAST
TIME SO. LET ME ASK A MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ON THE
LINE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PRESS ONE
THEN FZERO. WILL GO TO LINE ONE
ZERO EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN
AGAIN WANT TO EAT THE LINE IS
OPEN. SEPTEMBER TOP OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN THE FOR. THANK YOU
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT FOR NEXT
PERSON. I IN A FIFTY EIGHT WILL
BE NEXT. LINE FIVE EIGHT WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN. THE COLOR
BARS WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
FAMILY ON THE PART OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND A ONE MOMENT FOR
NEXT PERSON IN Q. THAT'LL BE
LINE ONE FORTY TWO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE ONE FORTY TO THE
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY NAME IS
MARY JO BARRICADE JOB REPRESENT
BE GOLDEN STATE MANY FACTORS
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE IT WENT OVER
THE BASIN FOR MOBILE HOME
HOMEOWNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT. THIS
THE OUT TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND WE MOVE ON NEXT TO LINE.
ONE FORTY FOUR. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ONE FORTY FOR THE LINE
IS OPEN. PART THIS IS BOOK
APPEARS FROM OF SOUNDING BOARD
MEMBER ROBERT BROWN HOUSE
MEMBER OF LOS THE COMMISSION
AND SHARE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. COMMITTEE COMMISSION ON
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE MOVE
NEXT TO LINE THIRTY SIX LINE
THIRTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE. HELLO AND WHEN THE LAST
SECOND AND VANISHED COMMUNITY
HOUSING. CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE BILL IN MY- THERE ARE A
LOT HER FOR- UNDERSTANDING THE
NEED AND ACTING ON. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WEEK- TWO LINES SIXTY
TWO LINES STICKS TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS THERE
A LOCAL BE AND I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. THE MASS.
ACTUALLY DO HAVE SOMEONE HERE
IN THE IN THIS CHAMBER- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THE BILL YES MARK STIVERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN FULL FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- LET ME ASK
THE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK
IF THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO ONE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE.
OKAY THAT CONCLUDES THE
TESTIMONY THIS TIME A
COLLEAGUES ANY COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THANK
YOU MISTER. CHAIRMAN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL I
APPRECIATED HER RECYCLING THE
TESTIMONY FROM WITNESSES- FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR I WOULD JUST
RECYCLE MY OWN COMMENTS AT THE
SAME TIME- I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATION HAPPY TO MOVE
IT I DEFINITELY BELIEVE IT AT
THEIR NO PERSON SHOULD BE
HOMELESS- IN OUR STATE NOR THIS
BILL TAKE A NAP. FOR
UNDERSTANDABLE. SUPPORTING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IS A NO
EXCLUSIVE THE FACT THAT OUT
REALLY THERE REALLY SHOULD BE
ANYONE LIVING OUTDOORS IN A IN
A NATION AS AS WEALTHY AS ARE
SO- JUST ONE OF THOSE COMMENTS
THAT HAPPENED IT WAS THE BILL-
THEIR POSITION TO THE OFFICE
GREAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND I WILL SAIL RECYCLE
WELL I'M A BREAK ONE NEW KIND
OF THE WHAT I'M INTEREST IS SET
I WAS HAPPY. ANOTHER TO THIS
BILL. WHEN I CAN THROUGH A
COMMITTEE. PART OF BECAUSE OF
HOW IMPORTANT IS ALSO PART OF
APPRECIATION FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DID WITH OUR STAFF I THANK
MY CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR ALL HER
WORK ON THIS- YOU KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK BY EVERYONE- AND-
WE NEED FULL SOLUTIONS RUN
HOMELESSNESS AND I THINK THIS
REFLECTS THAT. OF THE NEW THING
I WANT TO SAY IT IS JUST LAST
WEEK THERE WERE ECONOMIST THAT
ARE. BECAUSE IT ENDEMIC.
HOMELESSNESS VERY WELL MADE FOR
AT LEAST. PERCENT IN
CALIFORNIA. THE ESTIMATES ARE A
POTENTIAL INCREASE OF 4250%
AROUND THE COUNTRY. ARE DUE TO
RISING UNEMPLOYMENT. BEIN WITH
STEVE HOUSING COSTS. WE'VE GOT
TO TACKLE HOMELESSNESS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND I THINK THIS
BRINGS A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
IT SO WITH THAT. AND MOVED
FORWARD SO WITH THAT AND LESTER
ANY FINAL COMMENTS- MADAM
OTHER. ANY FURTHER COMMENTS I
THINK YOU'D CHAIR AND-
OBVIOUSLY LEASES YOUR STAFF HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN US HAS BEEN SUPER
DILIGENT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND ENERGY THE BILL OF
THIS MAGNITUDE HAS TAKEN AND
WILL BE FOREVER GRATEFUL AND
YES I SHE SAID. THIS NEW
EPIDEMIC IS RATED NOT JUST
EVERY ATION OF HOW MANY
FAMILIES ARE TWO ONE PAYCHECK
FROM BEING HOMELESS WHICH IS
WHY A SYSTEM SUCH AS WITH
PREVENTION. MARGIN THEIR ENEMY
DEPARTMENT THING IS IMPORTANT.
THIRTY FIVE STUDIES FIVE I'M
SHELTER PEOPLE DIE EVERY DAY IN
THE US. AND IT TAKES TO LIVE A
BETTER BE IF LESS THAN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS SHORTER. FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. AS A STATE WE HAVE
RALLIED AROUND THE RIGHT TO
CLEAN WATER AIR EDUCATION AND
HEALTHCARE. WE SAID AGGRESSIVE
GHG GOALS AND HAS SEEN GREAT
SUCCESS IN ACHIEVING OUR GOALS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO ESTABLISH
HOUSING IS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
FOR. NEED TO THE CALIFORNIA
WILL NO LONGER LEAD. LEAD AND
POVERTY ARE NEGLECT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN IDOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL HI SHEILA
BY DEEP. DEEP BY GABRIEL GLORIA.
I KILEY. KILEY NOT VOTING WE
MOAN. MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA I. YOUR MEASURE HAS
THE VOTES TO MOVE OUT BUT WE
WILL WAIT ON FOR OTHER ADD ONS.
I THINK WE ARE ACTUALLY WE HAVE
WE DIDN'T HAVE A NUMBER OF
AUTHORS AND I APPRECIATE THAT A
NUMBER OF AUTHORS OF COMMA
THINK WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
FILE WATER AND LESS AND EIGHTY
AUTHORS HAVE TO GO. IMMEDIATELY
IF THAT'S OKAY. TO FILE ITEM
FIVE MISTER TING. GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ALSO I WANT TO
THANK ON YOU AS WELL AS YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HELP WITH THE BE THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO- CURRENTLY WE KNOW
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS GOVERN
ABOUT 25% OF THE EXISTING
HOUSING. THAT THIRTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIA LIVE
IN A HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION DUE
TO A LOOPHOLE IN STATE LAW H.
AWAY IS ANOTHER COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE ALLOWED TO
PROHIBIT OR LIMIT HOMEOWNERS
FROM RENTING OUT THEIR HOMES.
SO WE WHO AB THIRTY ONE IT TO A
MAN'S THE DAVIS STIRLING ACT TO
A LOT OF AND LIMIT THE AREAS WE
ARE H. OKAY AN INTEREST. AND
LIMIT THE AREA WHERE THE AND
LET RENTER. WE'VE HAD GOOD
DISCUSSION WITH THE CAL SOURCE
IN AND CAL SO CA. OF THE
COMMUNITY MANAGERS WE WERE
UNABLE TO REACH AGREEMENT BUT
THE- TALKS HAVE GONE VERY WELL
AND DISSIPATE BEING ABLE TO.
REACH AGREEMENT ON THE VERY
VERY NEAR FUTURE. BUT THAT. WAS
FIRST BUT WE OFFER AYE VOTE
AGAIN WE THINK THAT THIS
CLOSING THIS LEUPOLD VERY
IMPORTANT SO THAT PROPERTY
OWNERS CAN OFFER. THEIR HOMES
AS A RENTAL PROPERTY IN
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS FOR
THEIR CURRENTLY BANNED. THANK
YOU MUCH. META MODERATOR WHEN
WE GO FIRST TO- WITNESS NUMBER
ONE FOR THE SUPPORT LUIS MERON
TAY FROM CALIFORNIA BE
TESTIFYING BY PHONE. TORONTO
AIRLINES OPEN. HI THIS IS
LOOKING YOU CAN HEAR ME SURE
CAN. HI A GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK HEREMISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE- INCLUDES MONT THEM
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BE I THINK THAT THE
MEMBER CAN GET A WONDERFUL JOB
EXPLAINING WHAT SB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO DID- SO I THINK I'LL
BUT MY REMARKS SHORT BUT HAVE.
JIM THE EXPLAINED WE'RE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL HI MY
RESPONSE RATE TODAY- CALIFORNIA
BE ADVOCATES FOR AN END TO
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS ONE
THAT YOU KNOW IT ARE IN STARK
CLARITY OVER. EIGHTY THIRTY BY
ALLOWING RENDER THE OPTION OF
LIVING IN A WITH COMING OUT OF
THE NAY AWAY BY THE LARGEST IN
CRITICAL STEP TO OPEN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE PORTABLE
HOW COMMUNITIES ACROSS HELP BUT
H. AWAY IT CAN WORK THAT BY
DANNY KIND OF THE TOP TEN RIGHT
AND IT THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING ONLY OCCUPIED. REVENUE
OF THE PROBLEM IS ALL THE MORE.
AS THREE TO THE KEVIN MAKE
INCREASE HOMELESSNESS BY 40%
THE UNITED STATES. IT'S LIKELY
THIS PROBLEM IN H. AWAY IS
GROWING TO. RECENT RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT 8% OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT AND THEM SOME FORM
OF AN H. O. AT IMAGINE IF
INSTEAD OF. THE GOVERNMENT A
PUBLIC LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTED
RULES THAT BAND SENATE. SUCH A
POLICY WOULD BE UNFATHOMABLE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT PRIVATE
GOVERNMENT HAVE THE RIGHT TODAY
TO DO THAT. AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO WOULD RELIEVE THE
PRESSURE THAT MANY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS STATE AND HELP
CALIFORNIA ABOUT. WE GROUP.
CALIFORNIA SOLVING. THE PART OF
ITS PLAN FOR ECONOMIC WITH
SEVEN NINETY FOR THAT REASON
CALIFORNIANS OR DID YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU LET ME ASK THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK FOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME EXPRESS
AT SPORT. CERTAINLY TWENTY
GERMAN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ONE EIGHT TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PRESSONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT WILL BE JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE FOR FIRST.
INDIVIDUAL. AND HER TO GO TO
THE LINE OF ONE ZERO FIVE ONE
ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE CANNOT CONTACT THE DAIRY
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. AT THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER ONE FIVE TWO
ONE ONE FIVE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY THE- EVERY FOOTBALL
COUNTY YES AND MY BACKYARD IN
SUPPORT. AND A COUPLE TO MY
NUMBER ONE FOUR EIGHT ONE NINE
ONE FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS RARELY EVER ON
A WITH JIM JUST GO AND I'D LIKE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE INITIAL
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THE TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE SHOWING SUPPORT AT THE
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME WHEN WE GO TO THE
OPPOSITION- MODERATE MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE-
ALLOW LOUIS BROWN IN THE
COMMUNITY SAYS. INSTITUTE TO
SPEAK. GERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOWER BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE.
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE ONE EIGHT TWO- FIRST OF
ALL LET ME START BY. FIRST MY
APPRECIATION FOR THE TIME THAT-
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IS PUT INTO
THIS AS WELL AS THE AUTHORS
OFFICE IN WORKING WITH US ON
THIS ISSUE- WE TAKE THE ISSUE
OF TENANCY- VERY SERIOUSLY- BUT
AS WRITTEN TODAY AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES- FOR FIRST. HOME BUYERS
VETERANS SENIOR SEEKING
MORTGAGES. AND ANY OTHERS THAT
ARE SEEKING FEDERALLY INSURED
ALONI LENDING PROGRAMS FHA VA
IN PARTICULAR HAVE VERY
SPECIFIC LINDEN REQUIREMENTS
AND THRESHOLDS WHEN IT COMES.
OWNER OCCUPANCY- REQUIREMENTS
THEY LOOK TO COME TO ME
PROJECTS THEY LOOK TO EIGHT
DAYS I TO BE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR FIRST TIME HOME
BUYER BUT THEY WILL USUALLY. OF
FOR ALL FIND OUT. BASED ON. CAN
RENTAL TENNESSEE OWNER RATES-
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICER TRIED TO
ADDRESS THIS SSUE- FRANKLY WE
DON'T SEE THE LAW AS WRITTEN IS
HAVING A LOOPHOLE IT WAS
STRATEGICALLY CREATED TO
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ASSOCIATINS TO ABIDE BY
FEDERAL REGULATIONS PRIVATE
LENDING INSTITUTIONS AND ALSO
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY A FOR
RENT TO OCCUR- WELL IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE COMMUNITY. WE
LOOK FOR CHANGE WE DO. HAS
WRITTEN TODAY THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE MORE PROBLEMS THAN IT
SEEKS TO SOLVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
SPEAK- MATTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE- ALLOW THEM TO DO
SO. GENTLEMEN ARE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION OF BILL. AB THREE
ONE EIGHT TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO SHIP
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE SHOWING UP AT ALL ONE
MOMENT PLEASE- WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE ZERO FIVE LIVE
ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I ADDED TO SEE MY TO **** AGAIN
AND- ACTUALLY YOU CAN TREAT THE
POOR. ON HAPPENED THAT COULD BE
A COLLECTION. ONCE AGAIN TO
SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE TO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS. SEE NOT I WANT TO
THANK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS BILL- I WANT TO SAY I DO
APPRECIATE- THE QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT HOW THIS MEASURE MIGHT
AFFECT FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES-
I DO KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR IS
LOOKING INTO THIS TO ME. THAT
THESE ISSUES DON'T HOLD UP I
HAVE A SPORT RECOMMENDATION FOR
THE BILL I. LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS OTHERS RUNNING AGAIN TO
ADDRESS THIS BUT WE NEED TO
STATIONS LIKE FOR TO ADDRESS
OUR STATE CRISIS IN WITH THAT-
LOOK FOR TO SUPPORTING THE
BILL. SAYS AND WHAT. THE
QUESTION. BUT TO REITERATE. THE
PRE THAT THE AUTHOR MAY. YEAH I
BELIEVE IN THIS. ABOUT THIS IS
NOT APPLICABLE TO- TENDENCIES
OF LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS.
THAT'S RIGHT THERE THANK YOU
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION. I IT'S
VERY. IT'S VERY CLEARLY STATED.
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO
H. AWAYS ABOUT WANT TO- BAND.
THE RENT SHORT TERM RENTALS OF
UNDER THIRTY DAYS THANK YOU.
BUT I THINK THAT FURTHER
UNDERLINES THE FOCUS OF THE
BILL WHEN IT COMES TO PADDLE.
TENNIS RENTERS. FOR HOME A LOT
THEY ARE IMPACTED BY THE HOUSE
CRISIS. WE SHOULD HAVE. BEEN
MOTION WITH THE BILL SECOND.
THERE'S A SECOND UNLESS ANY
FINAL COMMENTS MR TANK HAPPY
FEET OF MAKE A CLOSE YAK AGAIN
UP APPRECIATE OPTED TO PAY FOR
HIS PATIENT OF. THE OPPOSITION
WE FOR IN BE ABLE TO. AGREEMENT
WITH THEM WE UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONCERNS AROUND FINANCING AND
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT TO GET YOU FOR ALL YOUR
HELP FOR THIS BILL TO. THANK
YOU AND A WITH THAT THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS ON- MISTER TAX
BILL. FILE IN FIVE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SHE'LL HI JILL I
DEEP. GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA
GLORIA AYE AYE KILEY KILEY NO
LIMON LIMON I MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM SECTOR WHAT'S
THE CARVE OUT. FOUR EYES- ONE
NO. WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL ADULTS WITHOUT A
LIKE TO INVITE UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL. THE
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON THE OFFICIAL MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO. I
THINK THE COMMITTEE AND THE AND
THE CHAIRED EVERYBODY ELSE ALL
THE WORK- HAS GONE INTO THIS
BILL I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY A BILL
THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE A NET
GAME AND HOUSING STE COLLUDING
ADDITIONAL NEW HOUSING FOR
INCOMING LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
LOT HOUSING INVENTORY PROBLEM
DECK IN THE MAKING. THEY KEEP.
THAT IT THAT HAS JUST BEGUN
EVEN WORSE. WITH COVERT. MY
BILL INCREASES HOUSING
INVENTORY BY CREATING
STREAMLINED MINISTRIAL
APPROVAL PROCESS TO INCENTIVIZE
PROJECT DEVELOPERS TO CREATE
HOUSING FROM PROPERTIES ALREADY
BUILT IN ZONE TO HOUSE PEOPLE'S
FORMER. AND MOTELS.
TRANSITIONING BUT TELLS IN
MOTELS INTO MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING HAS SEVERAL ADVANTAGES
THEY ARE GENERALLY LOCATED IN
HEAVY JOB AREAS ALL THE MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HUMAN.
LIVING IS ALREADY IN PLACE AND
RESOURCE IMPACTS FOR WATER AIR
QUALITY IN SEWAGE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN PLANNED FOR. THIS PROPOSAL
KEEPS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS TO
A MINIMUM BY ENSURING THESE
PROJECTS DO NOT EXTEND PAST
THEIR ORIGINAL FOOT PRINT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF ACCOMMODATING
FOR NEW BUILDING AND THAT
EIGHTY A STANDARDS. OH OKAY
PLAN UNTIL THE MOTELS INTERNAL
OPERATIONS SO THAT THEY ARE NOT
PROVIDING SHELTER TO. ANYONE
LET ALONE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WILL NOT BE JUST
TURNED OUT ONTO THE STREETS.
BECAUSE OF THIS PROJECT
AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE A NET GAIN IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RESOURCES
AND WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT ANY PROPERTY WOULD
HAVE TO BE VACANT FOR AT LEAST
SIX MONTHS IN ORDER TO REMOVE
THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO SHUT
DOWN THESE HOTELS AND MOTELS.
DURING TO OUR LIST. WOULD BE
WAIVED HOWEVER FOR ANY PROJECT
AS A 100% AFFORDABLE. I'VE ALSO
WORKED WITH OUR SPONSOR TO
ENSURE A SET ASIDE FOR ALL
PROJECTS OF AT LEAST 5% FOR
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME IN MOVING
THIS IMPORTANT HOUSING IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
BILL FORWARD. WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS CARLTON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PART
ASSOCIATION AND PATRICK. SABLE
HOW. COUNSEL FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THANK YOU MUCH OUR TO
OUR MODERATOR. ASK IF WE CAN
IDENTIFY WITH HIS NUMBER ONE
PATRICK SAFE HOUSE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS-
PATRICK SAY WELL SOME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE-
CALIFORNIA. COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WHICH
CONSISTS OF THE FOR PROFIT
NONPROFIT THE- DEVELOP THE
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS- THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- THE- GAME DID
ASSISTING IN THE EXPANSION OF
BOOK BEFORE HEALTH. I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THE WE WERE
RUSSIA THANK YOU TOLD TO. OF ME
EGGMAN BILL OF THE PROCESS OF
BOOKING CONVERTING UP MOTEL AD
HOTEL FACILITIES- TO SERVE VOTE
THE HOMELESS AND OTHER PEOPLE
IN NEED OF A- HOUSING- THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES- A WARNING LABEL.
LATER A GROUP. HEARD TO ASSIST
THE DEVELOPING A NEW YOU THAT
WILL SERVE THE HOMELESS IN LOS
AND THE OF THE OF A TRIED TO
SET A CEILING ON ON THEIR
DEVELOPMENT COSTS SO THAT- THEY
THEY THEY TRY TO KEEP WITHIN
THE SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT- IN
THE CONSTRUCTION DIFFICULTIES
OF COURSE- OR FACING ANYONE NOW
IN THE DEVELOPMENT BUSINESS-
BECAUSE OF THE BOOK THE LACK OF
BOTH OF THE WORK FOR TO MEET
ALL. CAPTION THE- WE ALL WANT.
FORWARD BUT BUT HE IF YOU
THOUSAND A YEAR WERE WERE LOW
AT AT TO AGO MANY OF THE UNITS
WILL COME ON LINE AND SO WE ARE
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
MISS SEGMENT IS TRYING TO DO
WHICH WOULD ALLOW YOU TO DO
CONVERSIONS AT A AT A MORE
EFFICIENT COST AND MUCH QUICKER
IN TERMS OF WITH THE- PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE THE FOR THE
HOMELESS THE SACRAMENTO AND
THEN- ELSEWHERE THROUGHOUT THE-
CALIFORNIA SO- WE ARE WE TO
ENDORSE THE IN SUPPORT. THE
BILL. TWENTY FIVE IT THE
REQUESTED ARRIVAL THANK YOU FOR
ROAD CONSIDERING MY VIEWS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO NOW TO
WITNESS NUMBER TOO DIFFICULT
AND FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
A DIFFICULTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AGAIN WE REPRESENT
FIFTY THOUSAND FOR PROFIT AND
NONPROFIT. RIDER EVERYTHING
FROM SMALL LARGER PART. AND OF
COURSE AS YOU KNOW TO MEET OUR
HOUSING CRISIS WE NEED A NOVEL
HOUSING SOLUTIONS AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY JEFF THAT BUT ALL
THE STATE HAS MADE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS WE WERE
THERE ARE STILL MANY OF LOCAL
BARRIERS INCLUDING DELAYS AND
DUPLICATIVE WITH THAT LIMIT.
PRODUCTION ARE WE NEED UNIT FOR
ALL INCOME LEVELS VERY LOW LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING THE
BILL PROVIDES UNITS AT ALL OF
THESE LEVELS. THE CITY. GET
BACK THAT NOT MY IT'S LIKE A
OUR EVERYONE ON THE CALL TO
PLEASE BUTTE YOUR PHONE. DO YOU
DO FOR THE LAST PLEASE ME YOUR
PHONE. HI THERE WE GO THE YOU
KNOW THE COST TO BUILD HOUSING
FROM THE GROUND UP IS EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE AND TAKES YEARS YOU
KNOW THE MOST CHALLENGING PART
OF THE CONSTRUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT IT CAN TAKE
AS LONG AS TEN YEARS TO GET A
PROJECT BELT THAT'S SO
UNREASONABLE. AND A COUGH
CERTAINLY THE BAY AREA IS
APPROACHING A THOUSAND DOLLARS
A SQUARE FOOT BY ENCOURAGING WE
HAVE BEEN CONTINUED RE USE OF
OLDER HOTELS AND MOTELS THAT.
OTHERWISE BE TORN DOWN ON THIS
BILL WOULD HELP GET HOUSING
ONLINE SOONER YEAH AT A MORE
REASONABLE CAUGHT. I KNOW THE
ALL EXCEPT OF MANY AMENDMENTS
AND IS CONTINUING TO WORK WITH-
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
HAS- THE STILL- STATED SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS- I KNOW WE
DON'T- CREATE SOLUTIONS LIKE
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY WE'RE GOING
TO SEE THE- OLDER HOTELS
REMOVED. I KNOW WE'VE SEEN THAT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WITH LARGE
HOTEL COMPLETELY REYES. AND I
FEAR IF- WE CAN'T FIND SOME OF
THE- CLARIFICATION FOR THE
OPPOSITION. BUT WILL JUST
SIMPLY LOSE MORE HOTELS HOUSING
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE
MOST. WE CAN'T CONTINUE WITH
THE ALL OR NOTHING APPROACH TO
HOUSING IT'S FUN REALISTIC. AND
WILL ONLY LEAD TO OUR CONTINUED
HOUSING CRISIS FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
YOU MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THEY
WISH TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
ACTION WILL START HERE IN
CHAMBER WITH THE ONE INDIVIDUAL.
MISTER MARTIN. MARK ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION OUR POSITION IS
SUPPORT IF AMENDED IF THE
PERCENTAGE OF LOW INCOME- UNITS
WOULD BE COULD BE INCREASED WE
DO APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES A
MEMBERS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING A LOOK AT THOSE AND
PERHAPS MODIFYING OUR POSITION
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NOW LET'S GO BACK TO THE
PHONE NINE MISTER MODERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FIVE EIGHT ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE NOT
SHOWING SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND YOU'VE CUED UP PLEASE
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO ONCE
AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WILL GO TO MY
NUMBER ONE SIX ZERO ONE ONE SIX
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DON'T
OF STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT AND-
HOPEFULLY WILL STAY IN SUPPORT
AND- AMENDED. WELL EXCLUDE OUR
MEMBERS FROM DOING ITS WORK
THANK. LOCAL TO LIGHT NUMBER
THIRTY ONE ALIGN THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I TRACY
RIGHT WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
WEAPONS OF CALIFORNIA OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS TAKEN A
COURT IN HEART CONDITION. WE
APPRECIATE HIS. TO WORK WITH
THAT TO ENSURE THAT WE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
SUCCESSFULLY OPERATIONALIZED
THE DOW THANK YOU. NEXT PHOTO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT ONE
FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE NATIONAL. OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. NEXT
OPEN THE LINE UP TO ONE SIXTY
ONE LINE ONE SIX ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SELECT THE MILLIONS OF
MONEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND WE WITH- RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
STUFF. YEAH NEXT TO OPEN A LINE
OF ONE ZERO TWO ONE ONE ZERO TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE ONE
ZERO TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BUT NO RESPONSE WILL CLOSE YOUR
LINE. NEXT WELL TO LINE NUMBER
ONE SEVEN SIX ONE ONE SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS LIZ MANTE
WITH CALIFORNIAN BE OUR SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY ARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DID AGAIN DOG
ABOUT TODD CO A NONPROFIT
HOUSING PROVIDER NOW BECAUSE
SHE GROUP- IN STRONG SUPPORT
ONE EFFECT AS I CAN FOR HER AT
THIS YEAR'S ALL. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO LINE NUMBER SIXTIES
GIVE ME SIXTY LINE SIX ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS STILL BE FOR
OUR IN BEHALF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. NEXT OPEN LINE OF ONE
SIX THREE NINE ONE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
REMEMBER THE POLY FOR MANY DAY
HAS TO SUPPLY HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NEXT OPEN
THE LINE OF LINE FORTY TWO LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
WARRANTED LESS CARE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND WE
ACTUALLY HAD A RECORD IT'S
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL-
BUT WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND ALL THE WORK OF
THE- OFFERING HER STOP WE
REALLY APPRECIATE AND THE
SPECIFIC. TO ALLOW AND LOCAL
ORDINANCES THAT ALREADY EXIST
NOT TO BE NOT TO BE A GREAT BY
THE VISION OF THE- WHAT THAT WE
WILL BE PLEASED. PARTY THAT
SOMETHING. NOT OPEN LINE OF ONE
THING SEVEN. ONE ONE SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KATIE ON HERE AND WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LABORS WE HAVE MOVED TO A
POSITION OF SUPPORT IT'S
AMENDED TO INCLUDE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE PROFICIENT.
THANK YOU. NOT TO OPEN A LINE
OF LINE NINETY TWO ONE NINE TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NINETY TWO YEAR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
RELEASE THE LINE. NEXT CALL TO
LINE UP A ONE EIGHT ZERO ONE
ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBER ADAM RIGHTLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. INITIAL SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE ON SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE- I APOLOGIZE WE
DO HAVE TO LIMIT TO FEW DOT.
ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY NINETY TWO YEAR MY
OPEN. MORAN WITH THE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA ARE TALKING
ASSOCIATION TO COURT. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE TWENTY PART
PLEASE CONTINUE SIR THANK YOU
ONE WE NOW GO TO THE
OPPOSITION. THE FIRST WITNESS
WILL BE WATCH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS SPEAKING ON
THE MICROPHONE MR WATCH. IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER SCOTT WHAT
YOU'LL BE HAVE THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION- WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK WE- THAT THE COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHORHAVE SHOWN IN
THE PROGRESS. WE SHARE THE
GOALS AND THE AIMS OF THE BILL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION- WITH
THE AUTHORS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME ASK IF SURE REPORT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA. VERSION FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING IS ON THE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR. YES HI-
ACCUSED CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
SURE REPORT WITH CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING GOOD
AFTERNOON CSA TO THE NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WORKING TO FALL
HOMELESSNESS AND LEAVE MY
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY AND LATIN AND- IN
THE PAST THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TREATED EXEMPTION FOR.
STREAMLINING AS AN INCENTIVE TO
ACHIEVE A STRONG PUBLIC GOOD
AND WE SEE THIS BILL IN AND
ATTENDED- DEPARTURE FROM THIS
POLICY CURRENTLY THE STATE AND
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
WORKING TOWARD PLACING THE-
BORN IN SIX. AND MOTEL TO
SAFEGUARD THESE A FROM COVETING
THIS POLICY HAVE THE GOAL OF
ACQUIRING MANY OF IS NOT COME
INTO TERM HOUSING. AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT WOULD CREATE AN INCENTIVE
FOR DEVELOPERS ACROSS THE STATE
TO PURCHASE THESE MOTELS
POTENTIALLY DRIVING UP COSTS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE BILL I
COULD RESULT IN PLACEMENT OF
THOUSANDS OF HOUSEHOLDS WERE
SHELTERING IN MOTELS BECAUSE OF
THEIR OWN ABILITY TO COPE IT.
EXIT THIS PLACE THOUSANDS MORE
WHO LIVE IN MOTELS BECAUSE THEY
ARE HOMELESS OR WHO CAN'T GET
INTO HOUSING IN THE PRIVATE
MARKET BECAUSE OF POOR CREDIT
OR FIX OUR PATH JEFF. THE
REASON AMENDMENTS HAVING A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHERE
DEVELOPERS COULD BE BUILDING
HOUSING FOR SIXTY TO EIGHTY-
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PERCENT- A IN MY AREA MEDIAN
INCOME. WOULD RESULT IN
DISPLACEMENT OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
ARE ABOUT THE LOW INCOME
THRESHOLD. UNFORTUNATELY AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY CURRENTLY
DOES NOTHING TO PROTECT THE
RESIDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. EVEN RECENT
AMENDMENTS ARE UNLIKELY TO
PROTECT PEOPLE CURRENTLY
RESIDING IN THE IT'S NOT
SPELLED. AS MOST CURRENT
RESIDENTS ARE WELL BELOW THE
INCOME LEVEL AND DEVELOPERS
COULD DISPLACED RESIDENTS
OPPOSE BOTH EVEN COME AT THAT
ARE BELOW THESE INCOME LEVEL.
TO CONVERT HOUSE. THERE ARE NO
KERN PROTECTIONS THE BILL. I
PREFER THE ADDRESS. WE HOPE TO
COME TO WORK WITH THE SAN
MEMBER STAFF ON AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY TWO AND NOT ALL OF THE
TWO EXCEPTIONS THE LAST. NAME
LINE THE CONVERSION MOTELS FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING ARE AT RISK
OF. AND REQUESTED THE FALL ON
MEN AND- WOMEN THE STREAMLINED
MINISTER VIEW TOO MUCH TALKING
FOR. AND WHICH HUNG PERCENT OF
THE UNITS ARE FOR BOTH LOWER
INCOME. AND A SICKENING PORTION
OF THE UNITS ARE AFFORDABLE TO
THE HOUSEHOLD EXPERIENCING OR
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS.
REQUIRE THAT ANY EXISTING
RESIDENT WE THE LOCATION OF THE
SPENT DURING THE REHABILITATION
PROCESS AND IS OFFERED A RIGHT
TO RETURN TO THE PERMANENT UNIT
EVENT TAKE FOR. THE AMENDMENTS
WOULD CHANGE THE BILL TO
ACHIEVE THE STRONG PUBLIC GOOD
THAT IT'S BEEN TYPICAL OF- FROM
THE PATH. LISTEN LEARN CAN'T.
WITHOUT THESE AMENDMENTS AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY WOULDN'T
CHEAT THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY AT
A TIME WHEN THE STATE COULD BUY
TO STRESS MOTELS AT A LOWER
COST BY DRIVING MORE
COMPETITION FOR THE PROPERTY.
IT WOULD FURTHER DISPLACED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE AN ART RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE YOUR NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE WE GO
NOW TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT OPPOSE THIS BILL LET'S
START WITH. I WITNESSES HERE IN
THIS CHAMBER IF I COULD ASK THE
FIRST INDIVIDUAL IF EVERYONE
COULD. TELL US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND EXPRESS YOUR
OPPOSITION. MY NAME IS MIKE
LAST I REPRESENT THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS RENDON
DISCOUNTS THE SIXTEEN PAINTERS
LOCAL FORTY SEVEN WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES. NOT
POSSESS THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
MY NAME IS ROBERT COOK SOME
WISHY METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE
OH FOUR AS A BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT REPRESENTATIVE WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALEX
LANCE BURKE WITH IBEW LOCAL SIX
SENDING REGARDS FROM BUSINESS
MANAGER JOHN DORY HERE IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION
WORKER SHOULDN'T BE. PUSHED
INTO POVERTY TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HELLO TIM
SLEEP SHE MIGHT WORKERS LOCAL
ONE OF FOUR WE STATE WHAT STATE
BUILDING TRADE IN OPPOSITION
WAS AMENDED THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CAN FOR A SECOND
DIRECTOR SECONDS HERE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
OPPOSITION UNTIL FURTHER
AMENDED THANK YOU. HELLO
MITCHELL BACK- THE IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION UNTIL AMENDED.
HELLO GERRY WOULD OCCUR. ARE
YOU PHD AND MY STAFF WE STAND
WITH THE- STATE BUILDING TRADES.
IN A POST THANK YOU. LET ME NOW
GO TO THE TELEPHONE FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE SO. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION YOU WILL ONE THEN
VERO WILL GO TO ONE NINETY
THREE AGAIN THAT IS LINE NINE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTER NOON. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ROBERT SMITH
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX WE
STAND OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURED-
DUE TO THE FACT THAT IT IS THE
LACK SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE WHICH INVOLVED IN IT
YEAH. THE NEW CONSTRUCTION
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT QUEUE
LINE SIXTY FOUR THAT IS LINE
SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME HER NESTLE
MEDRANO WITH THE LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTIES BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. AND REPRESENTING FORTY
NINE LOCAL DISTRICT COUNCILS ON
CALIFORNIA AND I AM EXPRESSING
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PENDING
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WILL BE GOING TO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN AGAIN THAT IS LINE
SIX SEVEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE SIX SEVEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. I CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE CREEK MARK NOW
THEY HAVE A HOUSING CALIFORNIA
AND- OPPOSED LOOKING MENDED TO
THE REASONS AND THE SUPPORT IT.
YOU NEXT WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE BEGIN THAT IS LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE IT'LL BE
JUST ONE MOMENT. ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY
FIVE A LINE IS OPEN ONE MOMENT.
THANK YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE MAP RIGHT
HERE ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA. BACK TO OPPOSITION
WHAT A LINER COMMENT- WITH
MISTER WATCH AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU. NEXT
MINUS ONE SEVENTY SEVEN THAT IS
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS TROY TURNS LOW WHO
DISTRICT OPAL SIXTEEN CRATERS
KNOWLEDGE VERY. STRONG
OPPOSITION. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE SEVEN
FOR THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU CAN HEAR YEAH ONE
THANK YOU. THIS IS ONE CALDERON
WITH THE U. R. U. P. EIGHTY
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
NOWHERE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
UNLESS OTHER IT WILL OTHERWISE
MENDED. I WILL GO NEXT TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THAT IS LINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THE LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS ANTHONY
WATER FROM A BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN- FLOOR LAYERS
LOCAL TWELVE AND WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION AND LET THE BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU. NEXT TO ONE.
THIRTY EIGHT THAT IS ONE ONE
THREE EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ANGELA THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STRUCTURE TRADE
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED. AND THE LINE THIRTY
FIVE THAT IS LINE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS ANTONIO CONSCIOUS WITH IBEW
LOCAL ELEVEN O'CLOCK TURN TO
THE WE OPPOSED OCCURRED THANK
YOU. AND LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO THAT IS LINE ONE SICK
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS ON YOU
LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
AND I'M ON POVERTY THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE- WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE. AND IT FOR MANY
DIFFERENT REASONS SHERMAN PART
DATED. AND WE'LL GO NEXT IN
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
THAT IS LINE ONE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS BRETT DAVIS
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN GLAZERS LOCAL SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE. AND WE STAND WITH
HE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY AND AMENDED. WE GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT THAT IS LINE ONE SEVEN
EACH PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH JOHN
POPPER FURTHER TO MORE RESEARCH
WAS GIVEN. THE TO PLAY COUNSEL
ALSO REPRESENT THE Q. THIRTEEN
OVER. WE ARE LOOKING YOUR DAY
AND OFTEN OR WHAT ARE THE. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO MY ONE IN EACH
EIGHT THAT IS LINE THANK PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
WILLIAM ALWAYS DISTRICT THE
PAINTERS DRIVEWAY FINISHER
LOCAL SO AND WE STAND WITH
BUILDINGS NOT. UNLESS SOMEONE.
THANK YOU. ALONG WITH AYE YOU
PHD LOCAL UNION TWELFTH FLOOR
COVERS AND WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR THAT IS FINE ONE
EACH FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JOHN TWEED DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN GLAZERS LOCAL.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN. WE STAND. IN
OPPOSITION. AND LET THE BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WILL BE GOING TO MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THAT IS LINE ONE SEVEN ZERO I
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE SEVEN
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TWO
CHAIR MEMBER TERAFLOPS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING A
LETTER IN IN TIME WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES AND IN
OPPOSITION AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THE AUTHOR IS WORKING TO WORK
OUT AMENDMENT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THAT. THANK YOU. NO
NOW IN THE QUEUE AT THIS PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF. IT THIS TIME LET US BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION. MISS QUIRK SILVA.
ONE OF PSYC THANK THE OFFER OF
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND-
TO ALL OF OUR BUILDING TRADE
HONORABLE FRIENDS THAT TIME WE
ARE ALWAYS HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
THE CRITICAL FACTOR THAT MAKES
ME MOVE TOWARDS SUPPORTING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. IS SIMPLY
WE ALREADY HAD A HOUSING CRISIS
BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT HOMES AND WE CAN
EXPECT EVEN MORE AFTER WE GET
BACK TO SOME KIND OF NORMALCY
AND AS MUCH AS- WE MIGHT. TO
GET BUILDING HOUSING WE SIMPLY
DO WE KNOW IT'S TAKING THREE
FOUR YEAR AND- ANY PROJECTS OFF
THE GROUND. AND WE ALSO HAVE
MANY PEOPLE EVEN IF THE PROJECT
GETS TO THE CITY- WHERE THEY
OPPOSE IT. SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
USING MOTELS AND HOTELS THERE
ALREADY AS WAS STATED- EXISTING
MOTELS AND HOTELS THAT ARE
BEING USED FOR. LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. OR INDIVIDUALS AND
SOME OF THEM ARE OPERATING THIS
WAY AS WELL WHAT. THE
CONVERSION OF THESE HOTELS
CERTAINLY- AND I DO ASK THE
MEMBER BRINGING THE LEGISLATION
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE TRADES. BUT WE KNOW
THAT IF WE DO NOTHING. WE DO
NOT THE WE HAVE THE EXPECTATION
THAT NOT ONLY WILL THINGS GET
WORSE WHAT WE KNOW THEY WILL IN
FACT AND ALL THE MEMBERS IN THE
TRADES AND OTHERS WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. I THINK
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT YOUR VERY
OWN COMMUNITIES YOUR LIVING IN
AND ASK YOURSELF HAS
HOMELESSNESS INCREASED. WHETHER
IT BE FOR VETERANS WHETHER IT
BE FOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN
FAMILIES INDIVIDUAL. AND IS
THAT IT. ALL OF DO IS WALK OUT
THIS IS GREAT BUILDING HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND WE HAVE PEOPLE
LIVING LITERALLY ON THE CAMPUS
OF THIS GREAT BUILDING THE
CAPITAL OF SACRAMENTO. WE
WALKED TWO TO THREE BLOCKS AWAY
AND WE SEE PEOPLE NOT ONLY
LIVING ON THE STREETS BUT LINE
ON CURBS WITH LITTLE POP UP
TENTS. IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ACCEPTABLE WE HAVE TO WORK
TOWARDS A SOLUTION AND EVERY
TIME WE SAY NO THEY'RE ALREADY
BEEN. TOLD COMMITTEE WITH. EVEN
FURTHER EXPENSES GO UP AND
PRETTY SOON WE BEAT THEM YOU
TO. WHAT I WE HAVE OUR- AND WE
ARE I SO I CERTAINLY ON OUR
ONLY SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT I'M
IT SO AND I ASKED OF US
TOGETHER INCLUDING. A HIGH
VALUED BUILDING TRADES TO WORK
WITH US TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS.
SO THERE'S BEEN A MOTION WITH
THIS FOR IS OUR SECOND. MISTER
GORE'S SECOND AND OTHER
COMMENTS MISTER GORE. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE BILL AUTHORED
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND OF BECAUSE
IT WAS MY IDEA WAS
REPRESENTATIVE MY STAFF- THAT
THEY HAD BEEN CHANGED POSITION-
FROM THE BUILDING TRADES- ON
THIS TICKET AND I HEARD THE
TESTIMONY ST IF MANDATE. YOU
KNOW IT IS OFTEN. I HAVE JUST
AS MEMBERS TO HAVE BUT CAN THAT
IS A MEMBER MAKING YOU TO. A
PERHAPS THE- LEADING GOOD
INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN HAS
CERTAINLY SET IN AN NOT AND
THINK YOU YES A THE TROOPS
COMMUNICATED WITH US YESTERDAY
THAT THE APPRECIATED. ALL THE
WORK WE PUT INTO IT AND THEY
WILL NOT BE OPPOSING NOT BE
OPPOSING TOMORROW COMPETE. BOTH
THE CABBIE OUT NEED TO KEEP
WORK SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED BETWEEN NOW YES YOU.
WAS THAT. CAN ALL OF US. AND
TODAY BUT ALSO I LIKE TO SPEAK
A LITTLE TO. WHAT WHAT THIS
BILL IS AND WHAT IT IS NOT SO
WHEN WE STARTED WITH THIS BILL-
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE FIRST
BILLS WE INTRODUCED THIS YEAR
AND LIKE ME MEMBERS WE HAVE THE
MOST BILLS WITH THOSE THAT WE
THINK ARE EX COVERAGE. SO I TO
MIDDLE BILLS YOU DEALING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS RELATES NOT
OFTENTIMES TO HOMELESSNESS
PEOPLE STREETS AND THEN THIS
HOUSING ONE WHICH THE OTHER
SIDE OF IT IT'S- PEOPLE. ALIVE
BUT THEY- PLACE FOR THE TO. SO
IN. SOME OF THE- LOW LOW INCOME
THE SPEAKING ABOUT THIS PEOPLE
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
WHAT DONE IN HERE THAT OF A
MOTEL OR HOTEL. FOR SIX MONTHS
IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS SO
PLACES USING PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
CAN BE USED SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
SB CERTIFIED THE HOTEL OR MOTEL.
SO WE WENT JUST FROM THIS BEING
A- YOU KNOW WITH WITH WITH NO
LABOR PROTECTIONS TO AS WE
BEGAN TO NEGOTIATE. A
PREVAILING WAGE HER. AND LET ME
ALSO SAY REMIND YOU AGAIN THAT
WE AVE DONE FIRST WE HAD 20%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE GOT UP
TO. FIFTEEN WITH 5% GOING TO
LOW LOW INCOME HOUSING AND THEN
WE WERE ASKED TO PUT IN SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE. SO WE
TOOK THAT AMENDMENT AS WELL SO
THAT'S ALSO BEEN THERE FOR
THESE PROJECTS. HOW 2% SKILLED
AND TRAINED PREVAILING WAGE. WE
SAID THE ONLY CAVEAT WOULD BE
IF SOMEONE WANTED TO DO THAT
SPOKE TO SOME OF THE OTHER-
OPPOSITION. A 100% AFFORDABLE
LOW INCOME HOUSING. THEN IT WAS
STILL THE PREVAILING WAGE BUT
THE NOT SKILLED AND TRAINED
JUST BECAUSE OF THE CAR WE HAVE
ALL TALKED ABOUT. ASSOCIATED
WITH BUILDING HOUSING AND JOB.
AND THEN. BASE COST WITH
DEALING WITH- VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSING. SO WE FEEL LIKE THAT'S
A PLACE AS A GOOD PLACE TO LAND
AND I GUESS AS MEMBERS WE GET
TO THE- RIGHT WE HAVE BEEN
ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE THE
CALIFORNIA. TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
WE HAVE ELECTED TO DO THAT AND
WE GET TO VOTE ON WHAT WE THINK
IS PUBLIC POLICY. WHEN
SOMETIMES THAT MEANS SAYING NO
TO OUR FRIENDS AND IF WE CAN'T
SAY NO TO OUR FRIENDS SOMETIMES
FOR THE ETTERMENT OF ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. OF WHAT WE
THINK IS GOOD. POLICY THEN WE
DON'T AND THAT'S TOO BAD FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT I BELIEVE
MEMBERS I BELIEVE THAT E ALL
HAVE THE COURAGE AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE ALL CAN SEE WHAT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IS NOW FIND
WAYS TO BE RICH PEOPLE AND ME
SURE WILL HAVE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
BUT THAT PLACE TO LIVE. YOU
WILL I GREW UP. WE HELD OUR NAY.
WHAT I DRIVE MY CAR NOW WITH MY
ELEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND I
SEE PEOPLE LAYING ON THE STREET.
DO I TELL HER TO TURN HER HEAD.
TOWARDS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN'T HELP THOSE WHO NEED THE
MOST HELP. I TALKED TO HARD TO
STAND UP. OR DO I SAY. YEAH WE
DO OUR BEST TO HELP PEOPLE
EVERYDAY THROUGH NON PROFITS IN
THE WORK WE DO. AND YOUR MOM.
TO PASS LAWS. TO PROVIDE A PATH
FOR DIGNITY FOR ALL PEOPLE. NO
THAT MEMBERS I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR IBM. YEAH I WAS. OKAY
COMMAS I WAS QUITE DONE BUT I
APPRECIATE EXPLAINS HOW WE COME
HERE TODAY AND I BILL YOU LOVE
TO KNOW I KNOW THE MANY OF THE
OPPONENTS WHO SPOKE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE IT'S PROBABLY WORTH
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION. AND SO
I THINK IN THAT SPIRIT WE
SHOULD CONTAIN WORK ON THE
CHECK MY CALL. HOTEL CONVERSION
IN SANTEE TO INCREASE OUR
SUBSET PERMANENTLY OF- RETAINED.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY QUITE HONESTLY. WITH
THE CONVERSION PARKS CONVENTION
CENTER IN SAN DIEGO INTO A
TWELVE HUNDRED PERSON HOMELESS
SHELTER. WE DO NOT HAVE THIS
PARTICULAR- IN THE TOWARD
POSSIBILITY AB BEER FOR THE END
OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SHOW THESE
ARE SHELTERED INDIVIDUALS THE
DOOR IS SHUT FOR THE BACK ON
THE STREET SO. I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS. TO REPRESENT WHO'S
CURRENTLY LIVING THERE ALTHOUGH
I PASSED PARCELLS WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE FAMILIES
LIVING IN MOTELS. ON THAT DATE
THE DAILY RATE TENDENCY WHICH
IS EFFECTIVELY YOU DON'T HAVE
TIME HOMELESS RIGHT. IN OFF THE
DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS I WOULD
NOTE THAT IT'S MY LOCAL HOUSING
COMMISSION IS TRYING TO A PART.
PROPERTY THAT WOULD DISCOVERY
IS THERE TO SUPPORT. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY NOT WORTHY OF PUBLIC
IN. BECAUSE THEY NOT GONNA
CONDITION THAT THE KIND THAT WE
BY OPPOSING THIS LEGISLATION
ARE COMPLICIT SEEMINGLY TO.
ENDORSING WHICH I DIDN'T ALONG
THE LINES OF YOUR SAME AS AN
ANTI WITH TWO DAUGHTERS. ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF STATE YOU LIVE IN
SO. MY POINT IS THIS. I'M NOT
HOW THE COMMISSION. THIS IS THE
CHEAPEST PER DOOR WAIT DON'T
PER DOOR RATE I KNOW OF TO GET
MORE FOR THE HOUSING STOCK ON
TO THE ROLES. AND I RECOGNIZE
THIS ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE MEANS
A MAYES PROPERTIES ARE GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE. AND TO THE EXTENT
YOU ARE WORKING TO CRAFT A
SITUATION WHERE THESE WILL NOT
BE COVERED UP BY. A REAL ESTATE
CONFIRMS BUT INSTEAD CAN BE
PURCHASED FOR THE INCREASE FOR
TO GROW OUR HOUSING. HOUSING
STARTS I THINK THAT'S A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION IT IS
CERTAINLY COMPLICATED. OUR
OFFICE IS SCHEDULED THIS YEAR
NON BUT BELIEVE IN YOUR-
LEGISLATOR I BELIEVE IN THE
OPPONENTS BOTH CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT WHAT WHAT. DOES IT CARE
ABOUT THE- DOCTOR. THE STATE.
WITH THE BECAUSE THE DEMAND OF
A SUB THANK YOU. TO THAT FOR
THE VISION TIME HAPPY SUPPORT
THE- ANY OTHER COMMENTS. I WANT
TO THANK AUTHOR FOR YOUR WORK
HERE IN YOU KNOW LET ME SAY
STATE THE OBWHICH IS ARE LIVE
IN ON PRESS TIMES AND WE ARE TO
THINK HARD AND IN FOR NEW IDEAS
AND WE HOUSE. OF CALIFORNIA'S
ARE AND THIS IDEA OF THE HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS AND CONVERTED
HOTELS HOTEL ROOMS IS FRANKLY
CENTRAL TO OURS. POINT ARE AND
HOW WE ARE DRESSING NOT JUST
HOMELESSNESS BUT CRIME VIRUS-
THROUGH PROJECT ROOM KEY AND
OTHER PROGRAMS AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE
CONVERSIONS DON'T GET DOWN AND-
THE PROCESS OR NEED THE GROUP'S
ARE THAT ONE OF. HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ON HAVE VISUAL.
ONCE YOU KNOW I EVERYONE ON
THIS DíAS WE ARE INCREDIBLY
SUPPORT. OF THE WORK AND THAT-
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF OUR TRADE
BUILDING TRADES TO. I DO THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN THERE'S BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF CONFUSION ABOUT
DAYS I JUST WANNA AGAIN CLARIFY
WHAT. ABOUT MS AT. AGREED TO
ACCEPT THE MEMBER. TO ENSURE
THE PREVAILING WAGE WILL APPLY
TO ALL PROJECTS AND TO ASSURE
THAT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS- DEVELOPERS- WHO WISH
TO TURN TRULY VACANT HOTELS
INTO MULTI FAMILY HOUSING-
WITHIN I'M PRESS LEVEL OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'LL DO
THAT UTILIZING A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. ARE SKILLED
TRAINED WORK PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL HI AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS IS THE STANDARD- THAT
WE'VE HAD FOR- YOU FOR YEARS-
REALLY BASED ON THE IDEA THAT-
THAT THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCES WERE TRYING TO TREAT
THIS HOUSING SO ARE WANT TO SAY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW NUMBER OF
COLOR TO PASS ME SINCE THERE TO
AND SOME CAN. DO YOU HAVE NOW
FOR. TRADE PROVIDE TO MY STAFF
THAT THAT THEY WERE NOT BE
OPPOSING IN COMMITTEE TODAY BUT
AGAIN WITH THE UNDERSTANDING-
WITH THE CABINET THAT HAS
EXPRESSED AT THAT THEY WOULD
KEEP WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS LINGERING CONCERNS AND
I TRUST THAT YOU WILL DO THAT
SO. I KNOW THIS IS A- THAT WITH
THE WITH CHALLENGES APPRECIATE-
OF THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
IMMINENT SAID WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
THOUGHTFUL INPUT- I AM
COMMITTED AS A SURE THIS
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE- BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE TO. WE HAVE TO
MOVE THIS CONVERSATION FOR WE
HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE HELP
THOUSANDS OF HOMELESS PEOPLE-
QUICKLY- AND PERMANENTLY
RECEIVE HOUSING WHICH IS WHY
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. SO WITH THAT. UNLESS
THERE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS. LET
ME TURN IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR
FOR CLOSING COMMENTS YEAH JUST
AT THE THINK YOU OFFER FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND WE ALWAYS
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL
OPPOSITION AND CONTINUE
HOPEFULLY TAKE. GET EVERYONE IN
A- POSITION OF FULL SUPPORT.
LIKE MANY OF YOU I CAN FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN. MY FIRST
DAYS LOCAL GOVERNMENT JUST
TOURING AROUND THE CITY I
THOUGHT WHY CAN'T WE CONVERT A
LOT OF THESE HOTELS AND MOTELS.
THIS MISTER GORE POINTED OUT.
OFTENTIMES ARE JUST IN
DEPLORABLE SITUATIONS WITH
FAMILIES LIVING THERE RIGHT
ALONGSIDE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
TAKING ON AND CAUSING BLIGHTED
NEIGHBORHOODS THE IT'S IT IT
THE WAIT IN FOR. ALSO IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. SOME GOOD
HOUSING STOCK THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO HELP TRANSFORM.
SOME OF. HIS AT THAT LONG
STRUGGLE SO AGAIN I THINK WE
WORK TO STRIKE THE BALANCE
BETWEEN PROVIDING HOUSING
MAKING SURE THAT- THE MINIMUM
IN TRADES ARE TAKING CARE OF
PEOPLE HAVE GOOD JOBS DURING
THIS. THIS PROCESS. AS AS-
HOLDING. WEREN'T BORN OUT OF
AGO HE CAN YOU SAY THAT. HAS
DECREASED. CAN YOU SAY THAT OUR
HOUSING STOCK HAS INCREASED.
WE'VE GOT TO FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN THIS IS AN EASY ONE
SITTING RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
ON SOME OF OUR BUSIEST IN THE
STREETS. LET'S TAKE IT LET'S
PUT PEOPLE IN A SAFE PLACE TO
LIVE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR- ANDWITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I CLARIFY THAT THERE WAS A
SECOND PLEASE I HAVE A FIRST
FROM QUIRK SILVA. OF MR GLORIA
SECOND IT OR- DIDN'T I DIDN'T
HEAR YOU. DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS Q. HI SHE'LL II
DEEP. THE BY GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GLORIA GLORIA AYE KILEY. WE MON
WE MOUNT I MAIENSCHEIN. QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I. THAT'S
THE THAT BILL HAS SIX SIX BUT
YOU HAVE THE VOTES TO GET IT UP
WE WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ANNA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER. AND ONE IS A WITH
MISCONDUCT DALTON'S ALAS MISTER
LOW IF YOU CAN PRESENT THEY
BELIEVE IS PRESENTATIONS FOR
SHORT. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THIS BILL IS TO ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL LOCAL CONTROL NO
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE WITH
THAT WHEN WE GO TO THE
WITNESSES ARE TESTIFYING BY
PHONE- TO THE MODERATOR IF WE
CAN ALLOW FOR STANTON TO SPEAK.
TENSION IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN MY
NAME IS BRUCE YEAH GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR GS OF A WELL
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. SHOULD
CODE SEVEN I EIGHT POINT FOUR
FIVE IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHICH IS A NINE. NINETY
ENACTED DECADES OLD EXEMPTION
CORRECT STABILIZATION
PROTECTION. FOR WHAT IS DEFINED
AS NEW CONSTRUCTION. AND THE
PURPOSE WAS TO INCENTIVIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION BUTTE MOBILE HOME
PARKS BUT WE HAVE GOOD
HISTORICAL DATA COMPILED BY
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING. OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS CAN MAKE THIS
IS REALLY HAVE LITTLE OR NO
EFFECT. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED MOBILE HOME PARKS
CALIFORNIA COMPRISING ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
SPACES WE ARE GONNA FIGHT. DO
PARKS BILL. NINETY WITH MORE
THAN TEN PAGES WE SEE FIFTY
EIGHT PARKS CONSTRUCTIVE THAT
REPRESENTS A ONE POINT 59% OF
THE TOTAL PARK. AND FIVE
THOUSAND HUNDRED YEAH EIGHT TO
ADD GET THOSE WHICH REPRESENTS
THE ONE POINT 39% OF THE TWO
SPACE. BORN FROM TO THE PRESS
WE A FOURTEEN COULD. WITH ONLY.
HUNDREDS BILL. ABOUT REPRESENTS
ALL NEEDS POINT 41% OF THE
TOTAL SPACES CALIFORNIA. THE
LAST FEW MOBILE HOME PARK BUILT
IN CALIFORNIA WAS THE TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN. SO IT'S
CLEAR THE EXEMPTION IS REALLY
HAD VIRTUALLY NO IMPACT THAT
YOU CONSTRUCTION. BUT HAS BEEN
OPPOSITION TO IT THIS QUOTE.
WHILE THERE HAVE BEEN ONLY A
FEW NEW PARKS BUILDING CAL WHAT
IS THE DIFFICULT SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT POINT FORTY FIVE WITH.
HELP IMPACT FEES. THAT THE
POTENTIAL RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCES. SO MEANWHILE ALL
THESE SPACES BILL SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY REMAIN EXEMPT
CORPORATE PROTECTIONS WITH PARK
OWNERS HAVING HAD- FOR YEARS TO
RECOUP DEVELOPMENT COST. DIRECT
RESTRICTED SPACE RATS. MAKES
LITTLE STAND JUST JACK OF
AFFORDABLE FOR SUPPOSE TO SAN
WHICH TIME BEATING PROVEN TO BE
INEFFECTUAL. LAND USE PLANNING
AND COST THAT THAT THAT THAT
SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZE. AND
DOING THAT NOT NEGATIVELY IN
FACT IMPACT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SO BY THE- WE DON'T CHANCE
NINETEEN NINETY MANY MORE PARTS
OF THAT QUOTE COULD PRETTY WC.
FIELDSHOUSING AFFORDABILITY OF
COURSE REMAINS THE TOP ISSUE
FOR US WITH LOCAL OFFICE ONE OF
THE LOWEST FORM. OF REPORT I'LL
GET OUR STATE AND THIS BILL
ENSURES THEY REPAIR PORTABLE BY
LIMITING THIS. GOOD PROTECTION
FOR YOUR GRANT CITY IT WILL
SIMPLY PRIORITIZE THE
PROTECTION OF THE- FIRST.
RESERVE THIS PEOPLE AFFORD
HOUSING BEFORE CA HOLD JUAN
SURPRISE OUT OF THEIR- THE
AGENT WILL PULL PREVENT BE AT
THE SHOULD CONTINUE NO LONGER
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOAT
THANK YOU. FROM WHEN HIS NUMBER
TO STEVEN JONES. THANK YOU YEAH
STEPHEN JONES ON THE GIVES
MULTI AFTER EACH FOR YOUR AND
LIVE IN OKAY MOBILE HOME PARK-
HI WHICH IS A SENIOR PARK BUILT
AFTER. NINETY NINETY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. YEAH SENIORS
LIVING IN A MOBILE PARK WITHOUT
STABILIZE REINCE WE'VE SEEN
RAINS INCREASE AS HIGHEST IN
PERSON AT. YEAH THE PROBABILITY
AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
PROGRAMMERS FROM RICH TO
CONTINUE TO THE CURRENT. LEVY
INCREASES ARE NOT AVAILABLE FOR
US SENIORS. THE EXACT OPPOSITE
OF WHAT OUR GOVERNMENT VOTED ON
TO PROTECT. LIKE US. YES THE
STATE OPPOSE LOOPHOLE THIS BILL
ADDRESSES WE ARE NOT COVERED.
WE ASK LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S HEALTHY
CRIMES NAY YOU WHY THAT IS THE
STATE PAGE WE DID MEAN IT. IN
LOOK. THE MOBILE HOME PARK AND
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT ON THE ISSUE OF BILL
EIGHTY DOES NOT WHICH IS THE X.
AND FACT. THE LEGISLATURE AS WE
BE PASSED LEGISLATION TO CREATE
NEW AND DIFFERENT INSTEAD OF.
YOUR BILL THE MOBILE HOME PARKS.
THE RIGHT TO RESUME OUR
RESIDENTS SUPPORTED. THE REASON
OF THESE INCENTIVES TO BUILD
PART BECAUSE THE INCENTIVES NOT
MAKE IT NON COMPROMISING
AFFORDABILITY INPUT ACOSTA
PRESS. IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT NOTHING IN THIS BILL YEAH.
MOBILE HOME PARK WHERE YOU
SPACES FROM BE CONSTRUCTED. AND
AT A TIME OF THE CALL WITH
NINETEEN DENIKIN'S RESULTED IN
JOB LOSS THE KEY FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP THE MOBILE HOME RIGHT
THAT ROCK CALIFORNIA LARSON
WRIST BUT LOW INCOME SIXTY
INCOME. OR EXPERIENCE IN. I
LOOK. INEQUITY OF THIS
COMPLICATED NEW BECAUSE STAY
INFO LOOPHOLE THAT MAKES THINGS
WORSE. THANK VERY MUCH FOR.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL STARTING HERE IN THE
CHAMBER MISTER MARK WITH THE
CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN AFTER
THE EIGHT- FOUNDATION. SUPPORT
TWENTY THANK YOU AND LET'S GO
TO THE MALL TO OPEN UP LINES
PLEASE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE IN SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL PRESS ONE THEN IT IS
ZERO. AGAIN IT YOU WILL PRESS
ONE THEN IT IS ZERO. THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YEAH LINE
ONE TWENTY FOUR ONE TWO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. I HAD LINE ONE TWO FOUR.
ARE THEY MAY HAVE DISCONNECTED
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE AT
THAT POINT EIGHT ZERO THE LINE
IS OPEN. A LINE EIGHTY I HAVE
WE HAVE A WIDE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT WAS EIGHT ZERO. ONE
EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE TO LINE
OPEN LINE ONE EACH NINE. OKAY I
MEAN OPEN A LINE FOURTEENTH CAN
THAT'S LINE THE TWO ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OPERATE
YOU I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
RISK- I HAVE FRIENDS WHO LIVE
IN MOBILE HOMES AND- AIM TO
CHARITY. Q. AND IT WILL GO TO
MY NUMBER NINETY SIX NINE NINE
SIX THE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS BECCA COUSINS AND I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA ART AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU ARE
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY SIX LINE AT NINE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH WE
CAN HEAR YOUR BACK A CURTAIN I
THANK REPRESENTING. ART AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND PAN
THE PLANE TWO ONE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HAVE DROPPED OUT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE DID OUR NINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE YOUR
LINE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE THE
LINE IS OPEN. I CAN YES WE CAN.
WAIT HI THIS IS ELECTRICAL I AM
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. IN IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
THIS CRUCIAL LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. OKAY ONE MOMENT FOR OUR
NEXT PERSON. THE ONE MOMENT
HERE WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN LINE TWO
ONE FIVE WILL BE OPENING THE
LINE. ONE MOMENT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN. HELLO THIS IS
ANASTACIO ANNAPOLIS I'M A
TENANT I LIVED IN SAMSON SO I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE. HOTELS
ARE OF A PREMIUM FOR PEOPLE TO
LIVE IN NOT FOR DEVELOPERS JUST
WILL BEEN AND BY WE MUST
PRESERVATIVES RENTAL HOUSING
WORK AND- THANK YOU. AND IF WE
GO TO LIKE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN THAT TWO NINE LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS BRIAN I GOT
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. EIGHT TO GO
TO MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN THAT IS NINE ONE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME. OKAY ON THE SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND I PLAN TO ALSO OF
THE MOBILE HOMES AND- I BELIEVE
THEY DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTION GOOD OTHER INTERESTS.
WE GO TO MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO THAT FLYING ONE
FOUR TO THE LINE IS OPEN. HI
MARY JO PARA CATCH I'M- IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTY ALL THANK YOU.
I NINETY SIX HAVE YOU ALREADY
RESPONDED. YEAH ALREADY
RESPONDED I'M FROM CALIFORNIA
OUR COMMUNITY SUPPORT I AM
PLEASED HERE LINE BACK ON MUTE.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBERS HE TO
THE LINE IS OPEN LINE SIXTY Q.
NINE SIXTY TWO WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OH OKAY I
DIDN'T GET THE QUEUE- MY NAME
IN THERE WILL BE I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I HAVE A FRIEND WHO
LIVED IN A MOBILE HOME. IN
REDWOOD CITY HE'S A CURRENT
STRUGGLING WITH A ARE YOU
GETTING ON EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
I WOULD LIKE TO. WE HAVE TO DO
A- AND NEXT WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO IN
ONE FOUR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
WE DO HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
OKAY. NINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
TWO IF YOU'RE ABLE TO SPEAK
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GETTING A
RESPONSE ON THE LINE WE'RE
GOING TO MEET THEM THANK YOU.
AND THAT WE HAVE A NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU NOTES LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION- TO- INJURY GOVERNOR
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS ACTUALLY CHASE AND I
OCCURRED BUT THAT'LL STEAM
GILBERT ROBESON'S MEANT HALF
THAT CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME
PARK ALLIANCE- THE ANALYSIS FOR
THE BILL- JUST THE FACT IT AT
PARKS HAVE A REALLY IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
STOCK AND CAL. FOR ABOUT THAT.
JUST EARLIER IN IT. OTHER NOW.
WE'RE AT LOSE IN THE PAST TWO
DECADES SEVERAL HUNDRED PARKS
AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MOBILE
HOME SPACES- SO WE HAVE WE
BEGIN TO LOOK LOSE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK- I'M- BARRING
RATE. THERE IS A THERE U.
INCENTIVES BUILDING MOBILE HOME
PARKS AND HOW IT HOW IT'S THEIR
VERY COSTLY TO RUN- AND THERE
ARE HIGH LIABILITIES ASSOCIATED
WITH RUNNING MOBILE HOME PARK-
YEAH REPEAL OF THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION EXEMPTION IS
PROPOSING AB TWENTY SIX NINE
HE- TAKES. ONE OF THE VERY FEW
REMAINING SENTENCE OFF OF THE
TABLE TO CONSTRUCT A MOBILE
HOME PARK AND THE CHOICE IS
QUITE CLEAR IF THE BILL PASSES.
IF YOU ARE A DEVELOPER LAND.
THE OPTION TO BUILD A MOBILE.
PARK OR TO BUILD A PART OR TO
BUILD OTHER TYPES OF HOUSING IF
YOU BUILD THE PARK IF AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY PASSES. YOU DO NOT
ENJOY PROTECTION RACKET BALL OR
THE ABILITY TO RECOUP YOUR
VALUE IN THE FIRST YEARS AT
THAT. HOMES ARE GETTING OUR-
OPERATING BUT YOU BUILDING.
HOUSING WE DON'T HAVE THAT SAME.
AND SO OUR FIRST THIS IS JUST
GOING TO ACCELERATE THE LOSS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GOVERNOR
THERE. YES CREEK. AND YOUR
GOVERNOR I ONCE AGAIN HAVE TO
WMA I THANK YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- DURING A HOUSING
CRISIS SO I GUESS WE'RE
CONFUSED AS TO WHY YOU WOULD
ELIMINATE THE ABILITY PARK
HONEST EITHER BILL PARKER AT
SPACES ON EVERY SINGLE SPACE
YOU THAT EVERY SINGLE PARK YOU
HAD NO MATTER HOW BIG IS NOT
GOOD TO HELP HOUSING CRISIS SO
THE TOP OVER. TWO OF THEM. HE
DOES NOT UNDERSTAND US WE TALK
ABOUT NEW PARK BEING I THINK
KNOW THE MISTRESS WAS KERR YOUR
AT REGULAR FEES YOU LOOK AT THE
ENACTMENT RECKON ALL ON THERE
WILL BE A RENT CONTROL BILL WE
DISCUSSING IN A FEW MINUTES-
ANY TALK ABOUT THE MARK STONE.
SERVICE ISN'T PARK OWNERS ARE
GOING PARTS IN THE STATE IF YOU
CAN'T GET A FAIR RATE OF
RETURN. IF YOU CAN'T EVER CLOSE
A PARK. AND YOU HAVE ALL THESE
RULES AND REGULATIONS WHICH
POSSIBLY COULD HAMSTRING YOUR
ABILITY TO WORK- IT'S DIFFICULT
THE BILL AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THIS. WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER UNTIL THE NINETEEN
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS AND WE'RE
BEING OUT. TO RENT FOR UP TO A
YEAR AND A HALF SOME. ON THESE
PRESIDENTE TIMES THAT WE JUST
ARE STAND. LET IT. LIMóN BILL
FOR ANY INPUT ON HOUSING I'M
IMMEDIATELY AND MOBILE HOME AND
PEOPLE UP IN MATTER OF. SO WITH
NINE YEARS BUT- OF TO THE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO YOU UP IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE THEN IT
ZERO AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO. WHAT ARE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FVE THE LINE IS
OPEN. TO ALL FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
SCREEN GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS NOT FISH THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN IF ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IT ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITHOUT ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
DISCUSSION. MISS EMMA. I THINK
YOU'RE SIGN OUR LOW FOR
BRINGING THIS FLORIDA AND I
ALSO WANT TO THINK I MISTER
JONES I'M FROM HI MY DISTRICT I
KNOW THAT A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS IN THE DISTRICT
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO. TO THE
LAST THE WHOLE TIONS INTEREST I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT IT COMES
TO- THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN IT REPLICATE THAT
SAME MODEL. BUT WE HAVE. ANY
YOUR BILL TRYING TO DO THAT- SO
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY ONE OF. WORKING INCLUDING
SOME OF MY OWN. AND I AM HAPPY
TO MAKE THE MOTION IF IT HASN'T
BEEN MADE. THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION IS OUR SECOND. THERE'S
BEEN A SECOND. THE DISCUSSION.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR MOVETHIS
FORWARD AS SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED
ON TEN AND ISSUES FOR MANY
YEARS SAY APPRECIATE BILLS THAT
CAN YOU TO. LOOK OUT FOR
TENANTS AND CERTAINLY DURING
THIS COVERED NINETEEN CRISIS WE
KNOW THAT PRODUCTION OF HOUSING
MAY FACE ROADBLOCK. IRV SIXTEEN
NEW HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE HAVE SO PROJECT YOU BRING
THIS FORWARD HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT ANY FURTHER COMMENTS. OKAY
THERE'S A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS Q. HI. I. D. GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
KILEY KILEY NO THE MOM ME MOM I
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA I GIVE FIVE OH TWO BILLS
THAT WILL WAIT FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON. ASSEMBLYMEMBER. WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO FILE ITEM TO
THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE. YOUR OUTLASTED YEAH YEAH.
MARK MY YOU YOU HAVE MY
DILIGENCE ON THAT. IN AND
SOMEONE WHO IS SOMEONE IS ALSO
IN IN THAT CATEGORY I
SYMPATHIZE. LIKE. MAYBE. I'M
SORRY FOR THE AND HOUSES.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE WOULD
LOSE THE NUMBER FORMALLY BOB
YOU MIGHT BE DEBT. YEAH AND
THEN DOUBLE FOR QUALIFYING
HOUSING PER. CALVET SEVERE
CRISIS IS WILD RE YEARS. THIS
IS RESULT INCREASE HOUSING
COSTS IN AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS
EXPERIENCING A HIGHER DEGREE OF
HOUSE COPS BURNING. AT A TIME
WHEN THIS SHOULD BE
ACCELERATING ITS HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION WE'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN AT THE CELLAR IN A COURT
DEPARTMENT ANSWER NO DENTAL
BUILDING PERMITS WAS DOWN SEVEN
POINT. TWENTY NINE. HERE IN A
MINUTE TOOLS THAT ARE JUST.
LEVELS IS THE DENSITY BONUS LAW.
BENEFITS UNDER THE PROGRAM ARE
OFFERED AT A SLIDING SCALE
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY HOMES ARE
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE AND
HOW ME DEEPLY AFFORDABLE UNITS
ARE IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
DEVELOPERS A BONUS ABOVE THE
BASE DENSITY CONCESSIONS FROM
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS ARE
ALSO AVAILABLE DESPITE THE
BENEFITS. LEVELNOT RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN FACT
IN SAN DIEGO ONLY FOUR THOUSAND
UNITS WERE BUILT OVER TWELVE
YEAR.AND RISK HELLO THE
PROGRAM. AND A GO IN HERE THE
STATE PROGRAM BY INCREASING THE
MAXIMUM DENSITY BONUS TO FIFTY
PERCENT. INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF ALLOWED SENATE FIVE.
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL IN
NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE UNITS. IN
THE FIRST SEVEN MONTHS OF THE
ENHANCE SAN DIEGO PRO.
DEVELOPERS APPLIED FOR NINE
TIMES AS MANY PROJECTS PER
MONTH THAN UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ITERATION OF THE BONUS PROGRAM.
IN FACT IF TRENDS CONTINUE THE
ENHANCE PROGRAM. THE TECH
PERFORMED PREVIOUS PROGRAM AND
JUST. COMMUNITY PROCESS HELP
YOU CAN SEE IT FROM WHAT WAS
LEARN IN SANDY. AB TWO. TWENTY
FORTY FIVE PER TO EXPAND
DENSITY BONUS LAW TO PROVIDE
THE SAME ENHANCEMENTS ADOPTED
BY HE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
INCENTIVES AVAILABLE TO. FOR A
UNITS TO STICKS ARE
DEVELOPMENTS TO SIX. FINALLY
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE MAXIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR
DENSITY BONUS PROJECTS AS
SPECIFIED IN ORDER TO FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE MORE DENSITY BONUS
PROJECTS. WITH THAT OUT TO GET
TO THE WITNESSES. LET'S GO NOW
TO OUR WITNESSES TO THE
MODERATOR IF WE COULD PLEASE
ALLOW CALLING PARENTS TO
TESTIFY AS WITH HIS NUMBER ONE.
ONE PARENT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR READY TO
TESTIFY I'M EIGHTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN DOLLARS PRODUCE
INTRODUCING THIS BILL MY NAME
IS COLIN PARIS AND I MEAN THAT
GIVE DIRECTOR AND GENERAL
COUNSEL THE NONPROFIT. EIGHT
EIGHT. ABA I'M ALL ELECTED.
EIGHTY TWO THREE FOUR FIVE WITH
THE DESIGNED TO APPLY STATEWIDE
THAT ENHANCEMENTS TO GET PEOPLE
TO LAW WHICH IS A DOCTOR BY THE
STATE COUNCIL EIGHTY EIGHT WHEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND IN FACT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA WOULD
ACTUALLY THE ONLY MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO VOTED TO THAT-
DOCTOR. YEAH POLICY AND EVEN IF
IT'S WORDED CAN BE WITH ANY I
THINK. PUBLIC HOW AUTHORITY
WELL I SERVICE THE COMMISSION'S
DIRECTOR THE- I JUST YESTERDAY
CIRCULATING PUBLISHED A REPORT
MEASURING THE SUCCESS OF SAN
DIEGO THAN HERE ONE OF THE
PROGRAM. AS COMPARED WITH THE
CITY USE STATE AND IN THE FIRST
MONTH. AFTER PROGRAM IF THE NEW
PROGRAM A HUNDRED NINETY PER
AND IN FOR THE NUMBER THE
CLIENT YOU THE PRO. FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY INCREASE IN THE
IRAQI ANNUALLY IN THE NUMBER OF
KEY RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOMES
ENTITLED AND A 310056% INCREASE
ANNUALLY. ALL AND RATE HOMES
ENTITLED TO THIS EXPERIENCE TO
CITY AGO SHOWS THAT WE BUILD ON
IT ALREADY CORRECTED BY STATE
AND PEOPLE THIS LAW WE CAN
COURAGE TO. MAYBE EVEN MORE
FOR. THREE FOUR FIVE OF THE
BECAUSE POLICY. 50% BONUS WITH
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDE THE 15% OF
BASE CAMP THE AFFORDABLE AND
IT'S ROUGHLY PRESERVES THE
RATIO OF 11% AFFORDABLE UNITS
TO THIRTY FIVE FOR. OUR CAN BE
BONUS LAW AND I ALSO JUST BUY
ONE FROM THE HAPPEN OUT. UP
CIRCULATING FOUND THAT- THE
AVERAGE PROJECT YOU. BONUS
PROGRAM USE ONLY THREE AND
CONFESSIONS AND I NEED THAT
SOME USE ACTUALLY MORE THAN
THREE IN ORDER TO BUILD UP
THEIR PROJECTS IN THE OPERATE
THE AFFORDABLE IN THE BONUS
UNIT. BOB PROJECT IT BEETLE
PERCENT OF. THREE ADDITIONAL
AND TWO A CALM THEIR EXTREME SO
THATWE RESPECT ASK YOUR I WILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WOULD
CONTINUE TO ASK FOR ALL MEAN
WHEN THIS IS IF HE'S LOW.
MINUTES WITH THAT LET'S TO THIS
WITNESS. ALICIA WEEK WHEN
YOU'RE LYING AT ALL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU GET
UP THE PICTURE NUMBER THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE SPENDING OF MOSTLY CLEAR I
AM THE POLICY IN READ. ACTION
THE NATIONAL HOPPING OUT THE
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
FOSTER ECHO CAN YOU GROW BY LEN
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS TO HELPING.
PROBABLY CO SPONSOR EASY THREE
FORTY FIVE WITH CIRCULATING
DIEGO AND WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ FOR
AUTHORED THIS IMPORTANT HOUSING
PRODUCTION LEGISLATION. I KNOW.
MAJOR HOUSING CRISIS OUR
RECORDS FIND WITH THE STATE
FILED POINT THE HOLE SHORT
RELATIVE TO. FROM TWO THOUSAND
TO TWENTY FIFTEEN THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT THE SHORTAGE ARE MOST
PEOPLE FELT BY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE IT'S CRITICAL FOR
HELPING WITH STATE AND SHE EVEN.
CALLING HELP BIRDIE INVEST OF
PRIVATE HAPPEN GET A PORTABLE
UNIT WHERE NEEDED ABOUT THE
BILL WILL BE IN THAT AFFORD
UNITS IT FELT WITHOUT HAVING TO
RELY AND INVESTMENT OF PUBLIC
DOLLARS. FOR NOW IMPACT LOCAL
BECAUSE MAKING AUTHORITY ALL
PROJECT STILL GO THROUGH PEOPLE.
FOR GOVERNMENT CAN YOU THE
THING ABOUT IN A HEALTH PROJECT
WHICH WE REALLY NEED RIGHT NOW.
WE WITH BELIEVE QUESTION I
THINK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
LOW US GO. WOULD AND SUPPORT-
WE HAVE- AND THE CHAMBER PLEASE.
MARC FABER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU GREAT- INTO THE
MODERATOR IF WE COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE TO SUPPORTERS
OF THIS BILL. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ASK SHOW SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE THE
SENATE. NERO AGAIN IT IS ONE.
ZERO AND ELEVEN LINE TWO ONE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF TIME WHERE A
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO SUPPORT. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN LINE AT ONE EIGHT ONE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
GUNNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE
GO TO MY NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT AT
LINE SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THE GERMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
BOB NAYLOR I REPRESENT FEELS
DEAD COMPANY WHICH IS A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF CALIFORNIA YOU MAY
BE AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORTERS BILL. ACTUAL GO TO
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN THAT IS LINE ONE
NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
ONE NINETY SEVEN WE DO HAVE TO
LINE OPEN FOR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AGAIN A LINE ONE NINETY
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
SPEAK. OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT- PERSON IN THE
QUEUE THAT IT'S LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE LINE TWO
FOUR ONE STATE GOING AT. LINE
TWO FOUR ONE WE DO HAVE A LINE
OPEN FOR YOU YOU MAY SPEAK.
NINE TWO FOUR ONE A LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE SPEAK YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. OKAY WE WILL GO NEXT TO
THE LINE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT LINE TWO THREE
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MARINO
WHITE MARINO LINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WILL GO
NEXT TO MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE. LINE SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK
YOU THIS IS JOHN MIGHT AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M WITH EACH
DAY FOR EVERYONE AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS NATURE. WE'LL
GO TO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THAT IS LINE ONE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LOUIS
MONTEREY WITH CALIFORNIAN BE I
WORDS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GO TO MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THAT IS FINE TWO
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON CORY MET ON BEHALF OF
THE BAY AREA HELPING ADVOCACY
COALITION AB TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE THANK YOU. WELL MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THAT IS LINE TWO THREE SEVEN
THE LINE IS OPEN. HI TO PUBLIC
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE PLAN
THAT'S RIGHT CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN FORT THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT TO MY NUMBER SIXTY
THAT IS LINE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
STILL DEAL FERRARI ON BEHALF OF
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT. IT WILL GO
NEXT TO MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE TWO TWO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA WARNER
ON BEHALF OF THE- VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION INTO PORT.
AND ACTUALLY GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX THAT
IS PLAIN TWO THREE SIX GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M LAURA ON BEHALF BIRD
TECH EQUITY COOPERATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIVE THAT IS LINE ONE ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE MIGHT BE A
COUNCIL IN TRUMP REPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO MY NUMBER NINETY
TWO THAT IS LINE AT NINE TO GO
AHEAD. MORAN WITH ERIN READ
NECESSITY INTERPRETING THE
SEVEN CALIFORNIA RNTAL HOUSING
IS TAKE SUPPORT. AND IT NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR AT LINE
TWO THREE FOUR THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CERTAIN. YEAH
BEHALF OF THE THREE P.
COALITION INCLUDING A HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
COULD GO DOWN AND A PAYMENT
PLANNING AND URBAN RESURGENT TO
ALTERNATE BURKE AND HAVE
ATTACKED MANY CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR. AN ACTUAL TO MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR THAT
IS FLYING TO FOUR FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NEW CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADAM ROUGHLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
COURT THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
GO TO MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
DEADLINE CAN ZERO ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THEY TO KEEP
CONNOR WITH A BETTER WAY FOR TO
HAVE CALIFORNIA WORK ROUGHLY
SUPPORT OF AMENDED BELIEVE
STICK THE MADE OUR IDEAS TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE FEEL
CONFIDENT LOOKING FOR QUICKER.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE THAT IS LINE TWO FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'D LIKE TO
FORTY ONE WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO FOUR ONE IF YOU WANT
TO JUST CHECK YOUR NEW FEATURE
ON YOUR PHONE WE DO HAVE TO
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. THIRTY
THERE'S NO RESPONSE FINAL- TWO
FOUR ONE WELL AT. MOVE FORWARD
TO LINE. TWO FORTY THREE NINE
TWO FOUR THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT IS.
RUNNING JUST GO. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO THAT IS LINE NE FIVE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. Q. LINE ONE
FIFTY HERE THE ONE. AND THAT
ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE LINE ONE
FIFTY TWO EIGHT. THANK YOU.
OKAY I WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED ANDFORTY
NINE THAT IS LINE TWO FOUR NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
OPPORTUNITY I WORK AT RIGHT
ARCHITECT IN THE BAY AREA AND
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
DISTRICTS GENDERS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WOULD
GO A LONG WAY IN MAKING. IT
POSSIBLE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE THAT OF
LINE ONE NINE NINE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. YEAH I CAN. WITH
CALIFORNIAN BEER WE ARE IT'S A
PART OF THAT BELT THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SIXTY
TWO LINES SIX TO ME YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THE HELLO HI PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SIXTY TWO. OKAY
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
pFRANCISCO AND I AM WITH THAT
COALITION FLEET AT THAT THANK
YOU JUST GO YOU MD- IN I'M
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE HAVE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THAT IS LINE TWO FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT
MY NAME IS THAT THEY LOOK AT
THE- CREAM ON CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX THAT IS
LINE TWO FOUR SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS COUNTY MEANS
I'M CALLING FROM PALO ALTO ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE FOR EVERYONE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THAT IS LÏNG TWO
FIVE PLEASE GO. LAURA HART
CALLING FROM YOU IN THE ACTION
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND MARK.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO THAT IS
LINE TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI IN CALLING FROM
SECOND TO TELL WITH URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN SUPPORT.
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO THAT
IT'S LINE TO FIVE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KEVIN BURKE
FROM ALAMO CALIFORNIA I'M IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT THAT IS TWENTY TWO TWO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. CARL
WITH COUNT. TO THIRTY ASIAN IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT I WILL WE
WILL HAVE ONE TWO ZERO SIX.
AGAIN THAT FLANK TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO ZERO K. LATER THAT A
CAPTAIN GET UP FROM A FAMILY
DISTRICT FIFTY FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE IMPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR
OUR NEXT TASK. PERSON IN THE
QUEUE ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THAT IS LINE TWO THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
THREE ZERO. HI THIS IS TONY
TROUT FROM GIVEN THE LAW THE
POOR. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK AT THIS TIME WHEN WE GO
NOW TO OPPOSITION- IF WE COULD-
TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
ALLOW SANTEE GEORGE TO TESTIFY.
GEORGE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DANTE GEORGE FOR ANY AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION TODAY AND
THE FACT. AND YOU REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT THIS MODEL HAS
WORKED IN SAN DIEGO BUT OUR
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT FIGHTING
HIGHER DENSITY AND OTHER
BENEFITS. IN EXCHANGE FOR
HIGHER LEVELS OF ABILITY IN THE
PROJECT- AND IT HAVE TO BE
BASED ON WHAT WORK IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY. SO WE- THE
AMENDMENT THAT WERE. YOU BY THE
PUBLIC INTEREST ADVOCATES THIS
WOULD MAKE THAT HIGHER BENEFITS
FRIEND BUT AFFORDABLE PROJECT
CURRENT LAW AND ADD A NEW TWO
FOR OTHER PROJECTS WITH HIGHER
INCLUSIONARY UNIT- AND THEN
TAKE WORKING GIVEN THE
REDUCTION OF THE POINT FIVE
BEING PROPOSED FOR THE CURRENT
PARKING LIMITED AND DID. LAW
WHAT. WE ALL SUPPORT MAY THE
REQUIRED CONTEST OUT FOR THE
WE'D BE HAPPY TO COULD TO WORK
ON WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL BUT WE DO
THINK THAT THE- WHAT WAS
OFFERED FROM PUBLIC INTEREST
ADVOCATES IS A FAIR COMPROMISE
AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
FEDERATION THE. LET ME ASK IF
THERE THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT THE POSSIBILITY MISTER
MARTIN HERE. WE SECURE MEMBERS
RIGHT OR NOT BE HAVE THE AIDS
HEALTH HEALTH CARE FOUNDATION
WE OPPOSE THE BILL BASED ON
EARLIER LANGUAGE WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR
IS TAKEN. LOOK FORWARD TO GOING
BACK IN AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE
BILL AGAIN WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS WE DO REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AND OTHER
BILLS. THAT THE ATTENTION TO
VIDEO WHY. E. L. TENNIS VERY
LOW INCOME AN EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME- IS NOT ROBUST ENOUGH
TO- LIKE. TO TAKE CARE OF THE
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK
FOR TO TALKING TO THE AUTHOR
MORE ABOUT- SHE WOULD COME UP
WITH MORE ROBUST AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET ME ASK
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE LINE WHO WISH TO
OPPOSE THE BILL. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE. TO QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN IT'S
ZERO. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR THAT IS L<c.cyan>G TWO FIVE</c>
FOR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN AGAIN.
HI THIS IS JEFFREY THING RIVER
BEACH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
FIVE I MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY.
WITH THE BILL AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IF ANYONE ELSE IS IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO WE HAVE LIKE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE. THAT IS
ONE TWO FOUR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MOST OF I'M SEARCHES GO.
I LIKE THE ACTION AND NINETY
TWO QUESTION MY SUPPORT. AND IF
ANYONE ELSE IS IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IT IS ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF IT LET ME BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THIRTY COMMENTS
MR GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- BUT I WANT TO MAKE-
THE AUTHOR THIS BILL IN THE
PLOT OF FORGETTING AND
COMMENTS. IN SUPPORTING THE
BILL BOTH IN THE SUPPORT
SECTION HANDED THE OPPOSITION
SPECS FIFTY. I DON'T THINK
THAT'S JUST THE- SORT OF NATURE
OF THE CALL SITUATION I THINK
IF THE BILL IS THAT GOING. ON
IN SO THANK YOU AS A RESULT FOR
BRINGING THIS BOARD. I WANT TO
THANK. MY DEAR FRIEND- CALLING
PARENTS. WHO YOU'VE HEARD
PROVIDE WITNESS TESTIMONYIN
SUPPORT. HE'S VERY KIND TO
REMEMBER THE THAT WE DID VOTE
TO SUPPORT. THIS PARTICULAR
ORDINANCE AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER SEVERAL YEARS AGO-
THAT'S DID THEY CAN GIVE ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
SURE IS THAT THIS. ACTUALLY
WILL BE MEANING FIGHTING A LOT
OF TIMES. WHEN WE VOTE ON THE
BILLS WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
NO SINGLE BUILDABLE SUMMER
HOUSING PRICES. BUT WE OFTEN
WONDER THEY CAN HAVE A
PRACTICAL IMPACT. AND IN THE
SECOND LARGEST CITY IN THE
STATE NAY OF OURS THE NATION
YOU. SEEN OUR THAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING AND I WOULD COMPETE
COMMAND- CALLING PARENTS
ORGANIZATION. RUNS CIRCULATE
SIXTY EIGHT OUT. REPORTER TWO
DAYS GOES CHEN. IN TIME. ARGAN
AGAIN AND KNOWLEDGE THE- THIS
IF. GOOD BECAUSE IT HAS ONLY
PHOTO. STREET VIEW HOSPITAL IT.
AS YOU MAY KNOW HAVE A ROLE
THIS BILL IN A SET THE CITY
THIS. DISTRICT WILLING TO PUT
STUFF THERE AND THE THIS FOR.
SHOWS THAT. CERTAINLY. YEAH
YEAH THE EXACT GETTING THE
STUFF DONE YOU CAN THE TEN
PRODUCT AND I THINK WE KNOW
WHEN THIS IS ALL I BOTH KNOW
THAT THE CITY CITY OF CONNECTS
ALL THE ENTIRE TO STATE'S HOUSE
CRISIS IN WHY THIS IS NOT SO
THEY YOU SOME ITS ALL FOR ALL
THIS LET. AND HOW TO MOVE THE
AND IN INCOME IN MY COLLEAGUES
SUPPORT THIS. THEY IF PEOPLE
MINISTER WHY WILL CLEARLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT OF HOUSING
HAVE GENERAL BUT FOR THE LOW
INCOME WHICH THIS AGAIN THANK
YOU TO OKAY STANDING UP TO
SOMEONE DOLLARS. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. CONTACT MISTER IF
YOU'RE COMMON I AM A BIG
SUPPORTER THIS BILL IN PART
BECAUSE I THINK IT- IT WILL
SUPPORT ALL THE BEAUTIFUL PARTS
OF THE STATE- HOWEVER ONE
DEFINES AT- AND I'M ALSO HAPPY
TO BE A JOINT AUTHORED THIS
BILL- IN PART BECAUSE- THE
AUTHOR HAD AGREED TO ALLOW US
TO MERGE LANGUAGE FROM TWO OF
OUR OTHER BILLS THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD. OR JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO TELL THE COMMITTEE THAT- WE
HAVE MARCH I THINK NINE BILLS
INTO FOUR BILLS THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING TODAY IN PART- SO
WE CAN CONSOLIDATE THE NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT WE HAVE MOVING
FORWARD TO MAKE APPROPRIATIONS
THERE'S LIKE. A LITTLE. BUT YOU
KNOW DENSITY BONUS IS A POLICY
THAT HAS WORKED BUT I THINK WE
ALL UNDERSTAND IT COULD WORK
BETTER- I DO UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHOR'S BEEN ENGAGING WITH THE
OPPOSITE THE CURRENT OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL- TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT IS THE BEST
AND MOST PRECISE APPROACH TO
TURBO CHARGE THIS POLICY AND-
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH HER TO
FIND THE EXACT ANSWER- BUT AND
I THINK THIS BILL IS REALLY
VERY MUCH AT. VERY STRONG WORK
IN PROGRESS AND- WE SHOULD
SUPPORT SO WITH THAT LET ME ASK
THE AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE ANY
FINAL COMMENTS THANK YOU I AND
I ALWAYS SAY WHEN I'M I'M
WORKING IN A SPACE THAT I DON'T
USUALLY WORK AND I THINK
THERE'S SOME SHOCK. IN A
SUPPORT AND YOU KNOW I DON'T I
DON'T USUALLY DO HOUSING BUT
THE FRUSTRATION I THINK THAT I
FEEL IS OUR CONSTITUENTS FEEL
I'M NOT AN EXPERT- I WANT OUR
HOUSE A LOT AS IN VERY WHERE I
WANT OR PERHAPS DISTRICT WHICH-
IS ONE ITS OWN RIGHT- THE THAT
MAYBE WOULDN'T BE ON THE
PICTURES ABOVE JUST. THIS WAS
BANG ON THE- ONE FIVE ALL DATA.
TO SHOW IT WOULD WORK IT. WORK
IN AND WHERE HOPE THAT. COME
WITH OTHER THINGS THAT REALLY
GET TO THE VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSING THAT WE NEED WE NEED IN
MY DISTRICT- THIS IS IN A
FANTASY IT'S NOT A SOLVE
EVERYTHING. BUT IF WE CAN GET
ONE STEP CLOSER I THINK THAT
THAT'S A SUCCESS SO. I'M WITH
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
OPPOSITION. I'M TO SEE IF
THERE'S DATA. THAT SUGGESTED
SHE GO FROM 15% 217% WE GET
THERE MIGHT BE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH- BUT WE WANT TO DO.
WHAT IS DATA DRIVEN ENSURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
AND- STEVEN OFF. NEXT TO CREATE
A- SCENE SO. BUT I WAS I. FOR
MORE. THERE'S PROMOTION FOR
DENNIS SECOND. IS OKAY THERE'S
BEEN A SECOND MAY SO PLEASE THE
ROLL. DO YOU PASSED AMENDED TO
THE CA ON APPROPRIATIONS ISSUE
RIGHT. Q. I D. DEEP I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
KILEY. HIGHLY I HIGHLY ONE.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA GROUPS
OF I. IT WAS ABOUT COUNTY. ONE
SIX GUYS AND TO NOT PRESENT
YOUR BILL IS OUT AND WE'LL WAIT
FOR OTHER ADD ONS. IT THIS TIME
SINCE WE DO HAVE TO AUTHORS WHO
ARE NOT PART OF THIS COMMITTEE
IF THAT'S OKAY FOR US TO GO TO
A BILL AUTHORS- ONE WE GO TO
FILE. TEEN IF I COULD ASK THE
MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA GO TO
FILE ITEM. WHICH IS AB THIRTY
THREE FIFTY TWO FRIEDMAN. MS
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FOR TAKING OUT OF
ORDER OF THANK YOU ALSO
MEMBERS- HOUSING AND BUILDING
CODES ARE INTENDED TO ENSURE
THAT RESIDENTS ARE SAFE IN
THEIR DWELLINGS ENFORCEMENT OF
THESE CODES IS ESPECIALLY
CRUCIAL IN THE CONTEXT OF MULTI
FAMILY RENTAL DWELLINGS OR
TENTS HAVE LIMITED ABILITY TO
CORRECT HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROBLEMS. SOME LOCAL CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA PLACE RESTRICTIONS
OR PRECONDITIONS ON RESPONDING
TO TENANTS HABITABILITY
COMPLAINTS FOR EXAMPLE SOME
PLACES WILL REQUIRE TENANTS TO
PROVE THAT THE PROPERTY OWNER
HAS BEEN UNRESPONSIVE TO THEIR
COMPLAINTS OR THAT THE TENNIS
CIRCLE ON THE RAMP FOR THE
LOCAL AGENCY WILL SEND OUT AN
IT FACTOR. NONE OF THE SHOULD
MATTER LOCAL GOVERNMENT. POST
TO ENSURE THAT ALL DWELLING
UNITS ARE HABITABLE OR FREE OF
LEAD PAINT. AB THIRTY THREE
FIFTY TWO PROHIBITS LOCAL CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA FROM PLACING
RESTRICTIONS OR PRECONDITIONS.
BEFORE RESPONDING TO
HABITABILITY COMPLAINTS. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
THE AGENCY PROVIDE COPIES OF
THE INSPECTION REPORT ANY
CITATIONS TO THE TENANT. THEIR
OCCUPANTS OF THE BUILDING WHO
MAY BE AFFECTED BECAUSE SOME
LOCALITIES ATTENDED MY
COMPLAINT. AND NEVER FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE COMPLAINT
AND WONDER IF THEY'RE LIVING IN
AN UNSAFE CONDITION. OUTSIDE
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
REPORTED ANY INSPECTION AB
THIRTY THREE FIFTY TWO DOES NOT
CREATE ANY NEW DUTIES OR
RESPONSIBILITIES ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. I DON'T EXPECTED
TO CREATE ANY INCREASE THE
OFFICE HAS HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. THE
REPRESENTATIVES. IN COUNTIES I
PLEDGE TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THEM TO ADDRESS IF THEIR ISSUES
ARE CONFIDENT THAT THEY CAN BE
RESOLVED BEFORE FLOOR VOTE
SHOULD THIS BILL PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY AND TO SHAHAR FROM
THE WESTERN ON POVERTY AND
BRIAN ACOSTA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO THE FIRST WITNESS
TO SASHA HARDEN. THE NATURE
NUMBER ONE IN STOCK IN THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND APPEARING TODAY
FIND THE PART OF AB THIRTY
THREE FIFTY CHAIR WITH HER PART
BECAUSE SPONSOR. THE
COMMONSENSE BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR HOUSING STOCK
IS PROTECTED AND MAINTAINED A
KIND OF PURPORTED EQUAL RIGHT
ON PORTS MEN OF OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR HOUSING.
AND ALL VERY LITTLE TO SHELTER
IN PLACE AS WE'VE BEEN DIRECTED
WITHOUT HAVING TO PUT UP
DANGEROUS OR UNHEALTHY
CONDITIONS. IN OUR HOMES.
EIGHTY THREE THE BILL AND BUT
CAN BEEN EVERY PART OF THE-
DEMOCRATS. ACTION HOME AND WITH
TO A- WITHOUT HAVING IN A GROUP
CONDUCT. BUT ON THE RIGHT ABOUT
IN FACT. OUR STATE IMPOSED TO
YOU OF ON LANDMARK CAME BUNDLED.
FROM THE FACT COMPLY WITH HAVE
A LAW. WHICH REQUIRE RENTAL
HOUSING CONDITIONS SUCH
DANGEROUS MOLD THE FACT THE
WIRING THE AND THE LIKE AND
ENJOY IT ALL BUT NOT. IN A
NUMBER IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
STOCK AND THE CALL THE- BUT THE
CREEPY WERE COVERED REFINEMENT
I'M NOT THE THAT ARE THAT I GOT
PLAN LOWER WHO REFUSE TO REPAIR
VIOLATE. OR FOUND TO BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. THE BILL EXPAND THE
ALIVE OF GOVERNMENT TO
LANDLORDS THAT IT'S COMPLETE
INSURED NOTHING OBLIGATES.
IMPORTS THE STATE AND EVERY
LITTLE DIRECTION HOW INTEREST
IN ENSURING LANDLORDS NEEDED
OBLIGATION AND DON'T ALLOW
PROPERTY DETERIORATE AS. WE
WORK WITH ALL. RIGHT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AT THE PUBLIC. I
THINK THAT. OUR HOUSING. EVERY
IN OF HOUSING NOT THE COURTS
ALL NOT. WE MUST DO EVERYTHING
WE TO ENSURE BAIT THE PEOPLE TO
ADOPT HOUSING I'M- NOTHING IN
CRITICAL THE FULL WE YOUR
SUPPORT AND QUIRK WITHOUT THANK.
THANK YOU LET'S GO NOW TO BE
ACROSS. TO THE MOD. TO THE
MODERATOR IF WE COULD ALLOW
BRYAN ACOSTA TO TESTIFY. I
DON'T SEE MY LITTLE MIND. LET
ME SEE IF HE'S IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. TO THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM BRIGHT ACOSTA.
IF NOT WHILE WE'RE WAITING ONE
WE GO TO. HOW ARE BRAIN YOU
NEED TO START TALKING OKAY
GREAT GET THERE YOU ARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON OF MEMBER CHAIR
MEMBERS TRYING TO GUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN
ADDITION TO THE POINTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE- SUCH A HUNDRED IS
MADE- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HEAR FROM OUR LEGAL SERVICES
COLLEAGUES ALL THE TIME IS OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO PLACE
CONDITIONS ON AN INSPECTION.
THAT ARE COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE AND IT NOT ONLY
IMPAIRS ENSURING THAT WE GET.
THE REPAIRS MADE THEM EAT BUT
IT ALSO POTENTIALLY AMERICA'S-
THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS OBLIGATION
TO REPAIR IS ON ARE NOT ON THE
TENNIS. AND THE P. OBLIGATION.
NOT SHIFTED TO THE TENANT AND
OF THE TENANT- IS IT NEED
REPAIRS THEY ARE NOT TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THOSE REPAIRS
THEMSELVES UNLESS THE LANDLORD
FAILS TO DO SO AND THEN THE
CAN'T MAKE THOSE REPAIRS AND-
DEDUCT IT BY. EXERCISING THAT
RIGHT IS DEPENDNT ON HAVING
REPORT. FROM THE INSPECTOR.
FROM THAT COULD FORCE THAT
OFFICER. SO TOO OFTEN WE SEE
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
REFUSED TO DO SO INCIDENTS NOT
CURRENT ON THE RENT. OR THE
TENANT HAS HAD SOME OTHER
DISPUTE WITH THE LANDLORD AND
THOSE ARE NOT PROPER ENQUIRIES.
SO WE THINK THIS BILL US OUT OF
UNIFORM A TEXAN STATEWIDE AND
ENSURE THAT ALL TENANTS HAVE
ACCESS TO. AN INSPECTION BY A
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL WHO CAN
ORDER. WHERE APPROPRIATE THAT
THOSE REPAIRS REMAIN SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ABOUT. THANK
YOU TO THE OPERATOR IF WE COULD
HEAR FROM MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT ARE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN YEAH- IF YOU ARE
SHOWING SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER EIGHTY THAT IS
LINE EAT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS YOUR FINAL
MORALITY FROM LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT FORTY
EIGHT THIRTY THREE FIFTY THANK
YOU. I NEXT WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX THAT IS LINE TWO SIX SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OFFERED ON
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT CáC
PROTECTION BUILT IN CALIFORNIA
BUT SOMETIMES YOU SEE WHAT WE
CALL IT FICTION BY NEGLECT
WHERE. LANDLORDS LEFT THE
BUILDING BECOME UNINHABITABLE
AND A BILL LIKE WITH WOULD GO A
LONG WAY IN PRETENDING THAT
KIND OF REALLY UNETHICAL
BEHAVIOR. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IT IS ZERO AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN IT IS ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL BE JUST
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. AND LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX- WE WILL TAKE AS YOU NEXT
IN Q. AGAIN THAT'S TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO IN.
HELLO MY NAME IS HENRY PARKER I
LIVE IN SANTA CRUZ. I'M WHICH
CAN INCREASE INDY. AND ASKING
THIS COURT. A. B. THREE THREE
FIVE TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE'LL GO TO ADD TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWO SIX FOUR. HEY THIS DOESN'T
LOOK BAD. WORK WITH TENANTS
TOGETHER A CALIFORNIA IN A
RIGHT YOU'RE GOING TO BE XIN
AND WE STRONGLY. SUPPORT THE
NEED FOR MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
FROM OUR CODE ENFORCEMENT AND-
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE- I HAVE BY NO
ADDITIONAL PARTIES IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU ONE
WE NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION- TO
THE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW CHRIS LEE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA- STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES TO SPEAK. GO AHEAD
CHRIS LEAD A LINE OF OPEN. HI
THIS IS CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN UP OR THE
MONTH THE MINUTE CONDITION ON
AB THREE THREE FIVE Q. AND WE
AGREED THAT AND IT SHOULDN'T
STATE REASONABLE LIMITATIONS
CONDITION ON THEIR ABILITY TO
ENSURE THE- LIVING THEY MEET.
OKAY HELP AND SAFETY ARE MEANT
ON. THE FOR CONDITION PATTERSON
DIFFICULTY CALL OUT IN THE
BILL- WE ALL AGREE THAT
BUILDING OWNERS I'M SHOULD BEAR
THE COST TO ACTION REPORT I'M
CREATED PURSUIT. RATHER THAN
TENANTS. REASON THAT WE HAVE
BEEN THROUGH ABOUT THE BILL IN
THAT WE TO CONTINUE TO REMAIN
MAINTAINED FROM IMPORTANT LOCAL
DISCRETION WITH REGARD TO HOW
WE ENFORCE AND HOW WE MIGHT
VIOLATIONS OF BUILDING CODE
STANDARDS- WE THINK THERE'S TWO
KEY REASONS FOR THAT FIRST
STOP- WE THINK OF LOCAL
AGENCIES REACT THE BILL WITH
VERY HEAVY HANDED FORCE. IT
COULD HAVE A NEGATIVE THE
PATIENT WHERE YOU COULD JOIN
WITH BUILDING GETTING RED
TAGGED AS NOT FIT FOR HUMAN
HABITATION AND HAVING PEOPLE-
PUSHED OUT OF HOW DO WE THINK
THAT COULD BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
AND THE REASON. I THINK THAT
MIGHT. I GET IT LIMITS
DESCRIBE. AND EXPOSES LEFT SOME
LIABILITY THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
WRAPPED WITH THE PROPERTY
OWNERS. SO WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
CONCERNS AND AGREED- THAT WE
THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO REMOVE
OUR POSITION AND WORK THAT OUT.
AND LOOK FORWARD. TO AT- LOOK
AT HOW TO BE A- THANK YOU ONE
WE NOW GO TO THE SECOND WITNESS
TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW CREAM TO RECEIVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS TO SPEAK. ROOM
THREE THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'D LIKE TO
PREFACE MY REMARKS ARE SIMPLY
BY SAYING THAT YOU DO TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES ON MY END THEY GET
REGRETTABLY MISSION THE AUTHORS
OPENING REMARKS AS WELL AS THE
FIRST- PRINCIPAL WITNESS- FOUR.
HUNDRED THOUGH GET SO MY
APOLOGIES FOR THAT- BUT HAVING
SAID THAT THOUGH GOOD
AFTERNOON. MEMBERS CLEAN GREASE
CAN'T HAPPEN. ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. THANK YOU IT WOULD
OPPOSED. MISSION ON EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY YOU. NINE EIGHTY
THIRTY THREE YOU AMONG OTHER
THINGS. REQUIRES LOCAL. FIRST
IN A COMPLAINT UP LEAD HAZARDS
OR SUCH IN BUILDING. HOWEVER IS
CURRENTLY GRANT HE- THE IT IS
NOT A- CONFLICT SO. EIGHT
EIGHT. WITH THE INSPECTION DID
BUT REPORT THAT HE- HERE ARE
LIKE TO INSURE PROPERTY OWNERS
ARE NOW BILL BUT WOKE UP.
INTERVENTION BUT REPORT WORK
CATION THAT YOU NOT REPEAL ANY
BYERLY. RESULT HE ARMENIANS ME
CERTAIN. THAT LOOK GOVERNMENTS
MAY ONLY LAMP PROTECTION BETTER
REPORTS WORKPLACE THAT REVEALED
INITIAL VIOLATION. YOUR LOCAL
EIGHTY THREE HUMAN FORTY EARTH
FOR THE BILL NINETY OUR
COMMUNITY I NOT EVENING AND
LANGUAGE IN OUR LETTER NINE
MUCH FORWARD WORKING AT THE A
COOPERATIVE SPIRIT
UNINCORPORATED NEVER TO THE
BILL. CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK
AUTHOR OR WITH TO ADDRESS%
CONCERNS. HOWEVER THIS TIME IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTING BUT HE ARE
MOST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NO
QUOTES AND EIGHTY THIRTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO THE MODERATE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SO. UP THE LINE FOR.
OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THE
WISH TO POSE A SPELL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE Q. QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN IT IS
ZERO. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN IT IS ZERO.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN. LINE ONE ONE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE WORLD COUNTIES- THE%
REAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ALIGNING MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. THANK YOU. IF ANYONE
ELSE WISHES Q. Q. UP IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN IT IS
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU TIME LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION. I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AS SOMEBODY'S BEEN WORKING ON
LEAD PAINT ISSUES FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS CYBER GLAD TO SEE
YOU'VE TAKEN STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT. RENTERS HAVE MORE
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE SAFE FROM LEAD HAZARDS
AND OTHER HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS- LOOK FOR THE BILL
TODAY IT TO KNOW THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO BE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. FIND A PATH FOR
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL WORK WITH
THE WAY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HANDLE THESE TEN CASES SO
WITHOUT. LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
A MOTION WITH THIS FOR. I'LL
SECOND THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST TO SAY THAT WE
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THE-
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE ISSUES AT
THE IN THE BILL AS DRAFTED AND
WE WILL DO COMMIT TO FIXING
THOSE. TO THE FLOOR WE'RE ALL
THE SAME PAGE I BELIEVE AS AS
THEY KNOWLEDGE I WILL JUST ADD
THAT- BUT AS FOR THIS BILL CAME
OUT OF AN LA IS ARTICLE THAT I
READ- THAT DESCRIBES SOME
REALLY AGREE JUST CONDITIONS ON
IN SOME LOW INCOME- A MARKET
RATE LOW INCOME HOUSING IN THE
SAN PORTANTINO AREA AND WE WERE
REALLY JUST TO FIND OUT THAT A
LOT OF THE HOMES HAD TO DO WITH
THE REFUSAL TO INSPECT- BECAUSE
OF- THE TENANTS AND PUTTING THE
BURDEN ON THE TENANTS AND-
ACTUALLY LEAD TO THE DEATH OF A
CHILD BECAUSE- ALL TO WHAT.
FILTERING INTO THE MIX THAT AND
I HOPE. TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHU. CHU I DEEP.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA KILEY.
KILEY NO LIMON MAIENSCHEIN
QUIRK SILVA. THE BILL HAS TO
VOTE WILL WILL LEAVE THE DOOR
OPEN FOR ADD ONS NOT CONTINUE
IN AN FILE ORDER WHEN W GO TO
MISTER GIBSON AB TWENTY NINE.
SIXTY.
MR GIPSON PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY I WANT
TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I WANT TO
ALSO POINT OUT TO A VERY KEY
POINTS TO THIS BILL TWENTY NINE
SIXTY ONE. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
GIVE UP CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH A SHELTERED CRISIS
DECLARATION MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
ESTABLISH SHELTERS IN EXISTING
BUILDINGS. TO REQUIRE THOSE
PLANS TO BE APPROVED BY THE
STATE BAR MARSHALL FOR BEING
BEING BEFORE BEING UTILIZED. AS
WELL AS YOU ALL KNOW THAT
HOMELESS ISN'T CALIFORNIA
EPIDEMIC THERE ARE PEOPLE
SUFFERING ON OUR STREETS EVERY
DAY WITHOUT SHELTER MEANS
ANOTHER NIGHT IN DANGEROUS AND
INHUMANE CONDITIONS CURRENT LAW
WICKS SPECIFIC REGULATIONS TO
HELP CITIES. WITH A DECORATOR
DECK BY DECLARED SHELTER-
CRISIS BETTER ADDRESS THEIR
ISSUES FOR A CITY THAT THAT
WANTS TO ECSTATIC A TEMPORARY-
HOMELESS SHELTER. IN AN
EXISTING BUILDING THIS IS PART
THREE PAINS YOU AND REQUIRE
EXTENSIVE AND- SEISMIC AND
SPRINKLERS SYSTEM RETROFIT
DEPENDING ON THE AGE OF EIGHT
AND A SPECIFIC BUILDING THIS
CAN BE VERY COSTLY IN MANY
CASES TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS UP
TO A MILLION DOLLARS AND WILL
OFTEN MAKE THIS PROJECT- NOT
POSSIBLE. AB TWENTY NINE THE.
TURNING TO GET THESE SHELTERS
OPERATIONAL AND HELP MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR HOMELESS CRISIS
AND HELP OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES
REPRESENTATIVE IS THE CHIEF OF
THE HOMELESS- OPERATION FOR THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IS
OFFICE. ON THE LINE. YEAH
CORRECTLY WHEN I VOTE AT THE
PROCEEDS. IF WE CAN NOW GO TO.
PHONE LINES AND TO THE
MODERATOR IF WE COULD GO TO
BRAIN WHICH ARE FROM THE OFFICE
OF MAYOR GARCIA. THANK YOU
BRING WHICH THERE'S LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BRIAN BUCKNER AND THE
CHIEF OF HOMELESSNESS
OPERATION. IN ST STRATEGIES FOR
MAYOR CARCETTI IN LOS ANGELES.
LEAVE AT THE PROPOSED BILL
CONTAINS COMMONSENSE
CLARIFICATIONS AND CHANGES TO
STATE LAW THAT WOULD ALLOW
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
DECLARED A SHELTER CRISIS.
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS THE LACK
OF SHELTER BUT ACROSS THE STATE.
STATE LAW CONTINUE TO PRESENT
CHALLENGES TO THE CITING AN
APPROVAL OF TEMPORARY HOMELESS
SHELTER PROJECTS. THIS IS THE
CASE EVEN WHEN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES IS A CRITICAL
SHORTAGE OF SHELTER BEDS.
DECLARES A CRISIS MEETING.
EARLY TAILORED REFORMS WORKABLE
ONLY UNDER EMERGENCY CONDITIONS
CAN DRAMATIC THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH PERMITTING
THESE PROJECTS. UNDER EXISTING
LAW. THE STICKING TO CONVERT
EXISTING BUILDINGS INTO
TEMPORARY HOMELESS SHELTERS
OFTEN MOST COLLEGE SPENT FIRE
MY TAKE THE UPGRADE. IF THE NEW
USE OF THE BUILDING IS A
CHANGE. USE THEIR CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS INCLUDING WHEN THE
BUILDING IS ONLY GOING TO BE
USED AS A ON A TEMPORARY BASIS
SUCH AS A WINTER SHELTER. OPEN
FOR ONLY A FEW MONTHS OF THE
YEAR. HOWEVER OTHER TYPES OF
TEMPORARY SHELTERS WHICH MAY BE
OPEN FOR SEVERAL YEARS BUT ARE
NOT INTENDED TO BE PERMANENT
STRUCTURES. STILL REQUIRE
EXPENSIVE UPGRADES ACOSTA
OFTENTIMES MAKE THESE PROJECTS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE. AS A
RESULT THESE PROJECTS ARE NOT
BUILT. BERMAN OVERALL FIRED
LIKE STATE. POINT OF THE CITY'S
BUILDING AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS
WANT VERY MUCH DESTRUCTIVE
NECESSARY BALANCE THE PEOPLE TO
PARTICLES OF HAVING ACCEPTABLE
SHELTERS. SHELTERS WHICH WILL
OFFER THEM THE MOST NECESSARY
LEVELS OF PROTECTION SAFETY.
EXAMPLES OF CURRENT SAFETY
MEASURES INCLUDE. REQUIRING
SMOKE AND CARBON MONOXIDE
DETECTORS. FIRE EXTINGUISHERS
WITHIN SEVENTY FIVE FEET EVERY
PORTION F THE FACILITY
EMERGENCY LIGHTING ALARMS
DEVICES INTO FOUR HOUR FIRE
WATCHES. THAT'S WHY ANY. ACTION
IN THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
SHOULD FIRST PROVED BY THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL THAT IS ALSO
WHY THE USING THE BUILDING IN
LIFE SAFETY STANDARDS AND THE
FACT THAT THE TIME THE BUILDING
WAS ERECTED. MUST ALSO INCLUDE
THOSE REQUIREMENTS. THE BILL
USED AN OCCUPANCY FROM THAT
TIME HE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU LET ME
ASK IF THERE MEMBERS OF THE
UBLIC THAT WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
SUPPORTERS. Q. AND IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN THE
QUEUE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IS THERE NO COMMENT.
FOR OPPOSITION GREAT LET'S
SEPARATE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS. WHAT IS THE
AUTHOR I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
WITH THE MY OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL I KNOW
WE'RE TRAINING TO CREATE A
PROCESS TO PROTECT PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY FROM A FIRE AND
OTHER THINGS LIVING IN
EMERGENCY SHELTERS BUT ALSO MAX
AS IN. OTHER BILL IS IN.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS I
THINK THE MOMENT STEPTOE WORKED
OUT ADDRESS TEN. THAT WE ARE
CREATING A PROCESS FOR STATE
FARM MARSHALL TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE THESE- WITH THAT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT IT. ANY FINAL WORDS.
YES THE STATE IS THE ONE I
THINK AMERICA'S THE BACHELOR
AND HIS TEAM FOR BRINGING THIS.
ON THE SANDS IS LEGISLATION AND
ALSO TO ADDRESS THE BEARS THAT
EXAM AND I THINK IS THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
MOTION TO MOVE FOR. THE SECOND
THANK YOU. MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TO. OUR Q. ID.
DEEP I GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA.
KILEY THEN FINALLY IT MON
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA. THE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES GREAT WILL
LOW WEIGHT FOR ADULT MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU- ACTUALLY
MISS COURTS OF WILL AND AT THIS
MOMENT QUIRK SILVA AYE RIGHT.
LET'S PROCEED TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN.
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
TO TURN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN A BILL TO
BUILD HOUSING NEAR TRANCE-CENTERS JOBS. AB THIRTY ONE OH
SEVEN WILL PERMIT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITH AT LEAST 12%
OF UNITS FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO BE ALLOWED ON ANY
SITE DESIGNATED FOR COMMERCIAL
USES. THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF A OF
AVAILABLE SITES FOR HOUSING
WHILE MAINTAINING THE CHARACTER
OF THE COMMUNITY. HOUSING
PROJECTS WILL BE LIMITED TO
INFILL SITES AND SPECIFIED
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS REQUIRE
THAT THE HEIGHT AND DENSITY OF
THE PROJECTS NEAR THE
SURROUNDING RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL EXEMPTS%
SITES THAT ARE ADJACENT TO
AREAS DESIGNATED FOR INDUSTRIAL
USES TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF RESIDENTS. EXACT
CITIES FOR STONE'S THAT- FOR
THEIR- RINA CYCLE. BECAUSE THE
SUPPORT THE BILL ARE MARINO
WYANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND ANDREA OSGOOD VICE
PRESIDENT OF REAL ESTATE TO BE
EATEN HOUSING. IF I COULD ASK
THE MODERATOR IF WE COULD- IT
HERE FROM OUR FIRST WITNESS
MARIN ALLIANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
YOU KNOW WHY IT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MARINO WIND
BUT THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM THE AGENCY IS A NON
PARTISAN ADVOCATE FOR THE
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION. OF
HAVING AFFORDABLE BLOWING MY
ARE YOU CAN CALIFORNIANS.
REPRESENTED ABOUT INSULTING
FINANCIAL AND PUBLIC SECTORS
THE NIGHT IN THEIR GOAL THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIA HAVE A STATE A
FORMAL PLACE TO CALL HOME WE
ARE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR AB
THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN WHICH WILL.
TOLERATE YET. THREE DAY BEFORE
WILL HAVE. EVEN BEFORE THAT
NINETY THE CALIFORNIA FAVORITE
SHOW OF ONE FORM HOW AFFORD TO
DOES AMOUNT WITH A HIGH AND
FIFTY THOUSAND OR ANYTHING HOME.
AND ANY GIVEN NIGHT AND THEN.
OKAY MORE THAN FIFTY OF INCOME
RENT. IT KNEW QUITE. ENHANCE
BIKE HOW DINING A OR WHAT HOW
CHALLENGE AND IT NEVER BEEN
IMPORTANT. PART STATE LEADERS
TO WAYS TO ENSURE ACT THAT THE
FOR HOME. THE LIMITED AND
THEY'LL OF SITE CAN GREATLY
TRAIN TO DEVELOP OF CRITICAL
FOR HOUSING IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT I'M NOT. OF THERE AT
THIRTY ONE OF ON IT OPENS THE
BESIDE BUDGET THAN THOUSAND
DON'T MEET THE. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY AND WITH PROP APPROVAL.
MANY LOCAL GUY ALRIGHT ALLOW
JUST OF BY THE- TO. IN THEM.
NOT BE ANGELA FOR EXAMPLE
THAT'S NOT HAS. ALLOWED TO TRY
OR IN CAN YOU. TO TRY AND BRING
MUCH UP FOR HOUSING. TO AND
SHOT. AT THIRTY ONE SEVEN. AND
AT THE- HOCKEY IT MIGHT. READ
WE ARE JUST TODAY AT NINE
EIGHTY THREE AT THAT I. AND
HAPPY CAMPER AND. VERY MUCH GO
TO WITNESS NUMBER ANDREA OSGOOD.
TO THE MODERATOR YES GOOD
AFTERNOON. THERE ARE COULD
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS OLD.
GREAT A GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE
OUT WOULD BE HELPING. EVEN THE
NON. AFFORDABLE BILLS IN THE
BAY AREA. IN WE HAVE BEEN
CONCERT WITH YEAR. DEVELOPING
HOW FOR. THE MEDIA AND- YEAH.
ORDER I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT. IN
MY ROLE YOU DO NOT ALWAYS
LOOKING. AND. WELL I OTHER
LEGISLATION HELPED CREATE AN
ONLINE SITE SUCH AS THE-
LANDLOCKED AT THE STATE LEVEL
THE CURRENT WORKING ON FATE THE
WE WERE TO BUY CAL. PHYSICALLY
BECAUSE OF PROVISION REALLY
AREN'T FOR THE HELPING. WHAT
ARE ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT IT
COULD HELP US UNLOCKED CERTAIN
THAT MIGHT NOT BE A TO OTHER.
THE KLAY TARGET DEVELOPMENT SO
ARE YOU PUT THE TELL THANK YOU
VERY. THANK YOU LET ME ASK THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ALLOW TO
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS- TO GIVE THEM ACCESS
ONLINE. YOU HAVE ONE HERE THE
AUDIENCE WILL TESTIFY ANSWER
PLEASE PARKS THERE IS THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTY IN
SUPPORT GREAT. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE DAY IN A
ROW IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO AGAIN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND TWO ZERO. MY NUMBER ONE
HOW. MANY. NINE SEVEN. MR
MEMBERS LOSE MORE ON DAY I'LL
BE HAVE A CALIFORNIA BE HERE TO
OFFER OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO MY NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN THAT IS LINE FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR A BAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT. AND
ACTUALLY GO TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY THAT IS LINE
TWO NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT PROP AND I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M WITH
HIM REACTION I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN THAT IS FLYING TO EIGHT
SEVEN GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBER SEVEN MATTER THAT
MIGHT HELP PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THAT COALITION
INCLUDING THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
GUARANTEE CO FOUNDATION
PARTNERS. PLANNING AND URBAN
RESURGENT ALTERNATIVE AND
HABITAT MEDI CALIFORNIA'S
WORKING HERE. NATIONAL GO TO
LINE FOR SIXTY TWO THAT IS
LINED SIX TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MISTER
OGILVIE AND I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M WITH SAN
FRANCISCO YOU IN THE ACTION-
AND I AM CALLING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO FIND CHILL. AND EIGHT
POINT TWO EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHALF AND THE THEORY
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
THREE ONE ZERO SEVEN. IN ORDER
TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE THAT IS ONE NINE.
IT'S GOING. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TOM BRADY HAVING
SUPPORT NOT ONLY WITHOUT
REGARDING HELP BRING IT ALSO
THAT IS BETWEEN CITY YOU GO
DOWN- CAMINO RIEL MANGITA SO
BADLY DONE THROUGH THE LAST
SPRING SOME DOCTOR COMMERCIAL
BUT- OUR- WE HAVE MY NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE THAT IS LINE EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOLLARS
WAS. WE HAVE A HER ACT YOU PORT
IF YOU. WE HAVE A NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX LINE TWO
FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS COUNTY BEING CLINTON
HOW ALSO- NOT PRESENT. FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY EIGHT LINE TWO EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA
HONOR ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NXT LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE THAT A FLYING TWO NINE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND-
RUNNING HI THIS IS LAURA ON
BEHALF OF YOU IN THE ACTION
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO
TO NINE HUNDRED AT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT THAT IS LINE
TWO FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE WORK OF THE
HANDS BURKE I'M WITH THE IN THE
GROUP PEOPLE FOR HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY ALSO CALLING TO SUPPORT.
WHEN TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE LINE Q. EIGHT NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BOBBIE
LOVE. YOU'RE CALLING OFF INTO
OF AB THIRTY ONE SEVEN WE
COMMITTED A LETTER THAT INTO
THAT WE GET STUDY OF SHOPPING
IN OFFICE PARKING LOT THE BAY
AREA HE IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED
FIVE LARGER THAN. ONE EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE. I HAVE HELPING.
BECAUSE OF THE A PROBATION SO
WE ARE. POURTANT THEIR
LEADERSHIP. WE'LL GO TO LINE AT
SIX THAT IS LINE SIX ZERO GOING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STILL BE FOR OUR AND WE
HAVE TO FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
ONE OR TWO HUNDRED THAT IS LINE
TWO ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
ZERO ZERO. OUR TWO ZERO HERE
YOU MAY HAVE YOUR PHONE NEEDED
PLEASE CHECK YOUR PHONE. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TO WAIT SIX. THIS
IS DANNY JORDAN YOUR COMPLAINTS
OF PATIENT WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN SPEAKING TO-
DOCTOR'S OFFICE ABOUT FAR MORE
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND TO BE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORK ON THANK
YOU. WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO.
EIGHTY THREE THAT IS LINE TWO
EIGHT THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M CALLING. AND ANYWAY I'M
CALLING REPRESENTING THE
RESIDENTS UNITED NETWORK AS
WELL AS THE RENT AND
EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM AND WE ARE
IN TOTAL SUPPORT AT THIS AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE IT GO TO. MY
NAME. LINE TO HUNDRED NINETY
SIXTY NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME ADDRESS THE
LACK OF BEING A CREAM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY AT HOME THANK
YOU. YEAH MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR LINE Q. FIVE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FIGHT FOR THE LINE IS OPEN. I
WANT TO FIGHT FOR YOU MAY WANT
TO CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE WE
DO HAVE TO LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
LUNCH WORK. IN THE QUEUE THAT
PLANE NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT LINE
SIX EIGHT PLEASE CALL. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE SIXTY EIGHT THE
LINE IS OPEN. BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FIELD SAID COMPANY
IS STRONG IN THE SUPPORTER IN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT THAT IS LINE
TO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS K. BURKE FROM THE
BELMONT HARBOR INDUSTRIAL AREA
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE- WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIX LINE TWO ZERO
SIX GO AHEAD THE TURN OF THAT
KEPT ME I'M AT SIXTY FIVE AN
ORANGE COUNTY ALTHOUGH THE-
WORK. YEAH I KNOW I KNOW AND
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU WHAT WE NOW GO TO THE
OPPOSITION- WE SHOULD HAVE. I
SEE ONE OF THE OPPONENTS HERE
MISTER MARTIN- WANT TO TESTIFY.
IS THE CHAIR MEMBERS RAN BORN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION BY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. EXPRESS OUR
CONCERT WITH THE BILL- THIS IS
ALL AS MENTIONED EARLIER HOW
IT'S AN TAKE AS MANY. POSSIBLY
CAN TO ROUTE. SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT JUST. BECAUSE AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN. REPORTER THE
WEAKNESS IN AB THIRTY ONE OH
SEVEN AND SEVERAL OF THE OF THE
OTHER BILLS. IS THE LOW
PERCENTAGE THAT IS APPLIED TO
THE EXTREMELY LOW AND VERY LOW
INCOME REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
GET THE BENEFIT OF THE BILL.
TWENTY FIRST. WHEN YOU COMPARE
THAT TO WHAT THE NEED IS IN
CALIFORNIA. AGAIN TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM THE DEPARTMENT OF.
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT HAS ESTIMATED THAT
THE NEED IN CALIFORNIA- FOR
HOUSING IS 70% OF IT NEEDS TO
BE DIRECTED TO V. L. I N. E. L.
I. TENANTS- THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE INDICATED
SIMILAR NUMBERS. IF WE BELIEVE
WE'RE GOING TO REVERSE THAT
SITUATION WITH TWENTY FIRST
HERE 20% THERE THEN WE'RE NOT
EVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
AHEAD THE CARD WILL FIND OUR
SCHOOLS CAN WE TO GET PERSON WE
TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT. THE
HOUSING PROVIDING. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE AND WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUES ABOUT
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF
PROJECTS. WE DO SUGGEST THAT IN
BILLS LIKE SB THIRTY ONE OH
SEVEN. MS EGGMAN STILL- AB
TWENTY FIVE IN WHICH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROPERTIES. THAT
ARE ALREADY KOMMER IS OWNED OR
FORMER TELLS IN MOTELS. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TRANSITION COSTS
RE PURPOSING US THEY'RE
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN GROUND
UP STRUCTURE- AND SO SHOULD BE
ABLE TO REQUIRE OF THOSE
DEVELOPER. MUCH HIGHER SENATE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE LOWEST.
AND WE WILL NEVER GET AHEAD OF
CURVE IF WE DON'T SOME CHANGES
TO SOME THESE BILLS. AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH HIGHER. WITH YOU.
ME ASK OF THE MODERATOR COULD
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR THE SECOND
ONE IS KEITH GRINNING FROM
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA. TURNING
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU YOU KNOW I'M
KEEP TURNING FORMERLY. AS
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
PLANNING ROUNDTABLE WHEN A
MEMBER WILL DOUBLE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AN
ORGANIZATION OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS DEDICATED TO
THE SOFT OF A NATION WIDE SPLIT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. SB THIRTY
ONE OH SEVEN IS A TOP DOWN ONE
SIZE FITS ALL MANDATE TO
UNILATERALLY RESULT IN JUST
ABOUT EVERY COMMERCIAL SITE
EVERY CITY AND COUNTY OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS NOT ABOUT
GOOD PLANNING IT'S ABOUT POUND
CRAMMING IMPOSING HIGH DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT SOPRANO COMPUTER
THESE REGARDLESS OF THE
CONSEQUENCES. IT'S ALSO ANOTHER
TOP TWO WROTE THE SELF
DETERMINATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE CITIES AND COUNTIES.
ONE OF WHICH PROVISIONS
REQUIRES A 75% OF THE PERIMETER
OPEN. COMMERCIAL SIDE TO BE
WRITTEN FOR HOUSING. WE DEVELOP
WITH URBAN USES WITHOUT
DEFINING THAT TERM WE WERE ABLE
TO FIND A TERM IN STATE LAW
ABOUT GLOBAL NEWS ISN'T
SEXUALLY ALLOWS EVERYTHING
EXCEPT FOR AGRICULTURE AND OPEN
SPACE. IT ALSO CALLS FOR
BUILDING. AT THE GREATEST
DENSITY AND WITH THE HIGHEST
BUILDING HEIGHTS ALLOWED WITHIN
A HALF MILE RADIUS OF THE SITE.
THE OCEAN SMALL COMMERCIAL USES
AND ESTABLISH SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS HISTORIC
DISTRICTS AND WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES. ARE SQUARELY IN
THE BILL'S CROSSHAIRS FOR TALL
HIGH DENSITY BUILDINGS. AROUND
CHARACTER WITH THE
NEIGHBORHOODS. IT IS ALSO A CO
GOOD WORD IT'S TIME THAT THE
STATE TAKE REAL STOCK IT WOULD
SOFTEN FULLY UNDERSTAND THIS
NEW WORLD WE LIVE IN. ALSO
RESET BUTTON ON A SEPARATESET
HOUSING LEGISLATION. DOES
LOCATION SIR BY CROWDED NOT
WHICH TRANSIT IS NOT THE
ANSWER. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TO SPELL. THANK YOU LET ME US
THE MODERATOR IF THERE ARE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE
AND WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN IT ZERO AGAIN THAT IS ONE
OF THEM ZERO. WE HAVE NINE
THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI HI SIR AND ACTUALLY KICKING
APARTMENTS BEFORE- MY NAME IS
ACTIVE. CALLING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WITH URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LUNCH LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THAT'S
LINE ONE ONE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD.GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN KING OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE PATIENT. AND
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA NOT IN OPPOSITION
BUT WE HAVE EXPRESSED- A
HANDFUL OF CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL I APPRECIATE THE READ AND
AMENDMENTS AND WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE. AND NINETY
FOUR THAT IS LINE TWO NINE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU LINE
TWO NINE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE LINE IS OPEN.I ONCE AGAIN
LINE TO NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. IT
WILL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED TWO ZERO ZERO THE LINE
IS OPEN. ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY BE THIS TIME THANK
YOU. OUR NO RESPONSE THERE- WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT OVER LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY COPS ON THIS
BILL. AT WHAT AGE THERE IS ONE
OTHER PERSON IN THE QUEUE IT
FLAT TO NINETY FOUR I GOT YOUR
LINE OR- GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE
THAT MCELROY I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE WESTERN QUADRANT OF NORTH
LAMAR PARK IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE GREAT
BIRD AVENUE BLOCK BOB WE ARE IN
THE CAR HERE OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER CAREFULLY. WHAT YOU BE
FINE TO ESTABLISH NEIGHBOR SUCH
AS OURS I REPRESENT ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED. LOT OF INCOME
INDIVIDUAL WHO DO WE HAVE HOME.
AND WE ASK THAT YOU WILL HOLD
THE BILL. I'M GONNA GO BACK TO
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TRY
THAT AGAIN LINE TWO HUNDRED THE
LINE IS OPEN. YET THAT IT CAN
KIND OF WITH A BETTER WAY
FORWARD HOW CALIFORNIA. WERE
ACTUALLY SUPPORT IF AMENDED AND
WE ARE CURRENTLY HAVING GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
THAT DISCUSSION IS BECAUSE
THANK YOU. YEAH NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN THAT
IS LINE TWO SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS WILLIAM GOOD ONE I AM A
MEMBER OF THE RESIDENT
EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
RESIDENTS UNITED AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I'M ON HEALTH
NEIGHBORS. CONTINUE TO BE A-
THAT'S WHY THIS FUNDING IN THIS.
THE CENTURY AND THE I URGE THAT
WE SUPPORT THIS. THANK THANK
YOU WE HAVE ONE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED THAT AIRPLANE THREE
ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS RICK ALL IN AN
EFFORT TO GET THE. I'M SORRY
WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE HEARING
YOU IF YOU CAN GET CLOSER TO.
THANK SPEAKER PHONE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS RECALL RELATING
ANTI GENTRIFICATION ACTIVISTS
IN THE MISSION DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO I OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL BASICALLY.
DISRUPT ALL OF MANY MANY
NEIGHBORHOODS BY REPLACING THE
ON- MOM AND POP STORES WITH
HIGH DENSITY- MARK IT HOUSING
AND THE 20% AFFORDABLE IT NO
WHERE NEAR ENOUGH THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU LET'S SEPARATE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- THINK MR COLLEGE OF
A QUESTION. I YEAH I MORE I
LIKE TOM AND I'M THAT. I'M
QUITE SENSITIVE TO THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHEN HOUSING AT THE
SAME- STANDARDS ON VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BUT- TIME I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT RECOGNIZE THE ZONING
ITSELF LEE. IT ALL. LAWS ARE
BEING USED IN A WAY TO CREATE
STATEWIDE PROBLEMS I THINK THAT
THAT ADMITS OF A YOU KNOW YEAH
REVISITING THE STATE LAW AND
THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE SEE
WITH WITH WITH ZONING IN IN
SOME SORT. OF THEIR- I. IN
ORDER THE NATIONAL HOUSING HAVE
IN THIS SO YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
INTERESTING SOLUTION HERE I
PERSONALLY WOULD HAVE PREFERRED
IT IT DIDN'T YOU IS THAT. CHINA
INCLUSIONARY. AS THE- TASK YOU
KNOW GETTING A RELAXATION OF
ZONING STANDARDS- I GENERALLY
THINK WE NEED TO BUILD MORE. IN
GENERAL IN THE- AND IT. ON
INCLUSIONARY ZONING IS QUITE
MIXED BUT I DO THINK IT'S
BETTER THAN YOU. L'APPLICATION
ZONING SINCE THE MANDATE ONLY
APPLIES IT AS MUCH AS YOU WANT
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A LOT OF
THE PARTICULAR RELEASE OF THIS
BILL OFFERS SO. I'M I YEAH I
THINK THAT THIS IS A POSITIVE
STEP THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
CREATE MORE HOUSING THAT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED SO- ALL THE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU COLIN APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS I THINK- THESE THESE
ARE DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS
AND- APPRECIATE ROCKNESS ON
THIS. I WANT TO THANK MISTER
BLOOM FOR MOVING FORWARD AN
IMPORTANT HOUSING IDEA AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK HIS STAFF. AND
SPONSORS WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR STAFF AND SO. THE STATE OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT GOING
THROUGH THAT COMMITTEE TO
REALLY REFLECT. HE CONCERNS ARE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT. MAY HAVE
ABOUT THIS I THINK WITH- THE
PARAMETERS WE'VE ADDED TO THE
BILL. IT WILL RESULT IN BEING
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD SOME REAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD HOUSING
BUT DOING THAT IN APPROPRIATE
LOCATIONS- I WANT TO. TAKE A
MOMENT. I KNOW THERE WAS A-
SUGGESTION THE 20% NUMBER.
HIGHER AND BELIEVE YOU. I WOULD
BE. FOR US TO HAVE THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE. EVERY POSSIBLE. BUT I
THINK WE- A BIT UNREALISTIC
GIVEN FIND UNLESS HAVE. A
BILLING OF DOLLARS THAT WE CAN
USE TO HELP SUBSIDIZE THIS I
KNOW EVEN IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO- WE'VE DONE ECONOMIC
STUDIES BY ALL. BY ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TAKING PART
IN THIS CONVERSATION AND 20%
TO. IS A VERY HIGH THRESHOLD SO
UNLESS THERE ARE. IS AND SO
THIS I THIS IS TOUGH COME. I
THINK CERTAIN DURING THIS TIME
OF CORONAVIRUS WHEN WE KNOW HOW
MANY EMPTY STOREFRONTS AND
COMMERCIAL YEARS ARE GONNA BE
CHALLENGED IT IS AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR US TO TAKE A MOMENT
SAY. IT MAKES SENSE. THIS IS
PROPERTY OWNERS CAN'T MAKE IT
THE COMMERCIAL AND FOR US TO
CONVERT THAT TO HOUSING. SO AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT. THIS
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THEY'RE
AND MANY MANY- INCENTIVES FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ZONE
PROBABLY MORE THAN THEY NEED TO
IN CERTAIN AREAS- COMMERCIAL
ZONING AND I THINK THIS BILL
ELITE. TO MOVE RECESSION BACK.
ON NOW I JUST READ THAT- SENATE
I KNOW IN THEIR PROPOSED
PACKAGE TODAY HAD INCLUDES FOR
IT SEP SO. I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION CAN.
SPONSORS PRESENT WILL HELP IS
IT THE VERY MUCH CARE ABOUT
ENSURING WERE. AS MUCH OF A
HOUSING AS WE MOVE THIS FORTS.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. ANYTHING
YOU LIKE TO SING CLOSER AND SEE
THE RESPONDING TO. US IN THE
COMMENTS OF THE MADE OR OR
OTHER THOUGHT YOU'VE HAD WELL I
CERTAINLY AGREE. WITH THE
COMMENTS YOU. UP TO THE- A 20%
OF. RATE BOTTOM LINE IS- THESE
PROJECTS HAVE TO BE AN APPLE
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO-
DEVELOPERS HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PENCIL OUT TO- A PRODUCT. 20%
TO. IS ALREADY PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE AND WE KNOW THAT
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN HIGHER RATES
AND IN SOME CITIES- AROUND THE
STATE. HAVE PRODUCED OF ANY OR
US IN AFFORDABLE. HOUSING
COMPONENT OF THE PROJECTS-
WE'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF CON
SUS- A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO-
EXPRESSED- OTHER THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING GO WITH MY
OFFICE TO IMPROVE THIS ALL OUT-
TODAY. I CAN THE AND WORKING.
AND EVERYONE HAS MY COMMITMENT
THAT'LL CAN TO WORK ON
IMPROVEMENTS TO HE BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO I THANK
YOU AND- ARRIVAL IT THEIR
MOTION WITH THIS. ALL RIGHT
SECOND AND WITHOUT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY. APPROPRIATIONS GEO HI
SHE'LL I DEEP. GABRIEL GIVE
YOUR ALL RAW I'D GLORIA HIGHLY
KILEY AYE LIMóN MAIENSCHEIN
QUIRK SILVA BECAUSE OF A AYE
THE BILL HAS FOR BOTH YOU FOR
VOTING ONE VOTE AND- WILL WAIT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. ONE
WEEK AGO. CONTINUOUS FILE ITEM
TEN AB THREE OH EIGHT MR
GABRIEL.
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT THE BILL
THAT WILL HELP TO INCENTIVIZE
ACTION OF URGENTLY EEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OUR TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL FEES BY TEACHER
HOUSING. LIKE THIS I NOTING
THAT WILL BE TAKING JUST
REMEMBER VICE MEMBER. FELL
BECAUSE MULLIN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND FOR ME AS A
JOINT AB THIRTY THREE AWAY.
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER STAFF
FOR YOUR HARD WORK IN ADVANCE
OF THIS HEARING A BUSY FEW
WEEKS AND HOUSING WORLD
APPRECIATE GETTING US TO THIS
POINT. CALIFORNIA'S A- CRISIS
TOUCHES ALL SECTORS OF OUR
STATE THIS CHALLENGES
PARTICULARLY ACUTE FOR SOME OF
THE MOST MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THE TEACHERS AND
EDUCATIONAL WORKERS EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN. TRYING TO. EL áREA
ENTRY LEVEL TO. SPENT 5% OF
THEIR SALARY TO AN ACT RENTAL
UNIT FACED WITH THIS IMPOSSIBLE
SCENARIO MANY OF OUR EDUCATORS
AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE FORCED
TO WORK SECOND AND JOB.
DIFFICULT CONDITIONS AND YOUR
COMMUTE COMMUTE SO. OR MORE IN
EACH DIRECTION THIS HAS CAUGHT
THIS IS FOR THEIR FAMILIES FOR
EMPLOYEE RETENTION FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT FOR TRAFFIC
CONGESTION ON OUR ROADS AND
MANY OTHER DOWNSIDES. AB THIRTY
THREE RIGHT HELPS TO ADDRESS
THIS CHALLENGE BY EXPLICITLY
CLARIFYING THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN USE THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT TO FINANCE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. ON LET DOWN BY THE
DISTRICT. THIS NECESSARY BE
SHIFTING INTERPRETATIONS OF.
THING ACT BY THE CALIFORNIA TAX
CREDIT OUT PATIENT COMMIT. IN
ABOUT AN- INDIVIDUAL WILL
DESTROY CAN UTILIZE PRESS.
NEEDS THEIR TEACHERS AND I
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES. THIS CAR
FOR CASE IS A MY AND STEP THAT
WILL STRENGTHEN THE TEACHER
HOUSING ACT AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR DISTRICT AROUND OUR STATE
TO BUILD MUCH IT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CATION WORKERS. THE
THIRTY THREE OKAY ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONS FROM SOME ONE WITH.
THE LOCAL. CAN ALL THIS TO BITE
PER RENTAL. FOR MEMBERS OF
THEIR WORK. WITH THE TEST IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE OLDER
SHILOH FROM THE LAWSUIT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND TO LAWRENCE
DURAN FLORES. PRESCHOOL
POLITICIZATION THANK WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN IPHONE
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO WITNESSES
TO THE MODERATOR FIRST IF WE
COULD. OVER SHILOH AS THE FIRST
AS- TO. IF I GO TO BED WE ARE.
FOND OF AB THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
BURKE HOW THEY DISTRICT ON
POVERTY. I THINK THAT ADDRESS
THE HOUSE I CALL OF HOUSING
PROVIDE A- OPTIONS FOR THEIR
WORK. IF YOU. BUT YOU. IT OF
OUR OF THE IDEA OF CREDIT FIND
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
AFFORDABLE UNITS. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND TO LET EARLY
UNIFIED EXECUTE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THIS FUN DISTRICT ON
PROPERTY. THE PROJECT THAT WE
DID AND WE OCCUPIED WHEN YOU'RE
UNITS ARE MADE AVAILABLE THEY
ARE OFFERED TO THEIR ONLY
WORKFORCE BURKE IN ORDER THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND- THE WHITE HOUSE.
BOB QUALIFY FOR WHEN IT BECOMES
INCOME ELIGIBLE GUIDE YOU CAN
PUT FULL AND PART CLOCK BY ONE
FOR YOU. LIBRARY EIGHT. WORKERS
COOPER BURKE AND THE PHONE AND
AMONG. THEY'RE GOING TO BE AT
THE CENTER WAITING LIST I EACH
OF THE HOUSING PODS WITH LITTLE
TENANTS FOR OVER IN MY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CAL TECH
COULD ALLOCATE COMMITTEE
INFORMED DISTRICT COULD NOT.
COME BUT A LOT OF THE- MARKET
TWENTY TWO EXACTLY BIRTH THAT
OF SB THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT
PROVIDE THEM CLASS THAT FOR THE
DISTRICT ACROSS THE STATE COURT
FOR AFFORDABLE COSTS BUT THERE
WORK FOR CAN LEVERAGE TAX CUT
THAT'S PART OF MY MANY OF
AVAILABLE OPTIONS LA UNIFIED.
AND THE HIGH. BAR AT THE CHECK
IN STAFF WHERE WE TOOK TO A
THIRTY OH EIGHT I WOULD REQUEST
YOUR EYES. WE HAVE A WOULD
DISTANCE. ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON MR. GET OUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN NUMBER MY NAME IS THE
WARRANT DURAN FLORENCE AND I
RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ACCEPT PATIENTS YEAH
YEAH WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AB
THREE THREE LA. BELLE WITHOUT A
PORTABLE. OUR A BOY WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO NEAR THE MAY WORK IT
IS ABOUT SCHOOL DISTRICT YEAH
NOT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
EMPLOYEES PROPER. IN A COURT OF
HOUSING BILLS ON THEIR OWN POP.
HE GAVE. FIVE EMPLOYEES. WHO
WORK IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
THROUGHOUT HELPED AND EIGHTY
THREE OH EIGHT FOR HELP. WAIT
FOR. THAT WHEN THEY GET THERE
HAVE AND BLL TO LEARN IN CARE
FOR ACTUALLY CHILDREN EIGHT ARE
SCHOOLS AND IT CAN MAKE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WORKING ON
THE FRONT LINES MAKING SURE OUR
BALL TO. EVERY DAY HE THIS CALL
WHAT AND MARK THERE THE PUBLIC
WAIT TURNER WORKING IN OUR.
FIVE POINT PAID BACK AND MANY
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCE TO DUE TO
ONE OF FOR THE FOR HOW COSTS.
THEY WOULDN'T BECAUSE THEY LOVE
FOOD AN INMATE. WITH THEM. AB
TRAIL EIGHT ONE CREATIVE WHY OF
NET OF MY NOW. AND OTHER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. FOR AFFORDABLE HAVE.
HELLO MY HELLO NEAR THE POOL
WITH A IN A ROW THE CHILDREN
TAKE CARE FOR EVER THAT. IT
ALSO ALLOWS THE PLAYER HELP FOR
YOU. THERE MIGHT BE HERE WE
WANT TO THANK AUTHOR FOR HIS ON
THIS AND ISSUE. YES THE EIGHT.
I THOUGHT. TO THE MODERATE ME
ASK YOU THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS
OF ON THE LINE WHICH THIS
CONSERVE THIS BILL. IF YOU WISH
TO. IN SUPPORT OF BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALL DONE SO. AGAIN YOU MAY BE
ONE. THEN GROW WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER HUNDRED AND SEVEN SIX.
LINE ONE. SIX I HAD. I OKAY.
I'M SORRY THAT DILUTES MARIN
HAPPENED BE AN IMPORTANT THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE LINE AT THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE LINE
THREE TWO ONE. GO AHEAD WHACK.
CHINA AND HAPPY TO CALL FOR
SCHOOL HOW. WE WORK WITH MANY
LOW EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT
ARE TRYING TO IMPROVE THEIR
HOUSING AVAILABILITY IN ORDER
TO ATTRACT RETAIN EMPLOYEES
ABBAS MENTIONS OF THE BIG ISSUE
FOR CLASSIFIED. AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO. COMBINED EIGHT THREO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
MOLECULAR LEADERSHIP THIS ISSUE
I ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF COLLEAGUE BUT SAN DIEGO YOU
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT BOTH
MEASURE. TO HOW DO SOLUTION WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT THE YOU. WE
HAVE A NUMBER THREE HUNDRED IN
NINE LINE THREE ZERO NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. OF MINE DOES WALL
UNTIL ONE I'M WHAT SANTA CRUZ
CAMPAIGN I'M AT FOR YOUR THANK
YOU. WE HAVE MY NUMBER HAD AND
TWENTY SIX AGAIN THAT IS LINE
TWO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NUMBERS TWO SIX MAY GO AHEAD.
HI JEFF MY GARNER AND I WOULD
BE HUNTINGTON BEACH HOW AND I
AM THE FOUNDER OF EACH EACH FOR
WHICH I'VE BEEN FOR HOUSING AND
I HOW DO. A GROUP ON BEHALF OF
BREAD WITH CITY AND SUPPORTER
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT- WE ALSO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE MEMBER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF IN
THE WORKING WORK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MALL AND THE STATE
CREATE DIFFERENT TWENTY TWO
INTO THE. OKAY MY CHIN. THE
BILL. AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THREE HAD AND FOUR LINES TWO.
WE HAD GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS RON
RAP ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THREE
OUT A- HOWEVER WITH THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS YOU
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT GOING
PLACER GIVEN PRIORITY FOR THESE
RENTAL PROPERTIES. AND WORK TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
SPOT THROUGH MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS THE CASE THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WEEK MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX LINE TWO FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HENRY OCHRE I LIVE
IN SANTA CRUZ AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THE REPRESENTATIVE UP
SOUND YOU HEAR ME NILES CREEK
COURT OF THE STATE. THANK YOU.
THE HELP LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT LINE
AT TWO TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE DEMOCRATS CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINE ALIGNED ONE EIGHT NINE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAD
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINE. NINE ONE NINE NINE YOU
MAY WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE ON
YOUR PHONE WE DO HAVE TO LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. EIGHT I WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT STEP PERSON IN
THE QUEUE. THAT IS LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
HANDS BURKE I'M CALLING FROM
PEOPLE FOR HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY. I'M ALL FOR THE WHITE
THE TEACHER AND WE KNOW THAT.
SCHOOL COMMUNITY IS. THE
STUDENTS AND THE TEACHERS BUT
IT ABSOLUTELY INCLUDES THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF TO WERE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SIX
LINE TWO ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEY CAN GET UP TO
<c.cyan>OURTEEN ORANGE COUNTY ALTHOUGH</c>
THE PART OF THE BILL THANK YOU
CAN WE AFFORD. MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE A LINE
IS THREE TWO NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE TWENTY NINE OH I'M
SORRY THE ME OF DISCONNECTED
WILL GO TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TO LINE THREE. HI
CHRIS COUNTY MD AND THEN BE
ACTION AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTY FIVE IN PORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT-
YOU MAY PRESS ONE IT IS THEN IT
IS ZERO AGAIN WORK SUPPORT. ONE
TEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE I
WILL GO TO MY NUMBER ONE NINETY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN. HI LOCAL
NINE ONE NINETY NINE WE DO HAVE
TO LINE OPEN FOR YOU YOU CAN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI YEAH I LIVING
WE DISTRICT SIXTY EIGHT AND I
AM A PART OF SPELL SO I AM SAID
THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL
BE JUST ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT
THAT PERSON IN THE QUEUE.
ARE
THERE ANY FOUR LINE NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN-
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FOUR NINE
THREE THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THOMAS
CARTER I LIVE IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE UN BEES
AND I'M GOING TO ADD TO THIS
REPORT A. B. WE ONE FIVE FIVE
THANK. THANK YOU PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WE ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL. HE WISHED TO OPPOSE THE
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE. THE BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE THE BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE END
YOUR- DO NOT HAVE ANY RESPONSES
ON THIS PLEASE I CONTINUE. DATA
AND SPLIT TESTIMONY ANY. FOR
CALLING. SO HOW DO I DISTRICT
USUALLY COME INTO POSSESSION OF
THIS LAND THIS LAND IN ANOTHER
SCHOOL ON DECIDED NOT TO
ACQUIRE THE LAND FOR HOUSING.
YEAH IT'S YEAH I JUST AND THE
JUST MAY HAVE AVAILABLE THAT
THEY EITHER HAVE CLOSE TO
SCHOOL THAT THEY HAVE HAVING TO
OWN AND- YOU KNOW RATHER THAN
HAVING THAT WAY. AND I DON'T TO
GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
PUT IT TO GOOD USE INTO THE
HOUSE IT WILL BUT- LOOKING
BENEFIT. IS NOT A LAW FIRM-
DISTRICT ACQUIRING LAND
SPECIFICALLY TO BUILD HOUSING.
I'M NOT YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING WE HAD WE HAD
CONSIDERED I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THAT NOW I'M GIVEN YOU KNOW THE
REALITIES OF WHAT WILL COST
OKAY. THE MISSION OF SCHOOL THE
BUDGET CUTS FACE. VERY HARD TO
FORESEE A SITUATION IN WHICH A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD HAVE
ENOUGH CASH ON HAND TO GO OUT
AND PURCHASE LAND IN THE
PRIVATE BURKE AND I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT THE LEGAL RESTRICTIONS
BUT I THINK AS A- MATTER.
SOUNDS TO ME OKAY. SUPPORT THE-
I THINK I'D BE MORE CONCERNED
IF WE WERE. YOU KNOW TURNING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS INTO
DEVELOPERS BASICALLY BY HAVING
TO GO OUT AND PURCHASE LAND.
THERE MAKING USE OF PROPERTY
THAT. IS WHY. THE TERM
OTHERWISE. MAKES SENSE. YEAH I
THINK YOU'RE HAVE IT THAT'S AND
DOWN THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
CHAIR JUST WANT TO RESPOND
APPRECIATE THAT SUPPORT AND I
COULD GET YOU HURT. SO MUCH OF
THE COST OF HOUSING BONDS AN
ACQUISITION OF THAT AND SO THAT
IS A SIR ABOUT LAMBETH ACOSTA.
SAYS I THINK IS WHAT. IS THIS
PENCIL. THAT WHY WOULD WHY
YOU'VE- LAWCENTER SEEN GUILTY A
PRIOR TO SOME OF THE YOU KNOW
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE LANGUAGE
IN THE LAW. I TAKE IT TO BUILD
HOUSING. MATHIS ON THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR THAT. ON TO THE
PHOTOS OF. HER COMPLACENT OF.
YOU AND I'LL JUST ALSO JUMP IN
THAT I AVE NOT HEARD. TOTAL
SCHOOL HAS. TO BE A TO BUILD TO
BE LAND THAT THIS. IN THERE IN
THEIR DAY FOR OTHER RE AT THE
NOW WANT PUT TO PUT TO YOU
SINCE THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
BUILDING SCHOOL ON IT- LET ME
JUST THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING OFFICE. IN FOR MOVING
THIS FOR I ALSO WANTED.
PERSONAL ACCOUNT. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AS A TEACHER
OF THIRTY YEARS I KNOW- I WOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN
TEACHING THE SAME DAY CORRECT
TOM HARDY. THE MONEY OF OUR
YOUNG TEACHERS ARE NOT ONLY.
TRAVELING BUT SOMETIMES WELL
OVER AN HOUR TO GET TO THEIR
DISTRICT AND MANY TIMES THOSE
DISTRICTS ARE IMPACTED AREAS.
AND WE KNOW THAT WHEN THEY CAN
GET AN OPPORTUNITY ON THAT
OFTEN THEY WILL LEAVE THAT
DISTRICT HAS INVESTED IN THEM
IN ORDER TO FIND. A TEACHING
JOB AT. CLOSER O. THEY WANT TO
LET THIS CERTAINLY I THINK IS
ANOTHER STEP FORWARD AND NOT
ONLY DO I SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT
I'VE ALSO KNOW THAT THEY WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT IN CHURCHES
USING SOME OF THEIR LAND AND I
THINK THE MORE WE- BILLS. WERE
THERE ARE TWO. THERE'S NOT.
THANK YOU I AS A SAYING BEFORE
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
WITH OUR OFFICE ALSO ON A
PARTICULAR THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN EMERGING ASPECTS
OF HIS BILL. HI HIS BILL WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE MORE AVAILABLE TO. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN A COUNTY AND YOURS
WOULD MAKE IT SPECIFIC THAT-
THAT- THAT THE TEACHER. VOICE
OF THE SCHOOL THAT WOULD BE UP
USE IT AND- AM OUR- POLICY
RIGHT NOW HERE'S A- GIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE
THEY WANT TO USE. AND WHAT
MIGHT. SENSE TELL ME MAY A
LITTLE SENSE AND LA EXPECTORANT
pYOUR VEHICLE TO MERGE THESE
CONCEPTS AND WITH THAT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT- ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
IT'S ONE TO THINK YOU WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
EVERYBODY HAPPY TO MERGE THESE
BILLS AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I. AS FOR. THE
MOTION AND SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED Q. HI JILL I
DEEP. GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I'D
GLORIA KILEY KILEY IDLY MOM
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA AYE THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES ON CALL IS ON CALL THANK
YOU. WHEN WE GO TO IF FOR A
SCRIPT SO IF YOU'RE READY FOR
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE FIVE.
IF YOU WANT TO
PLEASE PROCEED AND I'M JUST
GONNA TALK TO THE BACK TO TRY
TO EAT A SANDWICH IN THE NEXT
TWO MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND AS WE HAVE.
MEMBERS COMING IN AND OUT I
ANY. STILL WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU- HEAR THE TESTIMONY
ABOUT AB TWENTY. EIGHT NINETY
FIVE. AS WE'VE HEARD MANY MANY
TIMES TODAY IN OUR HEARING. A
HOUSING IS AN SHORTAGE. WE HAVE
A HOMELESS CRISIS. AND WE ARE
INDEPENDENT AND THE THAT A
PANDEMIC. UP WHICH- MEANS THERE
ARE ESTIMATES. UP TO TWO. THAT
FALLING INTO HOMELESS. SO AS WE
THAT SEEN AND AS WE LOOK AT
THIS COMMITTEE IT'S A VERY VERY
SERIOUS COMMITTEE THAT DEALT WE
NEED TO MAKE EVERY ATTEMPT TO
MOVE HOUSING INITIATIVES
FORWARD. AT THE SHORE WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA HERS HAVE ALSO
EXPERIENCED RENT INCREASES AT
UNPRECEDENTED RATES.
HOMEOWNERSHIP HAS BECOME.
UNATTAINABLE FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS AND WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT THE LOWEST INCOME
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALSO TALKING
ABOUT OUR MILLENNIALS ARE ADULT
CHILDREN MOVING BACK HOME AND
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ARE MIDDLE
CLASS STUDIES SHOW THAT 40% OF
AMERICANS ARE ONE STEP AWAY
FROM POVERTY. WE KNOW IN THIS
PAN I'M AT THAT THAT TESTED
THAT MANY OF OUR FELLOW. BIRDS
AT FRIENDS HAVE USED EVERY BIT
OF THEIR SAVINGS AND NOW ARE
LOOKING AT POSSIBLE OF ACTIONS.
THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY PEOPLE WHO NEVER IMAGINED
THEM SELVES IN A SITUATION OF
BEING HOUSING TO KEEP. ARE
LOOKING AT THAT SAID. UNDEAD
PANDEMIC THE HOUSING CRISIS AND
HOMELESS ISSUES OF OUR STATE
HAS GROWN WHEN FROM BEFORE
COVETED NOW. ONE OF AN OPTIONS
THAT MANY PEOPLE AS THEY LOOK
TOWARDS RETIREMENT. INVESTED IN
WERE MOBILE HOMES FOR THIS
TODAY THERE HAVE BEEN TWO OTHER
MOBILE HOME BILLS SO I CONSIDER
THOSE UP ACTED YOUR MOBILE HOME
BILLS. EXACTLY THE LOOK AT
MOBILE HOME RENTERS AND MOBILE
HOME OWNERS AND TO NOTE ACTS
THE FACTS ARE THAT MOBILE
HOMES. ARE NOT MOBILE THEY ARE
MOBILE TO NOTE THAT MANY PEOPLE
WHO USE OR CHOOSE TO LIVE IN A
MOBILE HOME. OUR SENIORS ARE
RETIRED AND EXPECTED THAT
INVESTMENT TO BE. PART OF
RETIREMENT AND TO BE ABLE TO
RETIRE AND LIVE IN THE MOBILE
HOMES THAT THEY CHOSE. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN AN
INCREASED. EFFORT TO SELL
MOBILE HOME PARKS AND TURN
THOSE MOBILE HOME PARKS INTO A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF HOUSING. AS
WE LOOK AT THIS ONE QUOTE HUGE
QUESTION TO ASK IS WHAT ABOUT
THOSE SENIORS WHO HAVE INVESTED%
IN THAT PROPERTY WHAT WOULD BE
THEIR NEXT STEP. THIS SCENARIO
DEVELOPED IN MY HOMETOWN FULLER
TEN IN MY DISTRICT THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS SIXTY FIVE WHERE A
MOBILE HOME PARK WAS SOLD AND
WITH AND MONTHS OF SELLING THE-
RESIDENT. READ IF THE TWENTY
PERCENT. PAY INCREASE WHICH FOR
MANY OF THEM- IS JUST KIND OF
DOUBLE. WITH ANAHEIM TEN AS THE
MOBILE HOME PARK STRETCHES
BETWEEN THOSE TWO CITY BOTH
CITIES DELIBERATED ABOUT
POSSIBLE SUPPORT FOR MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS BUT IS IT TURNED
OUT ANAHEIM CAME UP WITH NO
SOLUTIONS FULLER TEN DID SOME
LOW. OR A SHORT SUBSIDY FOR
THESE MOBILE HOME RIGHT RENTERS
BUT EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE ABLE TO
HELP THE MOBILE HOME RENTERS
RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THOSE FUNDS
ARE RUNNING NOW. AND IT ALSO
KEEPS THEM FROM HELPING OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE AND HOMELESS
SITUATION GEN SO WHAT MY BILL
DOES MY BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY FIVE EXPAND PROTECTION.
AND RENT INCREASE IS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO OWN A MOLE.
BUT RENT THE LAND AND THE
THOUGHT HOME RESIDES ON AS- THE
WHO RENT A MOLD HOME FROM A
PART OWNER. THE RESIDENTS A
RANCHO LOS. AS I JUST KNOW ALL
OUR SOMEBODY THAT I KEEP IN
MIND AS I KNOW MANY OF THESE
PARK A RENTERS. WE HAVE MET
THEY HAVE COME UP TO ME TO ASK
FOR SUPPORT AND THEY ARE
STRUGGLING. THEY ALL ARE
WANTING TO LIVE. WE ACTUALLY
HAVE FOUR YEAR OLD VETERAN
LIVING IN THIS PARK AND THEY
PLANNED ON RETIRING THERE AND
NOT IS MY WHOLE BUT NOT JUST
FOR FULLER TO ANAHEIM. BUT
ACROSS THE STATE THAT WILL BE
CAN. LOOK AT LEGISLATION THAT
WILL HELP PROTECT THEM- WE DO
HAVE- SUPPORTERS ON THE PHONES
ALL MOVE TOWARDS HEARING THEIR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ONE WE GO TO OUR- WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE TO THE MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ALLOW BRYAN
ACOSTA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION OF SPEAK. ACTUALLY
REALLY SEASON THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM SO HALF BRIGHT
IF YOU WANNA START SPEAKING.
GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS BRIAN A GUEST ON BEHALF
OF THEIR CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. PLEASE
DO. A SUPPORT THIS BILL- AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DISCUSS- IT'S
CRITICAL. THAT WE PROVIDE TO
FOR. FOUR THIS IS ONE OF THE
LAST. REMAINING SOURCES OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES IN CALIFORNIA
AND RATE INCREASES CAN BE
DEVASTATING FOR MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE- YOU CANNOT
MOVE YOUR HOME INTO A NEW PARK
CALIFORNIA AND SO IF THE RENT
IS BASED OFF THEY SAID THEY DID.
QUESTION THEY CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD. TO TRY TO MAKE
ESCALATING RENT PAYMENTS WHEN
WE FACE THAT SITUATION WE OFTEN
SEE FOLKS FACING WHAT WE CALL
ECONOMIC EVICTION WHERE THEY
EVENTUALLY ARE FORCED TO MOVE
OUT NOW LOTS OF CITIES HAVE
PROTECTED HOME THIS AND BY.
RENT CONTROL. MANY CITIES AND
NOT HAVE SO MANY HOMEOWNERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE NOT
PROTECTED BY ANY LIMITS ON
GREECE'S. BEYOND WHAT AN ANNUAL
LEASE MIGHT PROVIDE AND SO.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE MAJORITY OF HOMEOWNERS ARE
PROJECTED FROM UNREASONABLE
RATE INCREASES WHILE ALSO
PRESERVING THE ABILITY OF
GOVERNMENTS TO. PROTECT AT.
NICOLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TOOL
AND WE WOULD URGE AND I DON'T.
IF WE CAN NOW GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS. IT TO THE MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ALLOW LUPE
RAMIREZ TO. FIGHT THE DAVID
MERIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES.
MY NAME IS TERRIFYING IN BATTLE
IT SHOWS CHAIRED PUT COVERAGES
FOCUSED- IN PART WE WERE
BLOCKED AND WE WOULD GET UP TO
FIFTY HERE ARE AT TEN YEAR
LEASE BY THE NEW OWNER. AT OUR
THE ONE THAT AND AT THE END OF
TEN YEARS WILL BE MORE NOW WHAT
I THINK IS. THAT ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE. WHICH MEANT THAT WE
WOULD STILL HAVE HORRENDOUS
RACKET CREASES BUT THEY WOULD
JUST COME SLOWER IN THE
MEANTIME THOUGH GET FULL BUT
COULD AFFORD EVEN A FIVE DOLLAR
INCREASE. WE'RE DOLLARS. SIX
YEARS AND THERE'S NOBODY CAN
AFFORD IT. NOW THERE IS NOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO SELL THEIR
HOMES AND OF COURSE THEY CAN'T
THEM ANYTHING THE MOST OF THEM
THAT. YEAH EVERYBODY'S KIND OF
WE KIND OF CRAZY THERE'S MORE.
THERE'S A HEART ATTACK I THINK
THE ONE WHO WILL SO. ERIC ABOUT
THE IN DID SHE LITERALLY WE
LIVE NEXT TO THE RAILROAD
TRACKS RAN UP ON THE ACTION ONE
TO GET HERE TRYING. DO AND IT
TAKES A LONG TIME YOU HAVE A
AND A NEW BLACK. A PREDATORY BY.
AND THEN MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO SHELVE THEM WHEN THEY
CAN'T ALL THE PEOPLE CLOSEST
AND THEN YOU LOSE YOUR HOME TO
KEEP. YOU CAN'T AND THAT. YEAH
30% OF OUR POPULATION IS
VETERANS AND THEIR VERY SCARED
IN THE FIELD WE FOUGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND NOT NOBODY'S.
PEOPLE IN THE PARK I HAVE LOST
PARTNERS. CAN YOU WHEN YOU'RE
ON INCOME IS THE MIND OUT IF
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE ONE OF YOUR
INCOMES. AND YEAH. PROBABLY IT
PROBABLY CLOSE DOT ORG END UP
LOSING. ON OUT THIS IF THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE MARVEL. WE NEED TO
CHANGE IN AS MENTORS GUIDING
PART WE CAN WE- THANK YOU LOW
LIFE WE'VE ALL RETIRED FROM
JOBS THIS ORDER. MR BECAUSE
WRAP UP THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
IT YEAH AND WE NEED PROTECTION
AND- WE JUST REALLY WILL GET
TAKE A CALIFORNIA WOULD
UNDERSTAND OUR PLOT. AND I'M
VERY. THANK YOU TO THE
MODERATOR FREAKING THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I'LL PICK
KNOWLEDGE ONE PERSON HERE IN
THIS CHAMBER. YOUR RAN. EIGHT
ASIAN SUPPORT NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU AND THE MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
SUPPORTERS. FOR SUPPORT YEAH
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU HAVE NOT
DONE SO ALREADY AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT YOU WITH. ONE ZERO
TOTAL MY NUMBER. YOU THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I L<c.cyan>G THREE</c>
FIFTY TWO WE HAVE YOUR LINE
OPEN. FIFTY TWO YOU MAY WANT TO
CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
OKAY I MOVE ON TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND. SIX NINE TWO ZERO
SIX. BUT I CAN'T GET A REPORT
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS MY SCHOOL CORPORATE
IT BILL IT HAS BEEN PLAYING.
FOR SO MANY YEARS IN FOURTEEN
ACT I AM AND I CAN THINK OF ALL
THE COMMUTER. ORANGE COUNTY
GOING UP. BECAUSE OR YOU I HOPE
THAT ARE PRE ON OUR MOBILE HOME
RENTERS OWNER THEY NEED TO TAX
AND ART ART JUST NOT CABLE DO
NOT OF THE PAST THREE HOW OUT
HI SO I. HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX LINE ONE SEVEN SIX GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YEAH LOSE FRIDAY WITH
CALIFORNIAN THE WOULD
RESPONSIBLE TODAY IN LIMELIGHT
WITH THE- THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER HUNDRED AND SIX
LINE THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NASH AT THE-
CALIFORNIA. THE PART. THANK YOU
AN WE GO NEXT TO THE LAW OF
THREE AND FIFTY EIGHT LINE
THREE FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GOING.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICHARD. I'M IN YOU WITH THE
CLUB. COUNTY SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE FIVE YOUR OF.
SHOULD WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD LAW THREE BY FOUR. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. ON
CALL IN FOR. AS WE MENTIONED
THE START EXTEND IT NEEDS FOR
AT T. OKAY. THREE TO. YEAH I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT CAN PROTECTION BILL.
MY NUMBER THREE TEN FIFTY SEVEN
LINE IS THREE FIVE SEVEN. GET
IT MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA FOR. NUMBER
EIGHTY THAT LINE NUMBER EIGHT
ZERO GO AHEAD. HI THIS BY
NUMBERLESS FROM LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
AT TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
THAT IS LINE NUMBER FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE FIFTY
FIVE WE DO HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY
FIVE WE DO HAVE THE LINE OPEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK. OKAY
KNOCKING ONE OF MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THAT IS MY
NUMBER THREE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE YOU THE BILL
BROUGHT. OVER CHEN AND IT'S
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THAT'S THREE SIX. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
RELEASED AND I MAY POLICY AND
TURN WITH YOUR LITTLE THE
LITTLE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND WE ARE AT
THE CORE OF THE- WE HAD. NINE
LINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME OF PROPAGANDA. I THANK AM
I'M ASKING YOUR FIRST YOUR
SUPPORT BILL THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
IN SEVENTY THAT PLANE THREE SO
ZERO PLEASE GOING. HI IS AND
NEED TO DO THE BUY. OUT READ
FOR ABANDONED HOUSE LA THIS.
OUR ORGAN STRONG FOR TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE. THREE FIVE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JORDAN I'M FROM SAN MATTEO
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING ONE SAN
MATTEO HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
THAT'S LINE. SEVEN THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY LOOK BAD A ALONG
WITH TENANTS TOGETHER AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT MOBILE HOMES
TO BE PUT IT. EIGHT PEOPLE.
THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY NINE THAT IS LINE
ONE NINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I CAN REALLY OUT OF THE
FAMILY DISTRICT SIXTY EIGHT
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN
I'M I'M- I I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
PROTECTION FOR MOBILE HOME ALL.
THANK LINE THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR THAT'S NINE THREE
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SASHA. FEDERAL
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE ANOTHER-
PERSON THAT WISHES TO SPEAK ONE
MOMENT. IT'LL BE JUST ONE
MOMENT. HE WILL BE GOING NEXT
TO LIKE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOU MIGHT THREE SEVENTY
SIX WE DO HAVE THE LINE OPEN. A
LINE THREE SEVENTY SIX YOU MAY
I GO AHEAD WE HAVE TO LINE OPEN
FOR YOU. I WILL TRY ONE MORE
TIME I'M LINE THREE SEVENTY SIX
ARE YOU JUST SPOKE TO THE
OPERATOR A MOMENT AGO WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN'T
BELIEVE THEY HAVE DISCONNECTED
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE NUMBER.
OF THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THAT'S LINE THREE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS IGOR TRACK OF I'M
ELECTED OFFICIALS REPRESENTING
A COMMUNITY OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. AND
I COUNTY DOES INCLUDE A NUMBER-
MOBILE HOME CAN. THAT WOULD
BENEFIT QUITE A BIT- THE
PROPOSAL. AND IT WOULD LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR THAT DATE
TO CONTINUE LIKE THAT CAPTION
OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO I MEAN
FOR MONTHS APART THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NUMBER'S THREE AND ONE
LINE THREE SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TOBY
MARZANO I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
AND ORGANIZE WITHIN MONICA EMB
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AS WELL. AND IF I
ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO QUEUE UP
IN SUPPORT YOU WOULD PRESS ONE
INTENDED ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE%
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE ONE FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE AGAIN LINE FIFTY
FIVE WE DO HAVE THE LIGHT OPEN
FOR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE
FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY WANT TO
CHECK THE MUTE FEATURE ON YOUR
PHONE WE'RE NOT GETTING A
RESPONSE. OKAY WE'RE GOING.
MOVE ON WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL-
PERSON IN THE QUEUE ONE MOMENT.
HOW DO I NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT LINE THREE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE VEHICLE YEAH. EIGHT AGAIN
IT WERE ON LINE SO EIGHT WE DO
HAVE LIGHT OKAY FOR YOU. THANK
YOU OKAY NOT GETTING RESPONSE
FROM WHITE SEVEN EIGHT WE HAVE
NOTICED PARTY IN THE QUEUE.
GRAY THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WHAT WE TURN IT
OVER. THE OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I THINK THE- THEY'RE BOTH
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM SO
THE FIRST WITNESS IS ANDREW.
YES THANK YOU CHAIR- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ANDERSON MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA- W. MAY RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL AS WE SAID
BEFORE. MA'AM WRITTEN TENANTS
ARE GOING TO COVER NINETEEN
TOGETHER- LANDLORDS ARE JUST AS
CONFUSED AS TENANTS WERE TRYING
TO PAY OUR EMPLOYEES ARE. TO
KEEP PARKS AND OBVIOUSLY THESE
BILLS PUT PRESSURE ON OWNERS.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REASONS WE
OPPOSE. HAVING THAT I RENT
CONTROL MOBILE HOME CONTROL IS.
THE RE BEING IF YOU PUT RENT
CONTROL ON APARTMENT THERE'S
JUST ONE FEE IT'S THE APARTMENT
RENT BUT WHEN YOU PUT RENT
CONTROL ON A MOBILE HOME WHAT
YOU DO IS YOU DRIVE UP THE
PRICE OF THE SALES. AND WE HAVE
EXAMPLES THAT WE'VE- WE'VE
NOTICED FOR INSTANCE WHAT LOW
INCOME A MODERATE PERSON CAN
AFFORD A SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR HOME IN OXNARD BY THE
BEACH IN A RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTION. THE IN CLOSE BY I
WOULD BE QUE. IN YOUR- PLEASE
THIS WILL HAVE A DRAMATIC. I
GOT WHERE IF YOU SUPPRESS THE
RENT AND YOU KEEP IT DOWN A LOW
LEVEL SPECIAL VACANCY CONTROL
ALL YOU'RE GOING TO DO IS JACK
UP THE PRICE OF THE HOME SALE
AND WHAT BE THE CURRENT. YOU
CAN READ CURRENT LIVING HOW
DOES THAT HELP YOU WHAT ABOUT.
IT DOESN'T WORK THE THAT IT'S
PAID FOR. YES THE TO A IT. SO
REALLY WHEN IT COMES RENT
CONTROL FOR MOBILE HOMES YOU
NEED TO HAVE A I DON'T TO
VACATE THE TROUBLE. A LITTLE
PRESSURE WHEN SOMEONE MOVES OUT
AND THEN THAT WAY THE RENT CAN
GO UP A LITTLE AND IT KEEPS THE
HOME PRICES DOWN AS- A FACT.
PROOF THAT ARE NOT. THEY CAP
THE RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR THE
SAME OF THE SO THE HOME OF THE
READ THE PARKING COULDN'T TO MY
BUT NEITHER COULD THE RESIDENTS
WHEN SURE THAT'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NOW THAT WAS THROWN OUT
BECAUSE SANTA DIDN'T FOR SALE
OTHER RESIDENTS. YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR A NOVEL CONCEPT FIND BOUNCE
FOR OWNERS SINCE IN THE STATE
BACK BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
DO RICH ONE GROUP OF AN EVENT.
AT THE DETRIMENT OF BECAUSE
TRYING TO COME AND WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN WHAT YOU WILL SEE IS
THAT IF YOU PASS THIS BILL IF
YOU PASS RENT CONTROL AND AGAIN
WE UNDERSTAND. THE ARE YOU. IN
MY- WHAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SET.
UP I THINK THEY NEED TO BE MORE
WORK DONE ON BILL PROVIDE ABOUT.
OF RENT AND THEN FINALLY A LOT
OF TIMES WHEN YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
A PARK THAT'S BOT. YOU HAVE TO
PAY TAXES ON THAT AND
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE TAXES GET
PASSED ON TO RENT INCREASES IF
THE STATE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH. THEM AND OWNERS TO
SOMEHOW WORK WITH THEM SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO PASS ON THIS
TAXES AND RENT INCREASES YOU
CAN WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THIS LEGISLATOR. SO IF IT ISN'T.
STRICTLY A- WE- TURN OVER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AGAIN JASON ACT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE
HOME PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE TO
HANDLE ALL THE IT'S BEEN MY
MISTER GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF
WMA. ADD THAT. THERE IS A
REASON WHY THE MORE HOME PARK
INDUSTRY IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT WHEN IT COMES TO RENT
CONTROL IT'S UNIQUE- OF THE
OVER FOURTEEN MILLION. HOUSING
UNITS IN CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE
AT AROUND FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
OR OUR MOBILE HOMES AND MOBILE
PARKS- THE REALITY. WALL IT
CAN. BE FORTY TWO. HE WAS IN.
NEW YORK MULTI FAMILY HOUSE
WERE BUILT IN LA ALONE. BUT IS
WE TALK ABOUT MANY TIMES THEY
ARE A- WE'VE LOST A SEVEN NOW.
AND A SPACE WHERE HOME PARK
MIKE HOW IN THE ONE YEARS. WELL
AB FOR EIGHTY TWO BRENT CAN OR
READ STABLE IS. TO INDUSTRY
THAT WAS. BUILDING NEW HOUSING
WE ARE LOSING HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR IN A
MOBILE HOME PARK. BECAUSE IT'S
SUCH UNIQUE OF HOUSING THAT
ISN'T. AYE AYES. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO AND TO.
TAG EIGHT IT. AND IT CONTINUING
TO MAINTAIN THAT HOUSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ONE WE ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY OPPONENTS TO THE
BILL. BE THE MODERATOR FOR ASK
A YOU TO OPEN UP THE LINES. IF
YOU. CANNOT OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN. GROW A LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
POINT THREE FIVE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SURE NUMBERS CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN- FOR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND IS ZERO. I'LL BE JUST
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE I CAN THAT IS LYING
THREE EIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THREE EIGHT FIVE. NIKE
EXPECT MY- I OPPOSITION TO THE
NEW TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN FOR THREE
EIGHT FIVE IF YOU COULD JUST BE
STATE YOUR NAME THANK YOU AND-
MY NAME IS VERY. DELICATE THANK
YOU. AND IF ANYONE ELSE THAT
WISHES TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS. I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
THIS FORWARD AS THE AUTHOR OF
PERTINI TO LAST YEAR'S VERY
HAPPY TO SEE YOU MOVE THIS TO
EXTEND. THE SAME PROTECTION TO
MOBILE HOME ON IN THE STATE AND
I TAKE A THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR PURCHASE TO NASA. I KNOW.
YOU AND REALLY JUST APPRECIATE.
I WORK IN THIS AREA. WE KNOW.
PRICES WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO GIVE OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS THE SEEMS. TO RENT
COUNTY PROTECTIONS- THAT OTHERS
HAVE AND THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
STEP- IF IT SO. IF YOU LIKE AS
WE DISCUSSED LONG AGO AT TO ME
THIS BILL GETS UP. AS A THIRD
ANY LEVEL YOU LIKE. AND THAT
WAY WITH THIS IS OUR MOTION
WITH THIS BILL. I'LL MAKE THE
MOTION IS OUR SECOND GREAT- ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. OF COURSE I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE BUT- I JUST
WANT TO AND WITH AS WE TALKED
HOUSING AT ALL LEVELS VERY LOW
EXTREMELY LOW MODERATE AND EVEN
MARKET WE HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL
OF THE OPTIONS OUT THERE. AND
MAYBE. I'M ARE. MUCH MORE DEBT.
AS WELL WITH MISTER. WILL
SOMEWHERE GOING WIRE OF
CONVERSION LIKE OUR MOTEL BILL
HOTEL BILL BUT ALL OF THESE
OPTIONS. TO GATHER CAN HELP
SOLVE OUR HOUSE UP PUZZLE BUT
ONE OF THEM IS ALONE WILL NOT
SO WITH THAT BEING I SEE THIS
EIGHT FORTY. I DO NOT HEAR KERN
HOW MOBILE AND RENTAL CAR DE.
YEAH I THINK THIS IS FOR THOSE
RESIDENTS ARE LIVING IN MOBILE
HOMES THANK. THANK YOU WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CAN YOU CLARIFY
THAT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
OUR YES I WILL ASK IF YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITMENTS YES
I. THE AMEND THANKS. ANDERSON
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED IT TOO HI
CHU I DEEP GAVE. CAMERA I
GLORIA ANY KILEY NOW WE MOM
MANGE QUIRK. THAT BILL HAS
SORRY. THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES
IN ITS ON CALL GREAT THANK YOU.
LET'S GO NOW TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS LINE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR HOW ARE YA
COLLEAGUES. IT'S LIKE TO- FIRST
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR
THE WORK ON THE ANALYSIS THIS
BILL- AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR
OF ACCEPTED ALL OF THE
SUGGESTED OR THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT SO. SHEET THAT FROM
FROM STAFF CERTAINLY MADE THE
BILL. MUCH STRONGER. I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO PRESENT
THIS BILL SIMPLY BILL THREE ONE
FIVE FIVE THE MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING ACT. RIGHT NOW THIS
BILL WOULD HELP- AND PRODUCE
HOUSING. AT A TIME WHEN WE
CERTAINLY NEED IT MOST. NOW I'M
AS- WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
ARE WAS WAS ALREADY IN THE
MIDST. OF A HISTORIC HOUSING
CRISIS- PRIOR TO THIS- KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC YOU KNOW THE
ECONOMIC IN A BECAUSE BY. THIS
PANDEMIC IS LIKELY TO MAKE
THINGS MUCH. MUCH WORSE- IN OUR
STATE NO FOR A STATE THAT HAS
BECOME THE NOT OPPOSE. FOR MY
HOUSE COSTS. HOMELESS THE
INABILITY TO PRODUCE HOUSING-
THIS PANDEMIC WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE THESE PROBLEMS. AND
ALTHOUGH THERE IS A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY MOVING FORWARD
SINCE MARCH SINCE THE ONSET OF
THIS PANDEMIC- WE KNOW THIS
THAT HOUSING- THE PRODUCTION
HAS SLOWED. MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS. HOW AND
FOR MANY IN OUR STATE HERE
CALIFORNIA THE DREAM OF HOME
OWNERSHIP SINCE FARTHER AWAY
THAN EVER. THE HOUSING
SITUATION WAS DIRE PRIOR TO
CALL THE NINETEEN BUT IT IS
EVEN MORE DIRE RIGHT NOW. AS I
MENTIONED WE ALL KNOW ABOUT THE
RECORD HIGH RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY IN OUR STATE. WE KNOW
THAT MOST COLLEGE GRADUATES WHO
CHOOSE TO LIVE AND WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. NO LONGER FOR-
AFFORD A HOME HERE CAN AFFORD
HOME UNLESS THEY COME FROM
SIGNIFICANT FAMILY WEALTH. WE
KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE WHO POWER
THIS STATE TEACHERS
FIREFIGHTERS. SCHOOL SUPPORT
STAFF HOSPITALITY WORKERS
FARMWORKERS COOKS ARE SERVICE
INDUSTRY MEMBERS MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE CAN NOT
AFFORD TO OWN A HOME HERE IN
OUR STATE. MY ARGUE THAT THIS
IS AT THE MOMENT THIS ISN'T THE
TIME TO ADDRESS HOUSING. BUT I
STRONGLY. I DISAGREE. EXPANDED
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MUST BE A CRITICAL PART OF OUR
RECOVERY FROM THIS
UNPRECEDENTED HEALTHCARE CRISIS.
WE NEED TO HELP THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
STRUGGLING TO GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR FUTURE. AND WE CAN
DO THIS WE CAN MAKE REAL
PROGRESS ON HOUSING. RATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND WE CAN
DO SO WITHOUT PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
THE SUBSIDIES THAT WOULD
CLEARLY PUT A FURTHER DENT IN
OUR STATE BUDGET. THIS LARGEST
ADDRESSES THE IMMEDIATE NEED
FOR HOUSING SUPPLY AND IT DOES
SO BY REMOVING BARRIERS IS
STATE LAW BARRIERS THAT PREVENT
THE PRODUCTION OF SMALL LOT
HOMES. AND BUILDING MORE OF
THESE ACTUALLY AFFORDABLE SMALL
LOT HOMES PUT HOME OWNERSHIP IN
REACH FOR MANY MORE
CALIFORNIANS. NOT TO MENTION IT
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HAPPENED
AYE VERSIFIED CAL AND STOCK. AB
THREE ONE FIVE FIVE IS DESIGNED
TO CREATE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE NEVER NEVER BE ABLE
TO PURCHASE A HOME IN THEIR OWN
CITY. AND WITHIN OUR OWN.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS
PERMITTING FOR SMALL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AT TEN UNITS ARE
FEWER. WHILE ENSURING THAT
DEVELOPMENTS MEET ANY EXISTING
LOCAL INCLUSIONARY REQUIREMENTS
OR ALTERNATIVELY PAY A FEE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO CONTRIBUTE
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
SMALL SCALE PROJECTS TOWN HOMES
AND ROW HOUSES OFTEN FORM THE
BASIS OF MUCH OFTHE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ALREADY BUSINESS IN OUR
STATE. BUT THEY ARE ALL VERY
VERY TOUGH TO GET APPROVED.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THESE
TYPES OF HOMES TO FOLLOW A
MINISTERIAL STAFF LEVEL
APPROVAL SO LONG AS THEY MEET
THE OBJECTIVE RULES AND
CRITERIA THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE THESE HOMES- WOULD
STILL HAVE TO FOLLOW RELEVANT
LOCALS ONLY RULES AN OBJECTIVE
DESIGN CRITERIA. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO EXPAND AN EXISTING
EXEMPTION IN CURRENT LAW THE
THIS THIS BILLS LIMITED
EXPANSION OF SB THIRTY FIVE IS
CRITICAL. AND IT'S CRITICAL
BECAUSE REQUIRINGSMALL
PROJECTS OF TEN UNITS ARE LESS
TO HAVE ONSITE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING A 50% 50% THE CURRENT
LAW SIMPLY IS NOT PRACTICAL.
IT'S NOT PRACTICAL. BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY NOW WHEN PUBLIC
FUNDS FOR FORMER HOUSING GO TO
LARGER PROJECTS PROJECTS WHERE
THEY CAN GET THE MOST BANG FOR
THEIR BUCK. WITHOUT THIS-
EXPANSION OF THE STREAMLINING
PROVISION THE SMALLER NATURALLY
AFFORDABLE ENTRY LEVEL HOMES
WILL NEVER NEVER GET BUILT. WE
KNOW THIS BILL WILL WORK IT'LL
WORK BECAUSE IT'S PROVISIONS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN TRIED THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN TESTED IN OUR
STATE. IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- THESE THESE ARE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE VERY
SIMILAR NATURE HAVE BEEN
POPULAR WITH BUILDERS AND HOME
BUYERS. THROUGH A SMALL LOT
SUBDIVISION ORDINANCE THE CITY
IS CREATED MORE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. AND IT'S HELP
AID THAT CITIES RECOVERY IN
PAST RECESSIONS. IF WE DO THIS
HERE A CALIFORNIA STATE WIDE
LEVEL WE CAN AS A STATE. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL PRODUCE RESULTS.
EXPANDING ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING EXPANDING ACCESS TO
HOUSING PERIOD. CAN BE AND
SHOULD BE A KEY PART OF HELPING
CALIFORNIANS RECOVER FROM THE
ECONOMIC DEVASTATION CAUSED BY
KOBE NINETEEN. OUR CONSTITUENTS
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE COUNTING
ON US TO MAKE PROGRESS WITH
RESPECT TO OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
SENATE PASSAGE THERE IS A
FUTURE FOR THEM IN OUR
INCREDIBLE STATE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM IS STILL
WITHIN REACH EVEN. EVEN IN THIS
TIME OF HARDSHIP. SO WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR ALTERNATE OVER TO
MASK THE TO MATTHEW GRUNDY TO
CEO OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY THE
GREATER FRESNO AREA- ONE OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS AND ALSO
FURTHER EXPLAINED THE BILL.
COLLECTING FROMSAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA OF PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION- KNOWN TO
SPUR THANK YOU MISTER SHOW. TO
THE MADRE FOR PLEASE A MATTHEW
GRUNDY SPEAK AS THE FIRST
WITNESS. MATTHEW TWENTY POINT
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY- THE
STATE MY NAME IS MATTHEW GROUND
IN THAT THE GOOD PLEASURE
SERVING AS CEO FOR HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY GREATER AREA. THE
LARGER HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
NETWORK THE WORLD'S LARGEST
PRIVATE BUILD OF AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. TOGETHER AS A
COMMUNITY WE HAVE IMPROVED
HOUSING CONDITIONS FOR OVER
THIRTEEN MILLION FAMILIES
GLOBALLY. HABITATS FORTY
AFFILIATE. FORMULA I'VE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO HELP FAMILIES
RELY ST STABILITY AND SELF
RELIANCE REPORTABLE SHELTER SO
POP WITH THOSE FROM EXTREMELY
LOW TO MY INCOME. FOLKS FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE RALLY TO
THIS CALL SIMPLY BECAUSE WE ALL
AGREE THAT EVERYONE DESERVES
THE SECOND. HOME PRIOR TO SPUR
BEAN THIS CAPACITY THE COURT
TENANTS OF HABITAT WILL
REALIZED MY OWN PERSONAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE. DONE AGO LIFE
HAPPENED- MY MOM WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH THE TRIO KILMISTER
DETERMINE ALL. YEAH LAID OFF.
WE FOR TRYING TO KEEP GOING
IT'S- WE LOS THEIR- HOMELESS MY
JUNIOR YEAR SCHOOL. I LEARNED
FIRST HAND OF SAFETY ENOUGH FOR
HOMEOWNER. IT BY THE DOES THE
BILL TO LEARN IN OCT OUT. TO
PUT NECK HEALTH OUTCOMES HE
GETS READ THE SHOT AND REALIZE
NUMERIC DREAM AND BY. TO AND
WELL. TRULY OWNER IS IN AND OFF.
PART OF HOW WE CAN UNDER THE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND THIS IS
EXACT WHAT FIND A DATE SUPPRT
OF AB. ONE FIFTY FIVE THIS BILL.
AS FIVE IN HERE TO BARBIE. ARE
TO MOVE QUICKLY AND AT THE- YOU
CAN. AND OF AFFORDABLE UNITS BY
STREAMLINING PROJECTS IN THE
RIGHT SITUATION PERMITTING
CONSTRUCTION AT TENTATIVE MAP
STAGE HONORING THE PAID GUARDS.
I KNOW THESE WORK ONLY BECAUSE
WE HAVE IN PLACE CURRENTLY IN
FRESNO MADERA COUNTY IT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO INCREASE THE NUMBERS OF
FAMILIES WHICH- BY TWO. X. OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. YEAH SO.
IT WILL LIKE OR SO. WHAT YOU
JUST AB SIR WANTED FIVE SO. WE
CAN BE EXTENDED TO THE OF ALL
THREE OUT OF YOU THANK YOU FOR
THIS REASON WE CRESTOR AYE BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S GO
TO THE NEXT WITNESS MICHAEL.
SPUR TO MODERATE PORCHER
CHECHEN MEMBERS. A RECENT
INTERNATIONAL STUDY FOUND
CALIFORNIA TO BE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PLACE IN THE WORLD TO
BUILD HOUSING. THIS IS
REFLECTED IN THE IN RENTS OF
OUR STATE. AND OUR
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE WHICH IS THE
SECOND LOWEST IN THE NATION.
BUT AS WE TRY TO CAPTURE SOME
MUCH VALUE FROM NEW RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND FEES EXACTIONS
OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT WE JUST
DON'T PRODUCE HOUSING FROM.
SAYS RESULT ALL AMOUNT OF HOW
IT IS PRODUCED JUST AS TO MOST.
AND CAL. THE PENCIL. SINGLE WE
HOMES ARE CLASSE MADE IN HIGH
RISE APARTMENTS BECAUSE THAT'S
ALL ITS OWN LAWS AND ALL THOSE
FEASIBLE. ONE THOUSAND HOMES.
ONE NINETEEN THE LITTLE
DOWNTURN NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HALF THE AMOUNT
OF HOUSING THAT WE NEED TO
PRODUCE EACH YEAR THIS JUST
ISN'T A VERY IMPROPER
PERFORMANCE. AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE MORE AFFORDABILITY BY
DESIGN WITHOUT PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES. THE BILL WILL ALLOW
THE MISSING MIDDLE BUILDING
TYPES THAT WE NEED. VOTERS HAVE
RECENTLY BILLION. IN BONDS
TAKING LEVELS OF FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON TO BURDEN
THE SMALL PRODUCT WITH
SPECIALTIES. LOCAL INCLUSIONARY
IMPORTANCE IS EXEMPT THE SMALL
PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ARE. JUST
WE NEED GREATER DIVERSITY IN
THE TOP OF HOUSING THE CAN BE
BUILT. AND TO REDUCE THE TIME
AND COST TO BUILD IT. THANK YOU.
LET'S NOT GO TO INDIVIDUALS ON
THE LINE AND SUPPORT TO THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES. IF YOU WERE
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE THAT AGAIN IT IS
ONE AND- ZERO. IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT GO TO LINE ONE ONE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THANK YOU YES THANK YOU
MODERATE OR MICHAEL GOT IN THE
HEARING RECORD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING. THANK YOU.
A STRONG RECORDED YOUR PATH OF
EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND NINE LINE THREE ZERO NINE.
YEAH BUT THE RAFAEL- TRAVELED
IN SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE THINGS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RESULTS FOR INCLUDING THE BILL
GONNA BE LOOKING FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN PATRICK COUNTY
AND WILL HAPPILY. ON BEHALF. I
KEEP. FLYING THREE HUNDRED AND
FIVE LINE. THREE MY NAME IS
PUBLIC MORE- I MEAN OAKLAND
AND- SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT LINE
SIX EIGHT LEAVE AT. THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR REPRESENT FEELS THAT THE
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY BASED
BUSINESS AND STRONG SUPPORTER
OF CALIFORNIA EMB AND STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS BILL. POINT
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND TEN
LINE THREE ONE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS STILL BE
ACCU LARGE AND STRONG SUPPORT
FROM THE TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE LINE IT THREE FOUR
NINE. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
STEVENS I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO I'M
WITH CALIFORNIAN B. AND THEN
YOU'LL BE DEMOCRATS INDIGO
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE ONE FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED LINE FOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY OF DISCONNECTED WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND. FORTY FOUR NINE TWO FOUR
FOUR. THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADAM RIGHTLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. I
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN LINE FOR ONE THREE. I
IN THIS PICK UP WHERE I LIVE IN
OAKLAND AND I'M UP MEMBER IF
YOU STAY FOR EVERYONE AND I
WANTED TO. ASK YOU CAN. THIS
BILL THANK YOU. YEAH MY NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN LINE
FOR ONE EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
RICHARD BELLINGER CALLING FOR
CA U. M. B. AND I AM ALSO SHARE
ALTHOUGH THE SUNNYVALE BICYCLE
PEDESTRIAN ADVISORY COMMISSION
ARE YOU NOT SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMISSION I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT. ALL THE- RIGHT. AND WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWO LINE. FOR TWO TO MY
NAME IS ADAM DECKER I LIVE IN
OAKLAND. I'M ALSO
TRANSPORTATION ADVOCATE AND I
AM CALLING TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE FIVE FIVE
IT WILL IT NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS.
AND TREND I'M VERY AS WELL. I
SO IT VALUE THANK. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED IN FIVE
LINES. ZERO SEVEN. HI MY NAME
pFRANCISCO- I'M CALLING FROM THE
WITHIN THE ACTION I'M ASKING
YOU TO SUPPORT AB THREE ONE
FIVE. THANK OKAY WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER THREE THREE EIGHT THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME MICHELLE AND I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA A AND B. AND HELP
SACRAMENTO I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I AM- URGING
YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THREE
ONE FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE LINE FOUR
TO FIVE. HI MY NAME IS ARE
HARMON I HOMEOWNER AND
LANDLORDS AND VERY NOW I SERVE
ON MY COUNTY PLANNING
COMMISSION TO BE CLEAR ENOUGH
FOR THE- I. LOCALLY SERVE ON
PLANNING ISSUE I WOULD URGE
SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE FIVE
FIVE. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT LINE FOR TWO EIGHT.
HI MY NAME'S AGAIN IF PERRY
FROM TECH EQUITY COOPERATIVE IN
OAKLAND AND MARK STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ONE FIVE FIVE THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO LINE.
THREE NINE TWO. HI THIS IS JAKE
CRIED ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING AT THE COALITION HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE FIVE
FIVE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX LINE AT
ONE SEVEN SIX. YEAH LUIS MORON
FAMILY HAVE A CALIFORNIAN BE I
REALLY URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
IS ONE IF NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT PRODUCTION BILL LEFT
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND ALL THE
MORE BY 21% ABOUT PERMIT THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR CATS
JUST. THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIX LINE TO ZERO
SIX. THE THAT CAPITA LORD
TOWARDS COUNTY ALL URGING YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR LINE FOR THREE FOUR. HI MY
NAME IS ROB NIELSEN I THAT YOU
TELL ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA I AM
CALLING CARE AS HUGE SUPPORT PT
THE ONE FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU.
ONE THREE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT LINE. THREE ZERO EIGHT.
HI KRISTIN JEFFREY AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTY FIVE ANALYST
WITH THE COUNTY. ME AND THE
ACTION. AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE BECAUSE A LOT OF THE CITY
IN ORDER TO ACTUALLY HAVE A LOT
BY THE DIFFICULT TO PRODUCE
AFFORDABLE NOTHING NO HELPING
ON THEM THE BILL WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP OUR SMALL.
TOWN THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT LINE. TWO
FIVE EIGHT. THANK YOU FIFTY
EIGHT WE HAVE SELLING OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH HANFORD I'M CALLING
FROM PEOPLE FOR HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY- I ALSO SERVICE PLAN
COMMISSIONER IN THE THREE OR
FOUR TEN- AGAIN I DON'T SPEAK
COMMISSION BUT- OTHERS ARE
DISCLOSING THEIR- COMMISSION
THE CREDENTIALS. I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT DEL WE ARE AND TO
THE OPTICALLY IN SUPPORT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO YEAH THANK YOU.
AND LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE LINE FOR TWO THREE.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE GARNER
AND I LIVE IN HUNTINGTON BEACH
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER
OF THE CITY FOR HOUSING AND I
URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THREE
NINETY FOUR GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ANTHONY TO DO
THIS IS DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
RESEARCH FOR ABUNDANT HOUSING
LA JUST TO EXPRESS OUR
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINE ONLINE AT ONE EIGHT NINE
NINE. HI KIMBERLY ADAMS OF AN
ORANGE COUNTY I'M WAY OF
CALIFORNIANS YEAH I ALSO
REPRESENT THE ANYBODY YOU KNOW
AND WE'RE GOING TO WEAR
RELIGION BEAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ALL THE- RIGHT IS ALL
THE MORE A- THE- BY DEPEND. AND
ONLY THAT PRODUCTION WOULD
BRING TO. AND HOW FINE CITY.
AND CREATED OUT ECONOMIC
STIMULUS SO I STRONGLY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT BILL AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE. EIGHT
NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS MILO
TRIALS- THERE'S NO WAY THAT
REALLY IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I'D
LIKE TO REGISTER STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE LINE ONE EIGHT
FIVE. HI MY NAME'S PATRICIA
GOODMAN I'M FROM PUTTING A
BEACH AND WITH YOUR GROUP
CALLED HOME WITH UNITED
HUNTINGTON BEACH. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE ONE
FIVE FIVE AND YOU TO DO LIKELY
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE BEEN
THREE PARDON E APPLYING OF
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX LINE. TWO
FIVE SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANDREW HOOKER I LIVE IN
SANTA CRUZ AND I SPEAK AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SANTA CRUZ
EMB. NOT ASK FOR YUR SUPPORT
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FOUR HAVE BEEN
THIRTY SEVEN LINE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
CONSTANTINE HATCHER I'M FROM
LOS ANGELES ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY THREE I AM AND WHAT
CALIFORNIAN BE AN ACT CALLING
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THE CRITICAL TOOL TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THE HOUSING CRISIS IS
BEING THE FACE OF THE OF THE
CONDEMNING. THANK YOU. LINE
FOUR HUNDRED AND. FOUR FOUR TWO
FOUR. MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF
OF THE SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE THAT IS LINE THREE
EIGHT THREE. THERE ARE MEMBERS
ALEX STORAGE WITH STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO LINE FOR THREE TO. I HAD
LINE FOR THIRTY TO THE LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS LAURA SPEAKING
FOR YOU IN THE ACTION AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SALE- ARE
ALMOST THREE THOUSAND BIRDS WE
NEED HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. IF MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT THAT
IS LINE THREE NINE EIGHT. HOLLY
FOR ME THEY HAD TO HEALTH
AFFAIRS I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE PIECE COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION. PMG AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THE OF MY NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED. LINE OF FOUR ZERO
EIGHT. HI THERE THIS IS ANDREW
MEANS PRESSURE WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. IF MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED. THAT IS
LINE TWO EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU
MONDAY NIGHT OF THE DAIRY
COUNCIL INSTRUCT THE COURT AT
THIS BILL WHICH WILL ENCOURAGE
MAQBARA NATURALLY AFFORDABLE
HOW THE IMPORTANT- COURT THANK
YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE LINE THREE FOUR FIVE.
HI THIS IS KEVIN BURKE FROM
ALAMO CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE SIXTY TWO LINE SIX
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
LEGISLATORS- MY NAME IN THERE
WILL BE- MY HUSBAND AND I LIVE
IN A FAMILY DISTRICT NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AND THEN STATE SENATE
JUST NUMBER ELEVEN WE PROBABLY
VOTED. I ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO AND
SENATOR PRECISELY QUIRK IS
BOLD. AND FORWARD THINKING
LEGISLATION- TO BE CONSIDERED A
PATH WE URGE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS. AND FOR YOU. YOUR
COLLEAGUE THANK THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND.
FORTY NINE THREE FOUR ZERO. GO
AHEAD LINE THREE FORTY. HI THIS
IS CONNOR ANY FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY FOUR AND I-
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE LINE THREE FIVE
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE
FIFTY ONE. I ONCE AGAIN MY
THREE FIFTY ONE THAT WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU YOU MAY
WANT TO CHECK YOUR A NEW
FEATURE ON YOUR- OWN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME OUT YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY I DIDN'T THAT
GIVEN THE NUMBER- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JORDAN
CRIME- I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THEM THAT THEY NEED
MEMBER OF POTENTIAL FOR
EVERYONE- WE REPRESENT HOUSING
ADVOCATES GRASSROOTS HOUSING
ADVOCATES FROM DALY CITY TO
SUNNYVALE AND ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS CRITICALLY
NEEDED LEGISLATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THREE SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS JON
BY FROM TIMETO GO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING HAPPEN BY MAGIC WE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE
BELIEVE INCREASING EVAN HOUSING
PRODUCTION IS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE
CORRECTED BUT ONE OF THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE THAT IS
LINE FOUR FOUR THREE. HI
EVERYONE I'M OUTRAGE FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA THERE ARE A
LOT OF THE SMALL PARKING
BUILDING TO MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND
THEY ARE THE MOST AFFORDABLE
PLACES TO LIVE WE NEED WORK AND
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND LABOR GO TAKE A
PICTURESQUE COULD NOT THAT GOOD.
YEAH AND WE'VE FORWARD THANK
YOU. THE ON LINE NUMBER THREE
HAD AND- THAT IS LINE THREE ONE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS A LIVE LOOK ONLINE AND
I LIVE AND RUN IN SANTA CRUZ- I
LOOKED IN AND I'M NOT. A FIRING
HOMEOWNER AND YOU TO SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
WE ARE THREE IN. THREE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACKYL AND I LIVING I CAL. I'M
CALLING TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY THREE ONE FIVE FIVE
THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER FOUR AND
FORTY FOUR THAT IS LINE FOUR
FOUR FOR THE FINANCE. HI MY
NAME IS AND IS NEW AND I LIVE
IN SANTA CLARA CALIFORNIA I'M A
REGULAR HERE AND I LOVE TO SEE
MORE HOUSING THAT CAN BE RENTED
OUT TO PEOPLE LIKE ME- I'M WAS
HOUSE MAY YET BE AND I'M A
CALLING TO ASK YOU TO STAY OVER
THE THROUGHFIVE FIVE. WE HAVE
A- FORTY TWO THAT IS WHY
FORTY. WELL THIS IS WRONG
WITHOUT CORD NEVER AGAIN BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE THE
DEADLINE FOR FIVE ONE. HI THERE
MY NAME IS AMPLE LUMBER AND I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND THE
RENTER AND I'M AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVEN I WENT HOW
SACRAMENTO THE LOCAL YOU THE
ORGANIZATION IN SACRAMENTO. AND
I'M CALLING TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU. KLEIN NUMBER SIXTY
THAT IS LINE NUMBER SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD FTERNOON
STILL DEAL FOR OUR HERE ON
BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER IS FOUR FOUR SIX AT
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE RIGHT
ENJOY I MANY CONSTITUENTS OF
THE FAMILY DISTRICT SIX A
MEMBER OF HOUSE SACRAMENTO I
URGE YOUR STRONG I BUILT ON. AB
THIRTY ONE TO KEEP TRACK THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE IT IS LINE
THREE SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME W. MARSHON ON THE
MONTH AND JOKE CALIFORNIA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF- SANTA
MONICA YOU IN THE HOME ALSO AN
ADVISORY MEMBER TO THE- DOC
BRENT WHAT. YEAH I'M NOT
CALLING ON EVERY. THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE THAT IS LINE FOR FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MATTHEW LEWIS I AM CALLING FROM
THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF
BERKELEY I AM A HOMEOWNER HERE.
WE HAD BEEN HOPING IN WATCHING
WHAT SUCH IS THE ONLY NUMBER
RIVAS AND OTHERS ASSEMBLY TO
PASS LEGISLATION EXACTLY LIKE
THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE. I'M
LOOKING AROUND MY BLOCK HERE IN
BERKELEY- WHERE I'VE LIVED IN A
HOME FOR TEN YEARS AND THERE'S
PLENTY HERE. WE ARE. WHICH. WE
HAVE- NINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE LINE FOR SIX ONE.
HELLO BUT MELVIN FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA. I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT AB THREE ONE FIVE FIVE
BECAUSE I WANT TO ONE DAY
AFFORD A HOME IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DEADLINE.
FOUR SIX FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT **** MAN I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M WITH YOU IN THE
ACTION ANDI'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT AB ONE FIFTY FIVE THANK
YOU. POINT NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THAT IS LINE FOR SIX
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI TO THE
COP BEATING THEM COMING FROM
PALO ALTO- I'M WHERE IT IS BUT
FOR EVERYONE AND SOUTH BAY
YOU'LL BE I DO TOO THANK. YOU
WHENEVER FOR HAND AND SIX THREE
THAT IS L<c.cyan>G FORTY THREE. HI</c>
MY NAME IS. AND I LIVE IN SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA I'M WITH THE
INDY NDA GOES DOWN AND I'M
CALLING YOU THAT THE COURT
EIGHTY THREE ONE FIVE NINE I'M
AT THE- BORDER AND I REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU. MY NAME. IN. TWO
FOR TWO. HI MY NAME IS GRETCHEN
PETERS I'M WITH A BUNCH AND
HELP YOU AND I HEARD YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE. THANK YOU PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AT THIS TIME WHEN WE GO TO THE
OPPOSITION IF- OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE NON CRISTINA KERO
FROM THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRAINTS. CRISTINA CAROL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE Q. AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CARL I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL CALIFORNIA I
THINK IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
FIFTY FIVE. I'M JUST MOMENTS
AGO BEFORE THE HEARING WAS
CALLED WE WORK WITH A VERSION
OF HEALTH CARE TO HAVE A
MAINTENANCE WHICH WERE
CIRCULATED. TODAY BUT WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OVER OF
THE LAND AND HOWEVER. WE AT TO
HAVE BEEN THAT THE AMENDED
VERSION OF THE BILL LOOKS LIKE
IT REMOVED THE EXEMPTION FROM
SUBSECTION NINE ABOUT THE
THIRTY FIVE. WOULD HAVE
EXEMPTED. YOU CAN OR A DIVISION
FROM AT THIRTY FIVE SO WAGE. ON
IT THAT IS THE REVISION WECONCUR WITH THAT HOWEVER WE ARE
STILL GETTING THE REVISED BILL-
I'M NOT GETTING THAT REVISION
WE STILL HAVE TWO MAIN CONCERN.
WITH THE BILL NO NEED TO BRING
TO HIS ATTENTION FIRST IT WOULD
GIVE THEM ALL YOUR DIVISION
OKAY BUT- AND. ACTIVISTS THAT.
LOCAL FROM MEDICAID IN BACK IN
IT WOULD PREVENT PUBLIC
PURCHASE IN PEOPLE I CAN'T BUT
DIVISION I BACK OUT THAT AND IT
WOULD PREVENT LOW DOG FROM MAY
THIS FINDING ARE UNDER THE
SUBDIVISION MAP ABOUT TO TRY TO
DO WITH LAND YOU PLANS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND YOU RATIONS
YEAH A DOT. THIRTY FIVE NOT.
UNLIMITED BACKING LEARN IS THAT
THE BILL WOULD REPLACE LOW
INCOME ON SITE OF HOW WHAT.
THAT ARE DIRECTLY GET FOR
THIRTY FIVE MINUTES APPROVAL
WITH THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
DEVELOPER IDEA K. AND IN LUCY
FOR COMPLY LOCAL. HOUSE ONE
WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY ON SIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS IS A
RED HERRING BECAUSE COMPLIANCE
WITH LOCAL ORDINANCES ARE YOU
ACQUIRED BY A LOT BUT IT'S ALSO
LIKE NOTHING YOU TO THAT
EFFECT. IT OFF THE TOP OF THE
BOX AND GOT TO MAY HAVE NO
MACINNES. COMMENT AFFORDABLE.
AND THE DILUTES IMMEDIATELY
PUTTING. BUT IT'S MEDICAID
COUNTY ARE STRUGGLING TO
IMPLEMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EXISTING IN THE FEES. LET ALONE
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A PROGRAM
SET UP. THE THIRTY THREE WE
ACTUALLY. CLOSE ONE THREE FIVE.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO TODAY
THANK. YOU LET'S GO NOW TO
THESE WITNESS ON YOUR LAWLER
FROM THE- ALONG PARTY. TO THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE-
SPEAK. OKAY IN HER LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE TEARING
MEMBERS- ON YOU LAWLER BEHALF
THAT THE WEB. ALREADY
CALIFORNIA. THE PUBLIC PROJECT
AMPLE I WOULD HAVE AT THIS TIME
WE REMAIN IN A AND AMENDED
PETITION ON THE DOCK ORGAN THE
COURT AND YOU CAN ON THE CALL
THAT ARE EQUITABLE INCLUSIVE
AND THAT HELP OUT THE HUSBAND
I'M JUST. SOME PEOPLE. AND
OTHER. HM THE VERY BEING HIT BY
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE UNDER
BUYER THE THING STOCK GENERALLY
WE HAVE TRUE PRIMARY ISSUES WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WRITE
CONTACTED WELL THE NAME. AND
THAT. WE WANT TO THAT THAT
RECEIVE BENEFITS UNDER THE OF
BILL COUNTRY TO A DROPPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS OF LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS IN A MANNER
COMMENSURATE WITH THE VALUE OF.
HI COULD BE HER AND HI AM.
PROJECTS OR THROUGH THE PAYMENT
ABOUT THE CALL PROJECTS THAT
CAN THEN BE TO PRODUCE HOW UP
FOR TO LOWER WE ALWAYS PREFER
THE ON THING. UNDER THE
ARGUMENT THAT FLORA. MAN ON
SMALL TOWN SUCH SECOND WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THE- REMAINING
MEASURES DO NOT EXACERBATE
PLACEMENT PRESSURES AND SAID
THIS UNITY IS WHILE WORKING
PART OF A- FINING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS. HOW CONTACT REALLY NOT.
HOUSING AND HIGHER MAKE. THAT
HAVE A HISTORY OF FAILING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO ME WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OF THAT ALL INCOME LEVELS
HOWEVER THE VERY STRATEGIES
THAT CAN HELP OPEN UP HIGHER.
PEOPLE IN A WHITE RANGE OF
INCOME LEVEL CAN THE- IT. LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
STREAMLINING THE DEVELOPMENT
HOUSING THAT ON AFFORDABLE TO
EXISTING RESIDENTS OF THE
COMMUNITY CREATE NEW PRESSURES
AND SENATOR TO PLACEMENT
EXACERBATING HOW THE CHALLENGES
ARE YOU EXPERIENCED BY LOW
INCOME PEOPLE. YEAH BUT THE
AUTHOR ALREADY AGREED TO
ACQUIRE HE- JOHN CHILDREN LINE
PROJECT. UNDER EIGHTY THIRTY
ONE FIFTY FIVE WILL ACCORD NEW
DISCUSSION ON HOW ABOUT THE SET
THE AMOUNT OF THAT FEE. TO
ADEQUATELY CAPTURED FROM THE
VALUE CREATED BY THE BILL WILL
STILL ENCOURAGING VULGAR TING
PROJECT FORWARD AND ALSO
INSURING AS THE PREVIOUSLY.
KNOWN AT THE TIME TO ACTUALLY
GET SENT THAT TIMELY MANNER.
YEAH I'M- CONVERSATIONS ON
PROTECTING THEM GIVE. FROM TO.
PROVIDE PRESSURES ARE GOING.
SMALLER MERCURY YOU KNOW. FOR
STREAMING THE BILL LESS EXPENSE
THAN LARGER MERCURY KNOW THEIR
CERTAIN NOT COUPLE AND THEIR-
REALLY OUT OF REACH. FOR OUR
COMPANY ONLY BE THIRTY TO FORTY
THOUSAND PER YEAR THANK VERY
MUCH UP WHERE. ON THE IN
HAPPENED. SHOW IT. IS LAWLER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WANTED.
THANK YOU MUCH IF WE COULD NOW
GO TO WE HAVE AN A OF FOLKS
HERE THE- OF WILL ACKNOWLEDGE
THEM AND WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
NINE. MY NAME IS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS RANDALL LADEN DISCOUNTS
IS SIXTEEN- PAINTERS LOCAL
FORTY SEVEN SACRAMENTO WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
OBSTREPEROUS. YEAH YEAH. MY
NAME IS ROBERT COOK SOME OF THE
SHEET METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE
OH FOUR WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING RADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL. WHEN I WAS TEN
SLEEP WITH THE SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OF FOUR. ALSO
OPPOSING STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
KERRY WOULD OCCUR ARE YOU P.
EIGHTY. DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN LOCAL FORTY SEVEN. AND
I STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. CAN FOR OUR
SEGMENT HERE BUILDING TRADES WE
STAND IN WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILLS WELL THANK YOU.
WHICH BATTLE I WOULD WORKERS
LOCAL NE EIGHTEEN WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. CHRIS GRADY WITH
THE CIRCLE ON THE SPHERE
BUILDING TRADES WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK I'LL ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE THIS BILL TO
THE OPERATOR. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE SO AGAIN IT IS ONE
BEEN ZERO WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR. IT IS
LINE FOUR ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YELLOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS SCOTT WEDGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BY TRADE COUNCIL. THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHE WORKERS. THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES. THE STATUS TO SEEK
TO ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS UNION
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE HERSELF BUT
THE OPPOSITION IN THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
THANK YOU. BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWO THAT IS
LINE. FOUR ZERO TWO. AFTERNOON
SURE NUMBER LOCAL RIGHT NOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WE GET
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND I DID
WANT TO SAY THAT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS YOU ADDRESS
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL AND TRAIN. AND OUR
REMAINING CONCERN IS REALLY
BASED ON THAT SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL WHICH IS THE END AT
THE THIRTY FIVE MINUTES I'LL
GIVE. WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
BE AUTHOR IN ORDER TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE- EXTREME
ENVIRONMENT REVIEW AND IF MY
FATE. THE WILLINGNESS ME OFF
BEFORE TO WORK THROUGH THE
CONCERNS WITH THAT. THANK I
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND ONE
LINE FOUR ZERO ONE. NOT BE
GAINES OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL TWELVE AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND HAMID
IS LINE FOUR ONE ZERO. HI MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY LOBBY WITH THE
LOCAL PARK FORTY NINE
BOILERMAKER AND WE STAND WITH
THE HUMAN TRAIT IN OPPOSITION
OF. MY NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY THAT IS LINE. FOR FOUR
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS COULD BE ABOUT
MOMMY YEAH BUT THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD A
BOILER MAKER AND WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. POINT
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE THAT IF LINE FOR FOUR NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FRANK
SALINAS REPORTING NOT
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN LOCAL TO NINETY FOUR
AND FRESNO. WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES NOT. MY NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
THAT IS LINE. FOUR SEVEN FOUR.
GO AHEAD LINE FOR SEVENTY FOUR
WE DO HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
MY NAME IS MARSHA ELEVEN
CHANCES GO AND I'M LIKE IN THE
ACTION AND I AND ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SO. WE HAVE MY NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
DEADLINE FOR SEVEN FIVE. MY
NAME IS CODY BACK WITH THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL PLASTERS THE
NATIONS OF NORTH CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADE IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH MY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY SEVEN LINE THREE
NINE SEVEN. HELLO THIS IS CHRIS
CANNON WHAT THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY THE BILLION
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITE.
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR LINE. THREE EIGHT. THIS
CALL HEADLINE THREE EIGHTY FOUR.
THREE FOR THE LINE IS OPEN IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE LINE
FOUR EIGHT ONE. YEAH YEAH THE-
CALIFORNIA. I'M EVERYONE AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK WHAT. THE FIVE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN YOU.
THREE FIVE. HI YOUR CENTER BUT
I BE. LOCAL ELEVEN LOS ANGELES
AND WE ASK YOU TO REPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND NINE
THAT IS LINE. FOUR ZERO NINE.
HI MY NAME IS STEVE ALONG
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN FLOOR COVERS LOCAL
TWELVE AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ONE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO LINE FOR EACH
YOU. YOUR CHEN NUMBERS KATE ON
HERE DROWNED THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL CLIPPERS IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE ONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN THAT IS
LINE NUMBER. FOUR ONE NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN
HUGHES WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN GLAZERS LOCAL SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THEY HAVE LINE
NUMBER FOUR AND TWELVE THAT IS
LINE. FOR ONE TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JEFF ROBERTS
WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
LOCAL UNION TO NINETY FOUR IN
THE FRESNO CALIFORNIA. WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. GIVE MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE THAT'S
LINE ONE SIX NINE. T
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE AGAIN LINE ONE SIXTY
NINE WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER FOUR
ELEVEN THAT PLANE FOUR ONE ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ANGEL
MEREDITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL REPRESENTING OUR
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS WE STAND
IN OPPOSITION TO THE STILL ALL
WORKS PEOPLE. THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE ALIGN THREE NINE ONE.
YEAH WATER IS ALWAYS REPRESENT
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PANDERS LOCAL TO NINETY FOUR
FOR NOW AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING IN OPPOSITION. YEAH MY
NUMBER. FOUR TWENTY NINE NINE
FOUR TWO NINE. YEAH MY NUMBER
NATIONAL MADONNA HOME WITH THE
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND I'M BURGEONING ALL
VOTE ON AB ONE THIRTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU. NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED IT NINE LINE HORSE.
FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TONY DI THAT THE PAINTERS
ALLOCATE JUST CALVET THIRTY SIX
ON BEHALF OF THE TO THOUSAND
MEMBERS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY UP THE POSTERS. MY
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED IN TWENTY
LINE. THREE TWO TWO. MR MEMBERS
THAT BROUGHT AFTER CAL TEAMS
MEMBERS OPPOSITION WE A MINOR.
THE BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
OF MY NUMBER FOUR HAD AND EIGHT
LINE. FOR SEVEN EIGHT. MIKE
FRANKLIN THOUSAND ABOUT SOUTH
OF THE ELECTRICAL WORKERS TO
DOCUMENT CALIFORNIA IBEW LOCAL
TWO FORTY. THEN WHAT THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. MY NAME IS THREE
HUNDRED NINETY LINE THREE NINE
SIX. THIS IS BRIAN HOLD WITH
THE ELECTRICAL WORKERS. ANY
IDEA EITHER LOCAL. WITH AND ON
TOP OF THIS TO THE BILL. HAVE
LINE NUMBER THREE HAD AND NINE
NINE LINE THREE NINE NINE MY
NAME LENNY WILKENS REPRESENT
GETS CUT SIXTEEN GLAZERS LOCAL
FOR GREATER LOCAL ONE SIX NINE
WE CAN LOOK AT BUILDING TRADE
IN OPPOSITION. HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THAT IS LINE. FOR ONE
FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KIMBERLY JEFFRIES UP IN THE
MEDICAL ABOUT THE LOCAL I. FIVE
TWENTY NINE. A WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THIRTY
ONE FIFTY FIVE. LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY FOUR LINE
TWO NINE FOUR. WE HAD LINE. TO
NINETY FOUR TO NINETY FOUR. IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WE DO HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. IT WILL NOT COME
OUT GOING SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
AND WE HAVE MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX LINE
FOR SEVEN THANK. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ONE
CALDERON I WOULD DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTED NOW I
TRADE CARPOOL MILLION STOCK CAR
LEADERS LOOK WELL AND WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSE THIS BILL. NUMBER THAT.
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LINE FIFTY FIVE WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. I'M SORRY
THERE'S NO RESPONSE LIVING ON
THE LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND THREE LINES FOUR ZERO THREE.
NINE FOUR ZERO THREE IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK PLEASE DO SELL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THREE. OUT YOU'RE
NOT GETTING A RESPONSE ONLINE
BRAND ALSO APPEAR CALIFORNIA
AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND IN THE MIDST
ACOSTA CONCERNS OBJECTION
INFECTION THE BECOMING A
CONCERN AROUND ONE IN THE MAIN
OF THANK YOU. BLIND FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR LINE. A.
FOUR YES MY NAME IS JOHN PAPA
BAR. CONSTRUCTION WELL BUSINESS
WORKERS. WITH COUNCIL OR UNION
TO SERVE GREATER BY WALKERS
WORDS STRONG NOT WITHIN. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN THAT'S LINE FORTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME BACK IN
EIGHTY AND I'M A RENTER IN
CULVER CITY CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
AB THREE ONE FIVE FIVE. MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED. IF LINE
FOUR EIGHT SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS DAMPENING WANTED FROM A
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN FLOOR
LAWYERS LOCAL TWELVE AND WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WHY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THAT IS LINE FOUR ONE FIVE. YES
MY NAME AGAIN WOULD DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN LOCAL PAINTERS
LOCAL NUMBER THE BAY AREA WE-
OPPOSITION. YEAH MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR THAT A
PLANE FOR SIX. YEAH GEORGE
STRUCK MORTON I'M A HOMEOWNER
AND CONSTRUCTION OWNER IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. I NEVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND. EIGHTY NINE NINE FOUR
EIGHT NINE. NINE FOUR EIGHTY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS. RANDY THOMAS REPRESENTING
BOILERMAKERS LOCAL LODGE BY
FORTY NINE WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND STRONGLY
OPPOSITION OF AB. ONE FIVE
FIVE. POINT NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE LINE. FOR NINE
ONE. MY NAME IS JENNIFER KALE
AND I LIVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
EIGHTY THREE ONE FIVE FIVE.
THANK YOU. NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME- ONE WE BRING
THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION. MR GIVER. THANK YOU
MISTERCHAIR- JUST WANNA
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FOR THIS THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
YOU KNOW I KNOW CAN NOT
SOMETIMES REQUIRE A LITTLE BIT
OF COURAGE POLITICAL TO JUMP
THE HOUSING PRODUCTION-
CONVERSATION I THINK WE'VE
CERTAINLY SEEN THAT. YOU KNOW
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME ABOUT
THIS BILL IT. HOW THE HOW THE
OPPOSITION HERE NOT WITH YOUR
BIOGRAPHY RIGHT WE'VE HEARD A
CONCERNS FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY FROM- FOLKS IN THE
LABOR COMMITTEE FROM EQUITY
GROUPS FROM HOMEOWNERS IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH IT. DOESN'T
MATCH UP WITH YOUR BY- BUT-
THESE AND ALL THESE FOLKS REYES
VERY LEGITIMATE CONCERNS- I
THINK THAT THEY MAKE REALLY
GOOD POINTS. BUT I DON'T KNOW
YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO. MOVEMENT
THE CHORE SOMEONE WHO HAS
DISTINGUISHED HERSELF AS
ENVIRONMENTAL CHAMPION LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT IN YOUR FIRST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
FOUGHT REALLY REALLY HARD FOR
FARMWORKERS AND IMMIGRANTS AND
FOLKS IN VULNERABLE COMMUTE.
I'VE EXTRA FAITH THAT YOU'RE
GIVEN YOU ARE. THE POLICY MAKER
WHO IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS OF ALL THOSE
GROUPS AND BE ABLE TO COME TO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN HAVE SOME
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY THAT.
HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY ABOARD
WITH. A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
YESTERDAY IN THE BANKING
COMMITTEE ABOUT SOME OF THE
POOR CONVERSATIONS OR HAVING
RIGHT NOW PROVIDING REALLY
BETTER JUST TO. NOT TO CAN. I
BUT THE CONVERSE HOUSING IS
JOHN TOO AND PRODUCTION AND A
MISSING MIDDLE PRODUCTION HOW
WE PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
JUST TO IMPORT YOU CAN. I THINK
THEY WERE POINTS FOR. SHE WAS
BECAUSE WE TALKED SENATOR
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH US FOR.
BUT I THINK THIS IS REALLY THE
ISSUE OF HOUSING AND HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS REALLY THE GREAT
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL AND
MORAL QUESTIONS FACING US AS
POLICY MAKERS IN SACRAMENTO
RIGHT NOW AS WE THINK WE COME
OUT OF NINETEEN CRISIS. I
REALLY APPLAUD YOU JUMPING INTO
THIS I KNOW IT'S NOT EASY I
KNOW THERE'S RESISTANCE NO
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS THAT ONE
WITH THE PERFECT THE ENEMY OF
THE GOOD POINT YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TODAY AND I'M LOU.
OR TO SUPPORTING THIS BILL. I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. ZERO
OTHER COMMENTS. MR KILEY.
HONEST ADEQUATELY THAT I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT PANEL I THINK A
LOT OF THINGS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO BUILD IN
CALIFORNIA- ARE ESPECIALLY
ONEROUS FOR YOU SMALLER
PROJECTS AND I THINK THIS BILLS
CAN HELP. UNLESS ANY OTHER
COMMENTS I WANNA. DO MISS QUIRK
SILVA DISH OKAY- FIRST OF ALL
LET ME JUST CONFIRM- WITH THE
AUTHOR THAT YOU'LL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS YES I. ALSO SAY
THAT IN THE INTRO I. ACCEPT ALL
THE GREAT. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY TO THE PUBLIC VERTICALLY
FOR FOLKS WHO. STILL HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL TO
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS- THIS AUTHOR. AND HIS
TEAM WORKED VERY VERY HARD-
PARTICULARLY AT THE LAST MINUTE
WITH CONCERNS OR REYES. AND I
KNOW. IN CERTAINLY IN THE SPACE
IT'S NOT EASY TO SATISFY ALL
THESE I THINK YOU MADE A VERY
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO- TO STRIKE
THE BALANCE. OF THIS. IF YOU
WANT ONE. THIS AYE INVOLVED.
THE 50% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THRESHOLD FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
TEN UNITS IN LESS AND WE ALL
KNOW WE ALL KNOW THAT IS SUCH A
HIGH STANDARD THAT IT IS RESULT
AND NEITHER OF MARKET RATE
UNITS OR FORMAL UNITS AND I. US
TWO IN THE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THIS PLACE IS A GREAT
IDEA- WE LOOK FOR TO YOU KNOW
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION WITH
YOU AS YOU WORK THROUGH THAT-
AS IT GOES TO THE PROCESS. I
ALSO WANT TO APPRECIATE THAT A
CREATIVE APPROACH YOU MADE- TO
MAKING THE SUBDIVISION MAP BACK
WORK BETTER FOR INFILL
PROJECTS- AND- YOU'VE TAKEN A
PROVEN IDEA. TO TRY THAT
STATEWIDE. ALSO WHAT. I THINK
YOU A AND- MANY OF US WERE
SURPRISED TO DATE. THERE FROM-
ARE OUR ALLIES- IN THE BUILDING
TRADES BECAUSE- EXISTING STATE
LAW HAS GENERALLY EXEMPTED
THESE PROJECTS AND- I KNOW THIS
IS A HARD CONVERSATION BUT-
THAT LONG WAS AGREE TO BYALL
PARTIES OVER THE YEARS FOR.
REASONS THAT I THINK WE ALL
KNOW SO- I KNOW WHAT THESE ARE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS BUT AS
YESTERDAY. WE GOT FOR. MEASURES
TO ADDRESS THREE OF TIME- WE
HAVE TO KEEP MOVING I KNOW THIS
CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE- WE
STILL HAVE A LONG WAYS TO GO ON
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BUT- OF
A HOUSING CRISIS. AND HOMES
PRICES WHICH IS- EXIT WHICH IS
INTENSIFIED BY A CRIME VIRUS
CRISIS WE'VE GOT TO KEEP KEEP
MOVING FORWARD SO. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND-
WITH. ME ASK. OUR TO CLOSE YEAH
YOU KNOW I DO. AS YOU'RE THE
COMMENTS I DID MAKE A SOME
SOME. SOME NOTES AND I GOT TO
GOT MY GLASSES BECAUSE I JUST
CAN'T SEE. WITHOUT THEM I CAN'T
THEM. FIVE BUT- AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER. AND ALL MY
COLLEAGUES I PRE. THE COMMENTS
AND DO YOU HAVE. A COUPLE
POINTS I HAVE TO MAKE IN
pONE IS YEAH I WANNA MAKE MYSELF
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT. THIS I
MEAN AS- MR CHIP YOU KNOW IT IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP THE FIRST
UP IN A- PROCESS. AND I'VE- AS
I'VE DONE WITH MY PRIOR BE OKAY
TO BRING IN ALL STAKEHOLDERS
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL IS
FAIR AND THAT IT'S RESULT
ORIENT YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN FROM THE
OPPOSITION. AND I HAVE MADE THE
COMMITMENT TO ENGAGE WITH THEM
I CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THEM-
ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUES AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD- YOU KNOW IN
THE- THE SECOND POINT IS YOU
KNOW I'M A LABOR PERSON. YEAH
YOU KNOW WHAT MY COLLEAGUE. MR
GABLE NOTED AND YOU KNOW I
BELONG TO THREE DIFFERENT
UNIONS IN MY CAREER. PRIOR TO
MY TIME- IN THE SIMPLY. YOU
KNOW I GREW UP IN POVERTY- AND
LIVED IN FORMER HOUSING AND IN
OVER OUR CONDITIONS AT THAT.
YOU KNOW I WAS ALSO RAISED BY
MY FATHER WHO WAS A FARMWORKERS
ENTIRE LIFE A PROUD UNION
MEMBER OF BELONGING TO THE U.
F. W. UNITED FARM WORKERS OF
AMERICA. AND IF YOU GO TO
OFFICE- YOU KNOW. I HAVE
HANGING ON MY WALL ONE OF MY
GRANDFATHERS PAY STUBS MY
GRANDFATHER HE SUPPORTED US IN
MY ENTIRE FAMILY OF TEN OF US.
AND ON MY WALL YOU'LL SEE IS
PACKED. IN THE LATE EIGHTIES
WHERE HE'D BEEN A FARM WORKER
AT THE SAME COMPANY FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. ON THAT PAYSTUB
IN THE LATE EIGHTIES HE WAS
MAKING SIX DOLLARS AND THIRTY
THREE CENTS AN HOUR SIX DOLLARS
AND THIRTY THREE OUR- SUPPORT
OUR ENTIRE FAMILY TEN. I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORT. OF
PROVIDING WORKERS WITH GOOD
PAYING JOBS PROVIDING THEM WITH
BENEFITS. WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS. AND I THINK IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THAT. LEGISLATURE
WE ALL WE SUPPORT LABOR. LOOK
AT THE PROOF AROUND HOW MUCH
HIS LEDGER THIS THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS VALUE LABOR
IT'S EVIDENT IN THE BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN PASSED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW CALIFORNIA. AND YOU
KNOW OUR JOB IS TO WORK AND
FIND SOLUTIONS TO OUR MOST
PRESSING PROBLEMS IN THE STATE.
IN OUR CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS
IS NOT GOING TO GO AWAY AND
IT'S ONLY GONNA GET WORSE UNDER
THIS PANDEMIC. AND SO WE NEED
TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PUT THE INTERESTS
OF PEOPLE OF ALL PEOPLE FIRST.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT TO
BE PROUD OF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVEN'T WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO DO. BUT
AS A NEW. OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW I AM NOT
OKAY WITH DOING NOTHING.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO DO IS TO STOP THIS
BILL KILL THIS BILL ALL. OKAY
BUT I'M NOT OKAY WITH THE FACT
THAT OUR STATE IS THE FIRST
YEAH IN WE HAVE THE FIRST IN
THE NATION POVERTY RATE. YOU
KNOW I'M NOT OKAY WITH CHILD
POVERTY IN STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS. I'M NOT OKAY
ABOUT PICKING UP THE NEWSPAPER
READING ABOUT POLICE OFFICERS.
CHOOSING TO SLEEP IN THEIR CARS
BETWEEN SHIFTS. BECAUSE THE
COMMUTE HOME IS TOO LONG. HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THE CENTRAL
FARMWORKERS. WITH THEIR
FAMILIES LIVING IN APPALLING
CONDITIONS IN THIS GOLDEN STATE
IN THIRD WORLD COUNTRY
CONDITIONS. YOU KNOW WHEN I
WILL ANYONE AND EVERYONE TO
FIND A WORKABLE SOLUTION AROUND
HOUSING. A TO FIND A PATHWAY TO
GET SOMETHING DONE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
WANTING AND WAITING FOR US TO
LEAD ON THAT. AND SO WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN. CAN I VOTE AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THEM 82% THIS
THANK THANK YOU LET ME UP WITH
THIS FOR. MOTION SECOND. RIGHT
MADAM SECRETARY COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS GEO.
Q. I DEEP. GABRIEL APRIL I
GLORIA KILEY KILEY IDLY MON
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA AYE THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES IT'S ON CALL GREAT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE ONE FINAL BILL
AUTHORED BEFORE THE BILLS THAT
I HAVE TO PRESENT SEPARATE. SO
WHAT ONE YES MISTER SANTIAGO TO
PLEASE JOIN US. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED. JACKSON A CO PRESENTER
PSYCHOLOGIST ABOUT THE MISTER
CHAIR FOR THE DAY NUMBER ON.
AND THE- THANK YOU FOR THE
ALARM IN PRESENT MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY- SO I. AM HAPPY OVER
STILL. PRESENT ON THE LAST. I
TELL YOU THAT I MEAN WE'VE BEEN
TO THIS TOURNEY OVER AND OVER
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT HOMELESSNESS.
AND I WOULD OR- THAT THE DAY IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER I'VE
GIVEN THE BILL IS GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC IN TUCSON ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS. NOW READ REPORTS
SUGGEST THAT THEY'LL BE A- ANY
TWENTY. OF 42405% INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS ALONE THIS
PARTICULAR YEAR THERE SOME
REGIONS IN THE STATE NOW
THERE'S- THAT INCREASED ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF OUR FOLKS. NOT TO.
AND SO WE ARGUE THAT THIS IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER AND
QUITE FRANKLY TO MODEST
INVESTMENT OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- FOR HOMELESS AS A 1%
OF OUR PROPOSED A BUDGET AND IT
BREAKS DOWN AS ALREADY ASSEMBLY
GO PLEASE PARTICIPATING BY
PERCENT GO TO THE- CARE. AT
FIVE WOULD GO FOR A HOUSING AND
IT REALLY IS A COMP APPROACH
THAT WILL TALK ABOUT THE BRICK
AND MORTAR PIECES OF HOUSING
PEOPLE BUT ALSO THE WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES. IN THE
AFFORDABILITY OF SINGLES
DESPERATELY NEEDED. YOU KNOW
AND WHILE MUCH HAS BEEN IN. IF
I THINK THAT IF YOU. ARNOLD ARE.
CONSTITUENTS IF THEY SEE A
DECREASE IN HOMELESSNESS- I THE
ANSWER WOULD BE PARTICULARLY-
DURING THE CALL THE CRISIS THAT
THE IN AN EXPLOSION
HOMELESSNESS. MORE ACROSS URBAN
CITY WHEN YOU DRIVE AROUND A
FEW MORE TENSE. I'M MORE CARS
PART OF FAMILIES IN A MORE OF
THESE MORE VANS AND
PARTICULARLY. ON THE FREEWAY
PAP IS. AHEAD AND I CHALLENGE-
NOT THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
KNOW IT'S BEEN SYMPATHETIC. BUT
WHO MAY BE LISTENING THAT TALK
HOMELESS IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THOSE WHO WITH THAT ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AND WE
BEEN THEM. ON THIS BOTH OF CAL.
HI BUT UP. YOU WERE ONE AWAY
FROM BEING RENT AND OUR LIVING
ON THE STREETS WITHIN OUR
CITIES AND THE FUNCTION THEY
SHOW UP THE WERE THEY THEY TRY
TO GET A JOB THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR PLACES TO SHOWER LIVE SOME
SORT OF LIFE AND WE SEE NO MORE
ON OUR NEIGHBORHOODS INCLUDING
MY OWN THIS INCLUDES. A RING.
HI THIRDS I URGEYOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP US PASS-
THIS BILL IN THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS POPULATION LAST YEAR
WITH PEGGED AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE. OF I THAT INCREASE
HOW TO MUCH LARGER NUMBERS
GIVEN THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND
THE PANDEMIC'S EFFECTS ON OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ABOVE- SO
WITH THAT- MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
A THIS BILL. ONE COLLEAGUES
SELECT PRESENT ON THE PHONE AND
I WANT ARE THE MAIN WITNESSES
TO RUN WITH THIS IS A MISTER.
THE MAYOR OF A- SACRAMENTO AND
AS WELL AS- DA IN TERM DIRECTOR
OF LHASA HEIDI MARCIN I THINK
THIS CHAIR GREAT TO ONE FIRST-
TIMELY MEMBER HE WAKES UP.
MADRE IF YOU. YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY AND- SUBJECT THE
PERKS- YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK I
HAVE EXPLAINED ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE WHY THE- MEASURE
CRITICAL- I THINK WE SEE IT
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN OUR- I
THINK YOU KNOW. THE NOW AN
ECONOMIC COLLAPSE IN A HOUSING
MARKET IN RENTAL MARKET
HOPEFULLY WE CAN STEM THE TIDE
WITH YOU FINANCIAL RESOURCES AN
ASSISTANT BUT- YOU KNOW WE
ALREADY HAVE TENT CITIES ARE
YOUR DATE- BY ALL THE TOP. I
CAN EXPECT IT. SIXTY THOUSAND
ON OUR STREETS AFFECTED BY OF
OUR WITH 20% OF THEM NEEDING
HOSPITALIZATION YOU KNOW
INVESTMENT IN HOW WE ADDRESS
THIS RIGHT NOW ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR PROJECT
ROOM KEY YOU KNOW IT CHEAP AND
HAVE HAD TROOP TO PROVIDE. MY
DISTRICT. BUDGET WILL CONTINUE
BE FUNDED SHOULD THE BOARD YOU
KNOW AND I THINK THIS BILL- AND
THE BUDGET OUT BILL BOND YOU
KNOW UPON PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUS
INVESTMENT BY THE- FLEXIBILITY.
PUBLISHED IN THE STATE MY
PERMIT FUNDING FOR. THAT
PERMANENT PEACE THAT IT'S
CRITICAL TO JUST YOU KNOW LOCAL
ARE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
COMBATING. HOMELESSNESS SO THIS
IS A VERY VERY CRITICAL. I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND IT'S AN
ISSUE. WITH THE BUSINESS
BEFORE- ART ART MAY REVISED
BUDGET BUT THE DISHES THAT THE
TRUTH THE MATTER IT'S NOT A
BISHOP AND I TO DO IT THE
ACTUAL QUITE. FACED WITH IT'S
MY HOPE IN THE- CORD BUT WE
FIVE THIRTY THREE. IN THE BUT-
I DO EVERY DAY DISTRICT AND I
KNOW YOU ALL DO AN INCREASE
THAT YOUR LONG BECAUSE LABOR
RESPECTASK WHEN I GO. THANK
YOU SIMPLY MEMBER WE NOW TO OUR
FOR WITNESS MAYOR TERREL
STEINBERG FROM SO TO OUR
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
ALLOW. UP MISTER STEINBERG TO
ADDRESS US. GOING TO LIKE IT
OPEN GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE WITH YOU. I WANT TO JUST
BEGIN BY SAYING THAT IS A
FORMER LEGISLATIVE LEADER-
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION I'M
FULLY COGNIZANT OF THE- FISCAL
CHALLENGES. YOU FACE. AND YES
WHEN WE REALLY STEP BACK AND
THINK ABOUT THE TIME WE ARE
LIVING IN HOMELESSNESS WAS. A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS BEFORE
COVERT NINETEEN. IT HAS
ELEVATED AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS DURING CO NINE. QUESTION
YOU'LL TO FOR. IS ARE WE GOING
TO TAKE THE STEPS TO TAKE
APPROPRIATE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN PERS INTO WEST TO
MAKE IT BETTER. ONCE WE ARE
MERGED. CRISIS AND HERE IS THE
MOST PRACTICAL EXAMPLE OF WHY
THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT AND
WHY AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING THE WHETHER IT'S FROM
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND OR
THROUGH SOME COMBINATION OF
RESOURCES- READERS TO VOTE OR
ISSUE FEDERAL STIMULUS OUR
STATE FUNDING IS. SOME
PATTERSON I WOULD ACTUALLY SAY
GREAT SUCCESS WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE TIME FROM THE AMOUNT OF
TIME. WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR
THE LEGISLATURE AND- CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE STAND UP
THIS PROJECT ROOM KEY. WHICH
HAS BEEN AN UNPRECEDENTED
EFFORT TO BRING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AND SHELTERED PEOPLE
INTO- IN MOTEL. NOW WE'VE GOT A
WAYS TO GO A AND THE NUMBERS
ARE ARE STILL MOVING FORWARD
BUT HERE'S THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE. CHALLENGE IS. HOURS
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT WE
BRING INTO TEMPORARY SHELTER
WHETHER IT'S THE MOTELS WHETHER
IT'S OUR LOW BARRIER TRIAGE
SHELTERS WHERE THERE IS A
VARIETY OF OTHER- MEANS CITIES
HAVE STOOD UP. AND COUNTIES
HAVE STOOD UP TO HELP BRING
PEOPLE INDOORS WE DON'T HAVE A
CLEAR ANSWER QUESTIONS TO EDIT
ACT WITHOUT ANY. SHE MAKES IT
HARDER TO. INDUCE WHO ARE ON
THE STREETS TO ONE TO COME IN
BECAUSE THEY ASK WAS JUST GOING
TO BE. ATTEMPT THING OR IS.
BACK FOR ME TO MOVE THROUGH A
CONTINUING TO ARE GETTING
LONGER TERM HELP AND SO THIS
BILL COMBINATION WITH NO THE
BILL WE'RE GOING TO HEAR. BY
THE CHAIRMAN I THINK YOU'RE THE
ESSENTIALLY. ACTUALLY MAKING A
SUBSTANTIVE REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBERS OF ON SHELTERED
HOMELESS PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS
MONEY PLUS PUBLIC POLICY. AND
THIS IS THE ESSENTIAL MONEY
PAID. SUPPORTED MUCH MISTER
BEAR WE COULD TURN OUT TO THE
SECOND WITNESS TO THE MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ALLOW
HIDING AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LA HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY TO SPEAK. I MISS
MARTIAN PLANS OPEN. THANK YOU I
THINK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR Q.
AND MEMBERS OF THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
WITH YOU IN A PART OF AB THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED I AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO I'M
WITH IT IF I NEED FIGHTING MARK
THEN AINDA INTERMENT BACKING OF
DIRECTOR THE BILL WE- THE- A.
B. O. B. AND- ALL. THE CRISIS
UP HOME WITH NEARLY NINE
THOUSAND. EXPERIENCING HOME
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND OF THEM ARE
ON SHELTER. AT LOCAL RESOURCES
LIKE MEASURE RATES IN THE STATE
RETARDED LIKE HE'D HAVE A LOT
OF THE HOUSE MORE PEOPLE THAN
EVER- WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
THIRTY. THE HOUSE EVERY DAY IN
NINETEEN BUT BECAUSE OF A
SEVERE SHORTAGE OF HOUSING OUT
A PORTABLE PICKS MAINLY LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS EACH DAY
OUTPACING OUR- EIGHT. REPORT
THAT. WILL FALLING FIRED THEIR
WAS A NEED DOWN EVEN IN THE
NUMBER OF POP AND EVERY PERSON
LA FOR FLEXIBLE FUNDING FROM
THE STATE- BUT THAT'S QUITE
THAT HAD MADE THE NEED EVEN
GREATER- AND IT'S NO LONGER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS BUT
IT ALSO HELPS RIGHT THERE AND A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH. UNDER
EIGHT. CALIFORNIA BY. THIRD
PARTY IF THE BALLOT AND SELL IN
PLACE WHICH IS WHY BLOCK THE
COLLABORATION WITH LEADERSHIP
FROM THE STATE THAT LA THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND- BJ. BRING
HE IN. HE I THINK CARD I'VE
BEEN YESTERDAY I MAKE TO YOU
OPENED OVER TWENTY NINE HUNDRED
ROOM IN A IF HE WE BOB IN
HEALTHCARE NOT HOW THE CROP THE
COUNTY. ONE THE- RIGHT. SIDE WE
CAN'T GO BACK TO. WELL AND
ALLOW THE RESIDENTS WERE IN THE
FIVE TO RETURN TO THE RIVER OF
THE- AND EIGHTY THIRTY THREE
HOW. GIVE ME IS THAT WHAT READ
NEEDED MEAT BUT HOW. WHY I LIKE
TO GO UP THE FOR AND AS AS
SHALL AND EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
AFFORDABLE LACK AND- WHERE WE
TALKED ABOUT. CERTAIN WE HAVE.
LEVERAGED. WHAT CAN BETWEEN THE
COUNTY AND CITIES BRINGING ALL
THE RESEARCH TO THE AS WELL TO
A WERE EVERYTHING THAT THE BILL.
WE REALLY THE LEE OF ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU AND BRINGING THE FOR.
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE YOU AND
YOUR AYE ABOUT THE SPELL. OF
THANK YOU WE NOW MY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE IT MEMBERS PUBLIC
THEY WISH TO EXPRESS SUPPORT ON
THIS MATTER LET ME ACKNOWLEDGE
SOME IN THIS CHAMBER AT THIS
MOMENT. I RESERVE THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND IF WE CAN
NOW GO TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PRESSED ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
PHONE KEYPAD AGAIN MEDI IS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY SIX. BUT IF.
SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
MEMBERS BONTA WOULD CALL ME IN
THE STRONGEST THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND.
TWO AGAIN LINE FIVE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBER MY NAME
IS ALAN I AM A MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT UNITED NETWORK OF LOS
ANGELES AS WELL AS THE HOME
WITH THE ADVOCATE. I REPRESENT
THE HOMELESS AND FORMERLY
HOMELESS. AND WHAT WHO HAS A
VERY HOMELESS. I TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE CALL SPONSORED
IN REGARDS TO A. B. THREE HOW.
I THINK EVERYONE HAS INDICATED
THE MANTRA WHAT ABOUT SAVING
LIVES AND WHAT ABOUT WORKABLE
SOLUTIONS AND PATHWAYS LIT BILL
IN DE PRODUCES THAT AND COME.
EIGHTEEN OKAY BUT WHY CUT HIS
MIKE HEALTH MY FOR OTHER AND WE
ARE GET A QUICK IN REGARDS TO
GETTING THE COURT AND I FELT
THANK YOU. GO TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE LINE
TWO TO THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SHERIN REPORT WITH
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IN STRONG. GO TO MY
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND SIX
LINE FIVE ZERO SIX. SECOND
TALLEST NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED AND ONE LINE OF
FIVE ZERO ONE. MAKING SURE
MEMBERS OUT FOR AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN THAT'S
LINE SIX SEVEN. A LINE SIXTY
SEVEN WE HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITHOUT
THE CALIFORNIA AND STRONG. MY
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THAT'S LINE FIVE ONE
THREE. OTHER GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PUBLIC POLICY OFFICER WITH
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
WOMEN HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THAT IT LINE SIX ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON BILL THE FERRARI
AND BE HAPPY FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. MY FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTH AT EIGHT FIVE ZERO
SEVEN. HOLLY FOR ME THEY HAVE
TO BUT LIKE HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE PIECE COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION AT THE AT HOME. P.
AND G. PARTNER I'M NOT BE HAPPY
I WOULD HAVE PROFANITY
CALIFORNIA ALL POINTS ON THE-
WE HAVE LINE. FOR TWENTY FOUR
FOUR TWO FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FOR TWENTY FOUR. NINE FOUR
TWENTY FOUR WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
I WILL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED AND THREE THAT
PLANE AT FIVE ZERO THREE. HI
NATALIE MAC BUT THEY HAVE THE
FACT THAT THE LA RIVER AND
STRUCK THE BOARD. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FIVE. EIGHT FIVE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS SPEAKERS ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM LICCARDO I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED- BUT ALSO LIKE TO
CITY MAYORS. I TO SHARE THE
AGAIN WANT TO THANK US SANTIAGO
AND SHOWS MEASURE THANK YOU.
AND LINE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED
AND NIGHT THAT'S LINE. FIVE
ZERO FIVE. BUT I CAN MARKET ON
BEHALF OF LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA REPORT THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN LINE TWO SEVEN
SEVEN. WE HAD LIKE TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
REALLY GOOD ONE I LIVE IN
PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- I AM A
SINGLE PARENT IT TOOK ME SEVEN
YEARS AFTER BEING DISABLED TO
FIND HOUSING FOR ME AND MY
DAUGHTER- THIS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. BILLION SERVICES WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO HELP IN OUR
BUSINESS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT WILL
TELL. THE TEMPORARY TO. THAT'S
WHY THIS BY IN THIS BILL IS I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO LINE. SIX TWO WILL BE
SAN FRANCISCO CONSTITUENTS- AN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT- NUMBER
SEVENTEEN STRONG SUPPORT. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DEADLINE.
FOUR THREE ZERO. HELLO MY TO
CARRERO REFUSING TO LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT AND THEY ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER SANTIAGOAND
ALL THE CO AUTHORS WHO ARE
CAN'T BE PHOTO TERRY POINT FOR
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
NINETY NINE THAT SLOT ONE NINE
NINE. YEAH I CAN REALLY I DON'T
ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENT AND
MEMBER OF LOOK AWAY SO IT TO
ME- STRONG WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THAT'S LINE FIVE ONE FIVE.
BECAUSE OF MY NAME IS PROFITING
FROM THE BUILDING I'M IN SANTA
CRUZ CALIFORNIA- PARADE
DEDICATION PURPOSES- I'VE BEEN
APPOINTED. COMMUNITY VERY
COMMITTEE ON THAT I ALSO SERVE
OUR OUR REGION CONTAINING THE
CARE OR- CALLED THE WHOLE OF
ACTION PARTNERSHIP. AND ON
BEHALF OF IN THE PARK AND
SUPPORT WITH THE THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY THAT'S WHY FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH LINE
FIFTY FIVE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU ASSURE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TAKEN DOLLARS ABOUT
HAVE YOU AT LEAST TALK SHOW A
NONPROFIT HOUSING PROVIDER NEXT
YOU GROUP IS ALSO A BETTER WEEK
FOR TO HELP CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH YEAH LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. WORK OF THANK YOU.
YOU I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. LET ME
ASK IF THERE MEMBER ANY MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC THE WISH TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. YEAH I DO HAVE- ONE
OTHER PERSON WHO IS I BELIEVE
IN SUPPORT- THAT JUST POPPED
INTO MY YOU JUST ONE MOMENT.
I'LL REMIND EVERYONE OF FOR
POSITION IF YOU WILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN FOUR.
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WHAT A LINE. FIVE
TWELVE FIVE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THE LINE IS OPEN. I AM OPERATE
CALLING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL IT
WOULD NOT ONLY SAVE LIVES YOUR
WILL ALSO SAVE THE STATE MONEY
PEOPLE WITH COLUMNS. ARE JOB
YOU HEAR IT'LL TAKE A DOCTOR.
THEY ALSO TO STAY OUT OF GOOD
CERTAIN FIXED SO PLEASE. IN
THAT. GOOD THANK YOU. ALTHOUGH
THE LINE NUMBER ADD TO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX LINE. TWO FIVE
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
HENRY PARKER AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I LIVE IN
SANTA CRUZ NOT BECAUSE YOU
REPRESENTATIVE THANK YOU JUDY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU- ARE IN OPPOSITION
A PRESS ONE THEN IT IS ZERO. I
GET THE IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEM ZERO. NO ONE
ELSE QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. CULTURALLY
DISSENTING MISTER KILEY. MISTER
SANTIAGO SO WE SPENT- TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION ONE HOMELESS THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS THE PROBLEM
IS ONLY GOTTEN WORSE AND NOW WE
HAVE THIS PROPOSAL FOR TWO
BILLION MORE. AND THAT I'M JUST
WONDERING I DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON WHY- PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS. DIDN'T WORK
BECAUSE WE MIGHT HAVE LIKED AND
WHY IS THIS INVESTMENT GOING TO
PRODUCE DIFFERENT GIRLS YEAH
AND I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
FIRST AYE AYE I. SHOULD A
SERVANT OF THE YOU KNOW ONE
THING. ALL THE- OTHERS IT
BOTHERS PICCOLI ONE WHO IS
SITTING ON THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
A THIS QUIRK SILVA SUPPOSE
MONTHS AND THAT IN WITHOUT SAY
WITHOUT- I ALSO SHOULD
RECOGNIZE MISTER BLOOM BONTA
GIFTS AND- AND WHICH WAS SPOKEN
HISTORY- SO I APOLOGIZE CONCERT
INDEED THE ANSWER. QUITE
FRANKLY HAS WORKED HERE'S
HERE'S A HERE'S HERE'S WHAT YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HERE IS WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND TO THE CHAIR
ABOUT THE AGE OF HOMELESSNESS.
IT IS AS THE INCOME INEQUALITY
WINDS MORE PEOPLE FALL ON
STREET AND FALL ON THE PEOPLE
OF ALL OF FAMILIES ARE ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY. FROM LANDING ON
THE STREETS OF THE BAR. IF YOU
YOU TAKE A AT SAMPLE CARE THAT
I REPRESENT OR THE LOS ANGELES
REGION THE LARGEST PULL PEOPLE
WHO LAND FOR PEOPLE WHO. WHO
ARE ON THE VERGE OF LANDING ON
BUT THERE IS. QUAN OF DATA
SHOWS THE MONEY BUT NOT. WHAT
IN PEOPLE. IS THERE ARE YOU
SURE THE WORK ON THAT THE LEAD
TO LET LET A TACKLING SUCH AS
OF HOUSING SUCH A BETTER WAGE
SUCH AS OF THE OTHER THINGS
OTHER THAN MENTION THIS
COMMITTEE BUT THERE ENOUGH THAT
TO SHOW THAT THE DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT OUR HOUSING PEOPLE
IN FACT EARLIER TODAY WAS
REFERENCE- PROJECT ROOM KEY THE
STATE IS I BELIEVE ARE PURSUING
CONTRACTS WITH- WITH HOTELS-
AND MOTELS TO HOUSE PEOPLE AND
HALF OF THEM ARE ARE ALREADY
FULL. OF SO THOSE PEOPLE ARE
HOUSED THE LARGER THAN A WE'VE
NOT TACKLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BETTER WAGES BETTER JOBS. HAS
RESULTED IN A LIGHTING AN
UNCOMMON EQUALITY MORE PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREETS. I WOULD
ARE YOU SAYING- MUCH MORE
INVESTMENT NEEDS AND NEEDS TO
BE DONE. WELL I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU THAT THERE ARE SOME
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS OUT THERE
THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A GREAT SENSE AT ALL OF.
WHAT THEY ARE AND THEIR GOALS
ARE BUYING- THAT COULD BE
BETTER SPENT IN THE HOUSE THIS
TO ME AFTER TEN. REALLY FIGURE
THAT OUT AND EVEN YOU KNOW BUT
I CAN'T AGREE WITH YOUR
ASSESSMENT THAT THINGS HAVE
OVERALL BEEN WORKING EVEN THE
GOVRNOR AND HIS STATE THE
STATE. ADDRESS IT DOESN'T. AND
IT. IS THAT WHEN IT WAS A SAYS
THE GOVERNOR'S IN THIS ADDED
WHEN WAS SPENDING PROPOSAL.
THAT NEW FOR. COULD QUICKLY.
WITHOUT DEMONSTRATING MUCH
PROGRESS. INVESTMENTS ARE MADE
WITHOUT A CLEAR PLAN SO. I
WOULD JUST YOU KNOW- URGED THAT
WE THINK VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT.
WHERE THE FUNDING IS GOING
BECAUSE I CAN GUARANTEE YOU IF
YOU'RE DOING A BETTER JOB
SPENDING THE LAST TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION IN DOING AND
USING THAT. YOU KNOW THE DATA
THAT WE HAVEN'T REQUIRED IN
ORDER SPEND MORE ON THE THINGS
THAT WORK AND SPENT MOST OF THE
THINGS THAT DON'T WORK AND THAT
WOULD DO A HECK OF A LOT MORE
GOOD. THAN JUST THROWING TWO
POINT TWO BILLION MORE DOLLARS
THE PROBLEM. IS NOT. NINE FIVE.
I AT LEAST APPRECIATE THE- TO.
ADD TACKLE HOMELESSNESS
SITUATION IN THE- IN A MAJOR
WAY. I CALL ME BACK OF COURSE
THANK YOU I BELIEVE THE
QUESTION WAS THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE EXPENDED BY THE STATE- TO
THE CHAIR- IF THAT IF WE SEE IN
SOME- SOME SUCCESS IN THE IT
WAS YES I DON'T THE QUESTION
WAS HAVE WE DONE ENOUGH.
HOMELESSNESS TO RESOLVE THE-
ANSWER ACTUALLY NOT. A 100% WE
SHOULD BE DOING A HECK OF A LOT
MORE WE SHOULD BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE AND IN FACT I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THAT A TWO BILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST OUT OF A STAFF
OF TWO BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
THE NUMBER THAT'S BEEN SEVERAL
BY THE GOVERNOR. HI MOM WHEN
YOU REALLY THINK OF 1% THIS IS
THE- SHE- OUR- OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES IN THE STATE.
WE'RE ONLY GONNA ALLOCATE CLOSE
1% I MEAN WHAT'S THAT SAY ABOUT
OUR VALUES I THOUGHT SO I WOULD
ARGUE WE NEED TO INVEST A LOT
MORE. MISTER COOPER THANK YOU
MISTER TURNER SO I CAN ACTUALLY
RESIST THE OPPORTUNITY EVEN
THOUGH THE DAY IT'S LIKE TO- TO
NOTE FOR MISTER KIND OF ACTIVE
A BILL UP TODAY THAT'S ON
CONSENT IT'S A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX THAT ACTUALLY IT'S
PARTISAN ALL THEIR EIGHTEEN
NUMBER. PUTTING THE ASSEMBLY
REPUBLICAN LEADER. OF THE WITH
ATTACHED. US TO COLLECT A LOT
OF DATA SO WE HAVE A BETTER
SENSE ABOUT WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING ONE ON WE CAN DO GOOD
DATA DRIVEN POLICY MAKING AN
INVESTOR SCARCE DOLLARS IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WHY SO I JUST
WANTED TO- YOU KNOW SUPPORT
WOOD MISTER SANTIAGO TRYING TO
DO. IN DRUGS ABOUT. RESEARCH
PROBLEM BUT- WITH YOUR. THAT'S
ABOUT THE NEED FOR TIME FOR
TRANS WITH TAXPAYER AND ABOUT
THE NEED GATHER DATA GOOD DO
GOOD DATA TERM POLICY MAKING SO
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT THAT
BILL WAS ON- CONSENT TODAY AND
THAT IF I TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
IT. YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO. IF YOU WANT WE CAN
NOTE THAT BUT- THAT'S UP TO
YOU- I WILL. ALSO SAY THAT I
THINK. WE ALL. I THINK WE WOULD
ALL AGREE WE NEED MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND
HOMELESSNESS AND ACTUALLY THE
NEXT BILL. THAT I'M GONNA
PROCESS. TO TACKLE THAT TOPIC.
ONE OF THE CHILD WE HAVE. IS
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE- A-
HUNDRED. THOUSAND AND-
CALIFORNIANS ANY. WEAKER ALMOST.
THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE ON THE
EDGE OF BECOMING HOME THIS AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY CHALLENGE IN.
OUR IN STEMMING. THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT ARE BECOMING
HOMELESS EVERY NIGHT SO FOR
EXAMPLE A I THINK THE
STATISTIC IS. WHAT HOUSING
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE PEOPLE
EVERY. AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PEOPLE BECOMING HOMELESS ON
THAT AMAZINGLY START. AND
THAT'S ONE. THAT'S ONE SO WE'RE
REALLY FACING. IT'S NOT JUST
HOUSING THE FOLKS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS IT IS NOT A
STEP. IN THE TIME. UP WHAT. I
THINK WALGREENS. HE AN ON GOING.
TO ADDRESS THIS THIS PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY INTENSIFIED THIS THIS
OUTLOOK AND- AND THIS CAN BE
HARD NOW ONE THING I WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST IS- I KNOW THE SOURCE
OF THE- AND OUR GENERAL FUND
HAS- BEEN DECIMATED JUST IN THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS AND I THINK.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT POINT.
SOURCES FUNDING ARE AND I KNOW
THIS IS A CONVERSATION A NUMBER
OF US HAVE HAD BUT I LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE THAT SO THAT. BACK
TO MISTER SANTIAGO. YEAH AND
ALL THAT IS MY CLOTHES IN THE
INTEREST OF THE COMMITTEE'S
TIME AND- WANT TO THANK ALL THE
JOINT AUTHORS THE COMMITTEE
FOR. THE WORLD THIS. LEAVING A
LONG TIME. A FUNDING SELECTION
OR ONLY JUST NUMBERS CONTINUE
TO EXPLODE- AND- I. YOU DO EVEN
THOUGH WITH THIS. GREAT MR
GLORIA SECONDED BY MS QUIRK
SILVA MEDICINE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHIO FIVE Q.
DEEP. GABRIEL APRIL I GLORIA
GLORIA AYE AYE KILEY. KILEY NOW
THE MOM. MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK
SILVA RIGHT. YOUR FOR VOTES-
WILL WAIT FOR OTHER STAT ON
THANK YOU THINK MISTER. BUT
THIS TIME I'M GOING TO.
RELINQUISHED THE CHAIR INTO MR
GABRIEL WHILE I PERCENT- THE
FINAL THREE BILLS OF TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR INTEREST- I BELIEVE THEY
WERE GONNA GO A LITTLE BIT OUT
OF ORDER WITH- WITH FILE ITEM
AT TWENTY FOUR AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO SIXTY NINE- MISTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A NUMBER THE
FIVE. IN A LOT OF TIME. AND
WHAT TO HIS TESTIMONY THIS. I'M
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL. IS
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR HOMELESS PROGRAMS- EXACTLY
THE DISCUSSION WE WERE JUST
HAVING WITH THE LAST BILL ARE
AND I KNOW IT IT THIS IS A CAN
KNOWS FULL WELL THE DIRE CRISIS
HOMELESSNESS BUT AS A REFERENCE
BEFORE. EVERY NIGHT OF THE WEEK
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS FOR
HOMELESS. W HAVE THE HIGHEST
RATE OF ON SHELTER HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN THE NATION. AND
AS I JUST STATED AS PEOPLE ARE
HOUSE MORE FOR INTO
HOMELESSNESS. IN LA FOR EVERY
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE PEOPLE
HOUSE. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
TO HOMELESSNESS. IN OAKLAND FOR
EVERY ONE PERSON WHO IS ALLEGED
TO FALL INTO. AND UNFORTUNATELY
AM I AM- SUCH A REPORT THAT IN
MY OWN CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
FOR EVERYONE PERSON HOUSE THREE
FALL TO HOMELESSNESS. AND THIS
WAS BEFORE CORONA VIRUS. THE
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED THE
CRISIS GASOLINE ON FIRE. IF WE
DON'T HOUSE PEOPLE WE ARE
INTENSIFIED THE VIRUS SPREAD.
AND ECONOMIC CALAMITIES LEADING
TO A NEW WAVE OF HOMELESSNESS
AS MR SANTIAGO JUST MENTION-
THE ECONOMIC PROJECTIONS ARE
THAT HOME ASSIST. GREECE BY 12%
OUR STATE A LOT. AS A RESULT.
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL OF REGIONAL
HOMELESS ADVISORS AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR THE CULTURES OF THAT
EFFORT. TIME BURKE WHO YOU'LL
HEAR FROM SOON AS WELL AS
SUPERVISOR MARK REALLY THOMAS
FROM LA BOTH OF WHOM ARE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. EARLIER
THIS YEAR BEFORE CRIME VIRUS
WHEN OUR GOVERNOR WAS DEVOTING
HIS STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
ON HOMELESSNESS. THE GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL MADE A KEY
RECOMMENDATION THAT OUR STATE
ESTABLISHED AND ENFORCEABLE
RESULTS BASED ACCOUNTABILITY
MANDATE TO END HOMELESSNESS.
SINCE WE ALL KNOW THAT PURELY
VOLUNTARY EFFORTS BY MYRIAD OF
LOCAL AND STATE JURISDICTIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
FUNDING HAVE FAILED WITHOUT
THAT. AND I WANT ALSO
KNOWLEDGE- MISTER SANTIAGO IS A
JOINT AUTHORED THIS BILL. WAS
LOOK AT THE CONDITION WE BOTH
INTRODUCED BILLS THE SPACE
MERGER EFFORTS FOR THIS CAR.
THE SECOND CONVERSATION THAT
HAS LED TO THIS BILL IS A LEGAL
ONE. BEFORE CORONAVIRUS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAD COME UNDER
INTENSE PRESSURE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS FROM. CONSTITUENTS
PUBLIC INTEREST ADVOCATES
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
OF COURSE PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS. THE LATEST
PRESSURE POINT HAS BEEN IN THE
COURTS. IN RECENT YEARS
ADVOCATES HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
SUED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AROUND
STATE WHO FAIL TO HOUSE THE ON
SHELTER. THE NINTH CIRCUIT
BOISE CASE BEING THE MOST
PROMINENT. I KNOW OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK SILVA IS
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THIS BECAUSE
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND CITIES AND
HER COUNTY. THEY WERE
SUCCESSFULLY SUED OVER THIS.
AND WHILE ONE FEDERAL JUDGE
JUDGE DAVID CARTER HAS IT WE
HELD. ACCOUNTABLE TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS. THAT LEGAL
PROCESS HAS BEEN COMPLEX
EXPENSIVE AND TIME CONSUMING
FOR LITIGANTS LOCAL GOT AND I.
OUT A HAVE FILE LAWSUITS WERE
SENT DEMAND LETTERS TO LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO. SANTA CRUZ
SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO AND
OTHER JURISDICTION. THIS BILL
WILL CREATE A SAYS HOLD STATE
AND LOCAL ACCOUNT FOR HOUSING
ARE ON SHELTER BASED ON
MEASURABLE GOALS AN EXISTING
RESOURCES IDENTIFIED FOR THAT
PURPOSE. HOPEFULLY AVOIDING THE
NEED FOR COMPLEX EXPENSIVE AND
TIME CONSUMING LEGAL FIGHTS
AROUND STATE. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ASSESS
THEIR RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND TO PROVIDE
THAT ANALYSIS TO OUR STATE
HOMELESSNESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL. IT REQUIRES
EACH CFC TO REVIEW THAT
ANALYSIS AND DEVELOP BENCHMARK
GOALS. BASED ON THOSE GOALS IT
REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP AN
ACTIONABLE PLAN TO REDUCE
PROCESS BY 90% BY DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. AND IN ORDER TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD HE WOULD ESTABLISH
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL POSITION
HOMELESSNESS INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THAT COULD BRING A PUBLIC RIGHT
OF ACTION AGAINST STATE
AGENCIES OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR FAILING TO SUBMIT A PLAN
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF ACTION WOULD BE
LIMITED TO EXISTING RESOURCES
SET ASIDE BY A JURISDICTION. TO
RATHER THAN WAITING FOR
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK NUMBER TWO
OR EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING
LAWSUITS TO FORCE THIS QUESTION
OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO AROUND
HOMELESSNESS. THIS BILL WOULD
PROACTIVELY ESTABLISH PLANS.
METRICS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENFORCEMENT. BY HOLDING ALL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE BASED
ON THESE BENCHMARKS THIS BILL
WILL HOPEFULLY MOVE CALIFORNIA
TORE FINALLY ADDRESSING THE
MORAL CRISIS OF OUR DAY. AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN THIS
OVER TO OUR WITNESSES AS I
MENTIONED- THE MAYOR OF THIS
CITY THE CHAIR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL OF REGIONAL
HOMELESS ADVISORS. AND A FORMER
SENATE PRESIDENT. MAYOR
STEINBERG AND THEN- WE WILL
HEAR FROM THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO- FROM MORE A TOP TOP. I
JUST WANNA MENTION- THAT SENIOR
SUPERVISOR NEEDS AND FLETCHER
WAS PART OF THE COUNCIL AND
SUPPORTED THE KEY
RECOMMENDATION THAT THIS THIS
LAWS BASED ON SO WITH THAT. ASK
YOUR SUPPORT AND WILL TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WITNESSES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR OUR
FIRST WITNESS IS- MAYOR DEAR
SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR YOU AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR. YOUR
COURAGE IN. BEING WILL WILLING
TO PUT FORWARD A VERY
PROVOCATIVE BUT IN. AND AS YOU
SAID THIS BILL REFLECTS. THE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT- OF THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL OF HOMELESS
ADVISORS INCLUDING NINE OUT OF
THIRTEEN MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN ONE. ASPECT
OR ANOTHER LET ME STIPULATE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AND
DAD- A PUBLIC POLICY LIKE THIS
IS NOT THE END OF THE STORY AND
IT WILL NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM
JUST AS MORE MONEY ALONE- WILL
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM. BUT A
COMBINATION OF MORE CLEAR AND
DIRECT PUBLIC POLICY. IN BORN
THERE WERE SAYS THE BEST
CHANCE. WE POSSIBLY HAVE TO
MAKE A GREATER DANTE IN THIS
PROBLEM. THE LEGISLATURE IS
OBVIOUSLY A POLICY MAKING BODY
I WAS PRIVILEGED TO SERVE FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS. AND WHEN WE
STEP BACK AND THINK ABOUT IT
JUST A MOMENT THIS WHAT ARE
COMMISSION GRAPPLED WITH WHAT
IS THE PUBLIC POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
HOMELESSNESS. I DON'T MEAN TO
DENIGRATE ANY OF THE HEROIC
EFFORTS DID GO ON AMONG
GOVERNMENTS AND NON PROFITS BUT
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS. OUR
PUBLIC POLICY IS LET'S DO THE
VERY BEST WE CAN. EVERYTHING WE
DO IS OPTIONAL INVOLUNTARY
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT TO
BRING PEOPLE INDOORS. THERE IS
NO HOUSING PRODUCTION STANDARD
OF ANY KIND. THERE IS A EFFOR
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
OFTENTIMES DATA HAPHAZARD WAY
FRANKLY AMONG THE NUMEROUS
JURISDICTIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHERE THE PROBLEMS
INTERSECTED NO NO ARTIFICIAL
BOUNDARIES WE ARE SEPARATE
FUNDING STREAM SEPARATE
PROGRAMS AN ALPHABET SOUP OF-
OF APPROACHES. AND NOTHING WE
DO IS DRIVEN TOWARDS- IT
ENFORCEABLE RESULT. AND AS WE
SAID DURING OUR COMMISSION
PROCEEDINGS NAME ANOTHER AREA
OF MAJOR PUBLIC POLICY WHERE
EVERYTHING THAT GOVERNMENT
CALLS ON THAT THE PEOPLE TO DO
IS OPTIONAL OR VOLUNTARY IF IT
MATTERS. WE REQUIRE IT I'LL
GIVE THE CREDIT TO SUPERVISOR
FLETCHER BECAUSE HE'S THE ONE
WHO CAME UP WITH THIS AND I'M
SORRY IF I STEAL IS LINED BUT
IT'S SO GOOD. AND THAT IS. WHEN
WE DECIDED CLIMATE CHANGE WAS A
MORAL IMPERATIVE. AND WE
DECIDED THAT RENEWABLE ENERGY
WITH A KEY PIECE OF ADDRESSING
CLIMATE WE DID NOT SAY TO THE
ENERGY WORLD OR THE LCAL AIR
QUALITY DISTRICTS ARE TO THE
STATE ITSELF. PLEASE VOLUNTEER
TO SUBSTITUTE OUT YOUR FOSSIL
FUELS RENEWABLE ENERGY DO THE
BEST YOU CAN REPORT TO WEST
WHEN YOU CANAND HERE'S SOME
MONEY AND GOOD LUCK WE DIDN'T
DO THAT. WE REQUIRED IT THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARDS
IN CALIFORNIA THE LAWS I WAS
PART OF THAT YOU'RE PART OF
REQUIRE US TO MEET. AGGRESSIVE
BUT REASONABLE PERCENTAGES AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOUR BILL
MISTER CHAIRMAN SEEKS TO DO. IT
DOESN'T SAY FINE MONEY THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE BECAUSE YOU'RE VERY
CLEAR THAT ACCOUNTABILITY NEED
IT SHOULD ONLY BE COMMENSURATE
IN A FAIR WAY WITH RESOURCES.
BUT IF ANYBODY BELIEVES THAT
THE CURRENT SOURCE MIX WE HAVE.
BEING SPENT WITH THE MAC.
AMOUNT OF URGENCY IN TERMS OF
HOW LONG IT TAKES TO GET MONEY
OUT. WITH THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
COLLABORATION IN TERMS OF
JURISDICTIONS. COORDINATING OR
CONSOLIDATING THE RESOURCES TO
GET MORE PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS. AND THAT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THAT OBJECTIVE OF
REDUCING ON SHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS NOT AS AN END. BUT
IS THE BEGINNING OF MOVING
PEOPLE. THROUGH A CONTINUUM TO
PERMANENT HOUSING. NOBODY CAN
MAKE THAT CLAIM THAT WE ARE
DOING THIS IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE THAT'S
WHERE YOU SEE THE LAWSUIT AND
WHY YOU SEE. THE FRUSTRATION
THIS WOULD GIVE US. EIGHT EIGHT
AND ENFORCEABLE- FOCUS THAT
COMBINED WITH RESOURCES I
BELIEVE WOULD MOVE US TOWARDS
GREATER PERCENTAGES IN NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY GETTING OFF
THE STREET I THINK THIS IS A
VITAL BILL NOT JUST TO TALK TO
DO THE INTERESTING PROVOCATIVE
IDEA BUT HE IS A VITAL
SUPERVISOR RIDLEY THOMAS MICE
CO SPONSOR AND I IN THE ENTIRE
COMMISSION. BELIEVE IT WITHOUT
A CLEAR PUBLIC POLICY BUT IT IS
NO LONGER LEGALLY ACCEPTABLE
FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE OUTDOORS
WITHOUT. WITHOUT ANY MOVE
TOWARDS TRYING TO HELP THEM
COME INDOORS THAT NO MATTER HOW
MUCH MONEY WE SPEND IT IN THE
END ISN'T GOING TO GET BETTER
BUT THAT COMBINATION OF THE
TWO. MONEY AND REQUIRE AND WHAT
WE ALL KNOW IS NECESSARY FOR
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PEOPLE
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. WE THINK
WE CAN ALL MOVE THIS ISSUE-
TOWARDS A MUCH BETTER
TRAJECTORY AND I APPRECIATE
THE- THE EFFORT AND I HOPE
THAT- THIS BILL IS A
CENTERPIECE OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE- CHOOSES TO DO
AROUND HOMELESSNESS THIS YEAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MAYOR OF THE MODERATOR COULD
NOT OPEN UP THE LINE FOR OUR
SECOND WITNESS MORE ATOP FROM
THE CITY CENTER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MATTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M WHERE
A TOP ON THE HOSPICE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO CERTAINLY AN HONOR TO
FOLLOW THEIR CAMARO. MERIT
THEIR STEINBERG BACK TO AND THE
CITY IS- VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT. OF AB THIRTY
TO SIXTY NINE. DIEGO IT'S ONE
OF THE FEW JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS ACTUALLY
SEEN A REDUCTION IN HOME A
THREE IN EACH OF THE LAST TWO
YEARS. WE'RE CERTAINLY PLEASED
WITH THAT THAT THAT THAT. BUT
WE KNOW THAT MORE MUST BE DONE.
THE CITY HAVE A SELF IMPOSED
GOAL TO REDUCE ON SHELTER
HOMELESS IN OUR CITY BY 50% IN
THE NEXT THREE YEARS. THE
REDUCTION GOAL OF 90% BY TWENTY
TWENTY NINE INCLUDED IN AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE IS IN LINE
WITH THE FANS WITH SAN DIEGO
GOAL. IT'S A STRETCH GOAL BUT
WE DO BELIEVE IT'S THE RIGHT
CALL. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS REQUIRES
MORE THAN JUST THE WORK DONE
AND DESPERATE CITIES. AND
INSTEAD MUST BE REGIONAL. INTER
REGIONAL AND EVEN STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL FURTHER IF THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES. AND WE
THINK CREATES THE RIGHT MIX OF
CARROTS AND STICKS TO TACKLE
HOMELESSNESS. THIS THAT IF THE
DOCTOR AND FUNDED CONSEQUENTIAL
HOMELESS REDUCTION MEASURES.
SAN DIEGO BELIEVES THAT ALL
CITY SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO DO THEIR PART TO AND
HOMELESSNESS. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE
MEASURE AND KINDLY ASK FOR YOUR
I THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN TO ANY-
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IT IS ZERO IF
YOU HAVE NOT DONE SO ALREADY
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO
WILL GO TO MY NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND ONE. NINE FIVE ZERO
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FIVE
ZERO ONE THE LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FIVE ZERO ONE DO YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER FIVE ZERO SIX THE
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT BACK AGAIN
DOLLARS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN FRONT. MY
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LINE FIVE TWO ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA AND TRUNKS QUIRK.
YOU HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE TWO TWO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND I ALSO SERVED ON
THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE WITH
MERE STEINBERG AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
SIX ONE SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LOUIS MANDE WITH
CALIFORNIA THE ALTERNATIVE PORT
THANKS. MY NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE LINE FIVE TWO ONE.
YES DANIEL CON WAY WITH THE LA
LINES GIVEN RIGHT ECHOING THEIR
STEINBERG'S WORD IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX POINT TWO FIVE SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TO FIFTY
SIX. THREE HOOKER MOTION CHRIS
SPEAKING IS REPRESENTED IN
CENTER REGION BE. IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIVE LINE AT FIVE
ZERO FIVE. GO AHEAD LINE FIVE
ZERO FIVE. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON
TO MY NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN LINE
SIX SEVEN. CHRISTOPHER MARTIN
HADN'T CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED IN ONE LINE. FIVE ZERO
ONE. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND ONE
THE LINE IS OPEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY NO RESPONSE WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE LINE ONE NINE NINE. HI
ADAM IN ORDER SEVEN CALIFORNIA
OUT THAT HAVE. THE MIDDLE RIGHT
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY OF THE-
I'D LIKE TO BUT THERE MIGHT
ORDER OUR- AND TONIGHT BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ANYONE
ELSE WISHES TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE YOU WILL PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE GO TO MY NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND ONE THE LINE IS
OPEN LINE FIVE ZERO ONE. YOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OUT TOWARDS ON THE
APP THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF VETERANS SERVICE AGENCY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL UP PERSON IN THE
QUEUE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE
TWENTY FOUR. A LINE FIVE TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS PETER I DO AND- ALMOST
POLICY DIRECTOR TO OAKLAND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE MAYOR-
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
FOR INTRODUCING THIS
LEGISLATION- AND I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALLOWING IT TO THAT. AND THEN
ADD THE MAYOR IS THE BAY AREA'S
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S- COUNCIL UP REGIONAL
HOW MUCH ADVISORS YEAH AND IS
HAPPY TO SUPPORT. THIS BILL IF
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER. FIVE
TWENTY SIX. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
HI LINE FIVE TWENTY SIX A LINE
IS OPEN. HI RECOMMENDATIONS ON
BEHALF OF LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU IT SEEING AS WE HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IT ASKED THE MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE.
OPPOSITION OUT PLEASE OUT PRESS
ONE THEN IT IS ZERO AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION FIRST ONE THEN ZERO.
YEAH NO ONE QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MY CASE TO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ABOUT. WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND A MOTION
BY SOME MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA- I WILL NOTE THAT THIS-
BILL ENJOYS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
AND FOR ME AS WELL. AND ASK THE
COURT TO CALL THE ROLL. I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY OPPORTUNITY
CLOSEST. OKAY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TO
HI Q. AIDID. GABRIEL KNIGHT
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I
HIGHLY KILEY NO THE MOM.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA HI THAT BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES SOME CALL. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU I THINK WE'LL MOVE
NEXT TO OPT FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB THREE ZERO FOUR ZERO- BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER Q. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THINKING COLLEAGUES COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL WOULD HELP CITIES GET
THE CREDIT THEY DESERVE WHEN
THEY ALLOW UP TO FOUR UNITS PER
PARCEL. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
CURRENTLY CREATING THEIR HEALTH
PLANS FOR THE MISSION EIGHT
CITY THIS IS A COMMON PROCESS
THAT HAPPENS EVERY EIGHT YEARS
BUT THIS TIME IT'S GONNA LOOK
DIFFERENT DUE TO THE WORK THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE DID A NUMBER
OF YEARS BACK WHEN WE REQUIRE
OUR STATES PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING OVERALL HOUSING
DEMAND. TO REFLECT NOT JUST
GROWTH BUT THE BACKLOG OF
MILLIONS OF UNITS THAT HAVE
BEEN BUILT THIS TIME AROUND THE
BAR'S GONNA BE HIGHER FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WILL HAVE TO MAKE
SOME HARD DECISIONS THAT THEY
MAY HAVE POSTPONED FOR SOME
DECADES. ONE OF THOSE HARD
DECISIONS MIGHT BE TO ALLOW FOR
MORE HOUSING IN NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY EXCLUSIVELY
SINGLE FAMILIES ON. THERE'S A
LOT TO LIKE ABOUT SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES AND THIS BILL DOESN'T SAY
ANYTHING NEGATIVE ABOUT THEM OR
WHO LIVES IN THEM. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
ZONE AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
LAND IN CALIFORNIA TO SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING. IT IS NOT THE
MOST EFFICIENT USE OF LAND AND
GIVING CHANGING CLIMATE. WILD
VIRUS AND PUNISHING COMMUTES WE
CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND OUTWARDS. WE
ALSO NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE
EXCLUSIONARY. AND OFTEN REYES
SPACING CLASS SPACE NATURE OF
THIS DESIGN. AB THIRTY FORTY
SIGNALS TO CITIES THAT THE
STATE WILL GUARANTEE THEM
ISSUED HOUSING TARGETS FOR
EVERY SITE THAT THEY UP ZONE.
FROM SINGLE FAMILY TO FOR
PLEXUS. THE VALUE TO CITIES AND
TOWNS IS THAT THEY CAN
CALCULATE THIS CREDIT UP FRONT.
RATHER THAN AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS THIS BILL THIS BILL
BILLS IN GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
THAT NEW UNITS COULD BE
CREATED. THIS BILL THIS BILL
ALSO BUILT IN AND CENTERS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE CREDIT GRANTED
BY THE BILL. ALLOWING EASY TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL CREDIT. AND
BEFORE TURN IT OVER TO
WITNESSES I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE STILL ADDITIONAL
WORK TO BE DONE WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BILL PROPERTY LINES. WITH THE
PROCESS THEY'RE CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING. AND THAT WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH LAND USE A CONTEST. TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THE EXACT RIGHT AMOUNT OF
CREDIT. WITH THAT I WANT TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
WINTER STAND WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- SUNDAY
GEORGE AND- JASON RHYNE
INTERNAT THE MODERATOR TO
CONNECT US WITH THE FIRST
WITNESS SEEM TO GEORGE. YES ANY
GEORGE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'LL BE QUICK
BUT IF YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
REALLY LIKE THE INCENTIVE
APPROACH- IT ALLOWS THE USE OF
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE TO IDENTIFY A
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES. AND
LOCALS ARE ALSO GOING TO BE-
ABLE TO IDENTIFY LOCATIONS THAT
WILL SUPPORT THE INCREASED
DENSITY THAT WILL ACTUALLY
RESULT IN THE PRODUCTION I
WOULD HELP YOU. SO WE- SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SEE YOU AND ASKED
THE MODERATOR NOW TO CONNECT US
WITH THE SECOND WITNESS JASON
RHYNE. THANK YOU AYE JASON
WRANGLING IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE FUTURE MEMBERS YES NINE WE
CALIFORNIA'S IN A WEEK YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS CONCEPT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIRMAN
EFFORTS TO CREATE A PROGRAM
THAT INCENTIVE BASED IT'S NOT A
MANDATE BUT IT WAS STILL
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF THE
STATE AND QUITE FRANKLY GOAL TO
MANY CITIES. AND TO FIND A WAY
TO INCREASE THE DENSITY THAT
OUR COMMUNITY TO MEET BOTH
LOCAL AND STATE OBJECTIVES OF A
DISTRICT LIKE WHAT WE KNOW
WE'RE GONNA NEED. TO FIND MORE
ADEQUATE SITE THIS IS A GREAT
WAY OF PROVIDING THAT SITE
CREDIT- BASED ON THAT AND WE
DON'T EVEN WE SEEN IT DONE
SIMILARLY WITH EXCESS READ
WHILE IN UNIT SO WE REALLY
SUPPORT THE GERMAN I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING THIS OUT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. WE COME
TOGETHER WITH WITH THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OF CREDIT WE SHOULD GET
AS WE DO THE EXAM IS A FIGURE
WHICH BUT SOME OF THE QUESTION.
I HAVE A. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT AT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO ON THE
PHONE KEYPAD. IF YOU HAVE NOT
DONE SO ALREADY AGAIN THAT IS
IN SUPPORT YOU WILL PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO. AND ALSO I BELIEVE
THAT LINE NUMBER TWO TWO EIGHT.
WOULD LIKE TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE. AT TWO TWO EIGHT. LINE
ARE YOU. TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
WE WOULD NEED YOU TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. OKAY MIND TO TWENTY
EIGHT YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH
YOUR QUESTION. OR COMMENT.
NINETY TWO EIGHT WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU ONE MOMENT.
GIVE A CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND WE
GO NEXT TO MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX TWO FIVE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS. AN INCREASE BECAUSE
THE REPRESENTATIVE SNACK YOU
CAN BE. AND HILET YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. DONEC SO
MY NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT LINE. SIX
EIGHT. A LITTLE BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FIELD SAID COUNTY%
AND ORANGE COUNTY BASED STRONG
SUPPORTER OF CALIFORNIA EMB ONE
STRONG SUPPORTERS BILL. AND WE
HAVE LINE FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN LINE FIVE TO SEVEN. I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON GERRY MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HOW
PUBLIC AFFAIRS I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WE GO TO LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR LINE FOUR
NINE FOUR. GET YOUR NUMBERS
PARTNERING WITH HERE AND WE CAN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENT WILL HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I HAVE MY NUMBER. FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE NINE FIVE
TWO THREE. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JOHN MIGHT IT WITH EAST
BAY FOR EVERYONE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
THAT IS LINE TWO SEVEN NINE. HI
CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AS WELL THE URBAN
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA AND THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAD A
SUPPORTING CONCEPT POSITION AND
THINK THE OTHER COURSE WORK ON
THIS. MY NUMBER SIXTY THAT IS
LINE NUMBER SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE AFTERNOON WILL BE-
FERRERI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT. AND IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
HAS NOT YET YOU MAY DO THAT BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN IN
THE PORT YOU WOULD PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE ELSE QUEUING
UP PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION THAT'S-
CHRIS ACROSS CAN YOU- PLEASE
CONNECT US NOW WITH OUR FIRST
WITNESS. I DON'T THINK HE'S-
VERY. ARE YOU LOOKING FOR CHRIS
TO PRESS ON THE PHONE. YES I
JUST A MOMENT ONE MOMENT. IS IT
THE H. R. I. S. I'M NOT
LOCATING THAT NAME ON THE CALL.
I UNDERSTAND HE MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW SO CAN YOU
DO WITH MODERATOR DO YOU MIND
OPENING UP THE LINE UP TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. THE MAIN LINE. HERE
OKAY ONE MOMENT. DO YOU HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION- TESTIMONY
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION YOU WILL
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. BE
JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANKS AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION YOU WILL PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ONE MOMENT. YEAH.
WE HAVE- NINE SEVENTY FOUR NINE
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GUYS
FOR ME THIS TIME YES. FIVE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER SORRY BUT THAT'S NOT
BROUGH NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENED
THIS IS CHRIS WOULD DROP WITH
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND- WE
OPPOSE EIGHT THE THIRTY FORTY.
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T JUST HAVE A
HOUSING SHORTAGE WE HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
AB THIRTY FORTY WOULD NOT
IMPROVE THE STATE'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SHORTAGE IN FACT IT
VERY LIKELY WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITE EFFECT I MANDATING THE
REPLACEMENT OF EXISTING SINGLE
FAMILY STOCKTON FOR AND WITH
EIGHTY USE POTENTIALLY EIGHT.
MULTI FAMILY UNITS THE BILL
WOULD RESULT IN HIGHER THE
LUXURY DEVELOPMENTS DISPLACING
COHESIVE EXISTING NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT POLICY WOULD BE A GIVEAWAY
TO BIG DEVELOPERS AT THE
EXPENSE OF DESTRUCTION OF
EXISTING NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES. AB THIRTY FORTY IS
REALLY ANOTHER TOP DOWN ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS THE
MANDATE STUDENTS TO BE AND
COUNTLESS SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND IS
PARTICULARLY TROUBLING THOSE
PROVISIONS US- SPECIFICALLY
TARGET. HOMES THAT ARE FIFTEEN
OR MORE YEARS OLDER THIS
SUGGESTS A RIFLE SHOT THE NEXT
BUSINESS DAY. ESTABLISHED AND
COHESIVE NEIGHBORHOODS. WHEN I
WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT ON THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BLOCK WITH YOUR
NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE GETS KNOCKED
OUT. AND REPLACED BY A LARGER
BOTHERED BUT THE FAMILY ABOUT
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
DO WHAT. WE DO. THE COROLLARY
IS THE PROBLEM IS THE BILL'S
BACK AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS. AND AS WE KNOW-
OFTEN EVEN MODERATE AND ABOUT
MODERATE INCOME REQUIREMENTS
YOU'RE SKIRTED. SO AGAIN THAT'S
ANOTHER WAY TO DISPEL WHAT I
THINK UNINTENTIONALLY
INCENTIVIZE. LUXURY OR HIGH AND
MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT SCREW
JUSTIN COMMUNITIES. AND THE
LAST POINT I'D LIKE TO MAKE IS
I WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER THAT THE NEIGHBORHOODS
MOST VULNERABLE TO THIS KIND
OF. DE FACTO UP SO THEY CAN
DISPLACEMENT ARE PRETTY DECENT
URBAN CORES. WHICH IN MANY
CASES RECORDS OF LOWER INCOME
AND MINORITY HOMEOWNERSHIP. SO
NEIGHBORHOODS MAILLET LIKE
CRENSHAW WE LOOK PARK. HEIGHTS
ELSEWHERE WOULD BE PRIME
TARGETS LASTLY LIKE MANY
HOUSING IN THE CONTEXT OF
CLOTHES NINETEEN. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE STATE HOUSING NEEDS
ARE GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN SIX
MONTHS MUCH LESS FOR SIX YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD WHEN THIS BILL
WOULD REALLY KICK **** AND SO
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE
STRONGLY URGE EMAIL PHONES ON
AT THIRTY FORTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NUMBER FIVE. EIGHT
FIVE TWO EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME JOKES TO WORK CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. OKAY HI JILL
DILLARD I'M WITH- ANYTHING ELSE
FOR TREES WHICH THEN BY MIDDLE
GROUP AND THE GLOBAL CALIFORNIA
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT SOME- MARKETING
AND GEN X. HOME HOMEOWNERS THE
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD HOUSING ISSUES
BAFFLING TO ME WE HAVE A HUGE
NUMBER OF WORKING CLASS PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BE AFFECTED
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
CHEST ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
RESIDENTS MANY MANY OF THEM
FAMILY HOMES AND REALIZE YOU
DON'T HAVE MUCH OF THIS IN THE
BAY AREA AND I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENCES IN THE TWO FIVE
STATE BUT WE HAVE MANY MANY
FIBER FILLED WITH CHINO AND
BLACK WORKING CLASS MEMBERS ALL
OF WHOM WOULD BE DISRUPTED IN
POTENTIAL- BOUGHT OUT SHOVED
OUT OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS BY
DISH I JUST DON'T. IF. I DON'T
THINK IT'S NOT TO IT'S NOT FOR
WHO SOUTHERN CAL. WE LOOK LIKE
IT WAS FOUGHT FOR THE BAY AREA
AND WE ASK THAT YOU. AND START
ALL OF THANK YOU MUCH. IF
ANYONE ELSE IS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MAKE YOU UP BY
PRESSING ONE THEN IT IS ZERO
AGAIN THAT IS ONE. THEN FZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU ARE BRINGING IT BACK ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A OUR MOTION.
YEAH SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
US A MEMBER QUIRK SILVA A
SECOND FROM MISTER GLORIA-
MISTER TURNER JOY TO CLOSE I DO
WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS- IN
RESPONSE TO THE OPPOSITION
FIRST OF ALL- THE IDEA THAT
THISIS A MANDATE IS SIMPLY NOT
TRUE- AND IN FACT- I WOULD SAY
I DON'T THINK THAT- SEE
SACROILIITIS CITIES OR THE
IRVINE COUNTY CALIFORNIA OR THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES-
WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED THIS BILL
IF IT WASN'T MANDATE. THIS IS
PURELY THEN THE LOCAL CONTROL
OF ANY JURISDICTION TO DECIDE
WHAT IS IT THAT THEY WANT TO DO
SO NOTHING ABOUT THAT COULD BE
FURTHER THAN THE TRUTH- I WANT
TO MENTION THERE IS A QUESTION
ABOUT WHY WE SAY APPLICABLE SIX
NEED TO INVOLVE HOUSING OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS OF THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT NEWER HOUSING
IS LESS LIKELY TO BE DEMOLISHED
WE'RE GONNA. FOCUS ON. ON SIDE
EFFECTS. I'M IN THE- BLESSING I
JUST HAVE TO SUGGEST. IT IT IS
WELL DOCUMENTED THAT SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING. CAME ABOUT
BECAUSE OF- OF OFTENTIMES CLASS
SPACE MOTIVATIONS AND RACE
BASED MOTIVATIONS AND THE IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW THE OPPOSITION
WILL TRY TO CLOAK THEIR
OPPOSITION ARE REFERRING TO
THEIR DESIRE TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS
INCREDIBLY IRONIC AND FRANKLY
SLIGHTLY OFFENSIVE- BUT TAKING
THEM AT FACE VALUE- JUST SIMPLY
WRONG SO I HAVE TO SAY THAT.
AND THAT WITH THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ADULT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- COURT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS Q. FIVE Q. BY
THE BIKE APRIL. GLORIA GLORIA I
KILEY. KILEY EILEEN MOM.
MAIENSCHEIN QUIRK SILVA. FIVE
FIVE IN SUPPORT THE BILL IS OUT.
GREAT THANK YOU I THINK WE'RE
COMING UP ON OUR LAST BUILD-
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
THAT'S A. B. THREE ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT MISTER CHIP. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS CLEAN
UP BILL FOR A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
THE- TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TENANT PROTECTION ACT. AS THIS
COMMITTEE WILL WILL WELL
pROBUST CONVERSATIONS. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO PROVIDES.
EIGHT MILLION TENANTS JUST
BECAUSE PROTECTIONS AND A CAP
ON RENT INCREASES. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE EVERY ASPECT OF THE
DEAL LAST YEAR WAS
PAINSTAKINGLY NEGOTIATED DOWN
TO THE VERY LAST DAYS OF
SESSION- HOWEVER AS THE DUST
CLEARED FROM THE NEGOTIATIONS
IT BECAME. APPARENT THAT THERE
WERE A FEW PROVISIONS- THAT
WERE POTENTIALLY OPEN TO
INTERPRETATION. AB THIRTY
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT IS MEANT TO
PROVIDE CLARITY AND TO REMOVE
SUBJECTIVITY FROM THE LAW SO
THAT ALL PARTIES CAN BETTER
IMPLEMENTED. IT INCLUDES ITEMS
SUCH AS CLEAN UP ITS REFERENCE
IN A REQUIRE NOTICE AND THEY'RE
DEFINING HOW TO MEASURE THE
CHANGE IN THE- INDEX AND ALL
NOTE. THIS BILL IS MEANT TO BE
NON CONTROVERSIAL. WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES ON ALL SIDES OF THE
ISSUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
CONCERNS. AND THEIR LIVES
EXPERIENCES ARE REFLECTED AND
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR WITNESS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE- ONE. PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT BRAND ACOSTA
WHO IS JOINING US VIA VIDEO
CONFERENCE. I AM NOT STUDENTS
ACTUALLY CALLING AND SO WE-
YEAH. MODERATOR COULD YOU CAN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD BRAND ACOSTA
THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU-
CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS BRIAN I
GOT THAT WILL KEEP IT SHORT BUT
ON BEHALF OF ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND- ALL
OF THE OTHER MANY SUPPORTERS
AND OPPONENTS OF THE BILL. WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
AND- MANY CO AUTHORS FOR THE
INITIAL LEGISLATION AND AS WE
ALL LIVE WITHTHAT A LITTLE BIT
CLEARLY WE'VE NOTICED- SOME
THINGS THAT WERE. AGREED UPON
BUT THE LANGUAGE WAS NOT AS
CLEAR AS IT COULD BE AND SO
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE SOME OF
THAT. CLARITY WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH EVERYONE TO
FURTHER- RESOLVED SOME OF THE
REMAINING AMBIGUITY THAT WE ARE
THE MOVE THE THIRTY FOUR TO
BEGIN ON THAT SO. THANK YOU
AGAIN AND URGENT ABOUT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
MAIN LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN ZERO ON
THE KEYPAD AGAIN FOR SUPPORT IT
IS ONE THEN ZERO. I NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE. FIVE THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HI
MY NAME IS ROBERT FRONT LINE-
CALLING I'M WITH THE- MEET IN
THE ACTION I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M CALLING AT THE
PORT THANK YOU. FIND TWO TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY TWO EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD I THINK IT'S
EVENING DIFFERENT EVER CARLTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION I WANNA SAYING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR
WORKING ON THIS CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE AND FOR STATING THAT
THIS IS. LANGUAGE THAT WILL BE
NON CONTROVERSY OR WE ARE GOING
TO WORK WITH HIM- TO CORRECT
SOME OF THE- STATEMENT- INTO
LEGISLATION AND WE APPRECIATE
HIM WORKING WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YEAH MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX LINE ONE
SEVEN THIS. I AM WITH MARK THEY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN BE AT
THE POOL THANK. MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY SIX LINE FOUR
NINE SIX. SHOP AROUND AND WHAT
CAMPAñA LAW AND POVERTY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF ANYONE
WISHES TO QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ONE THEY AND ZERO. NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
YEAH I BELIEVE I HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PARTY IN THE QUEUE
JUST ONE MOMENT. THE HELP LINE
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN LINE OUT LINE FIVE ONE
EIGHT WE HAVE YOUR LINE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE NUMBERS
CLEAN GREASY ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- CA ARE THE TWEENER ON
THIS MEASURE BUT THAT WE WANT
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
CARE OF CRISTINA CLARIFY
AMBIGUITIES. CLASSROOMS
LEGISLATION VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR. HEY COLDER'S ON
IDENTICAL ON LANGUAGE YOU THERE
BY THE HE WOULD BE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING THAT
WE HAVE NO- PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ASK THE MODERATOR
IF. TO OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OFFICE. SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO ONE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ABOUT MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA- MISTER CHIU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A START ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. I'M HOPING THIS IS
ONE OF THE USER MEASURES THAT
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT.
VERY GOOD. MISSING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL YES- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS Q. HI JILL I
DEEP. IS THIS FOR AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT YES HI. THE BY
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I GLORIA
GLORIA AYE KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTING THE MOM. MAIENSCHEIN OUR
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA I. THAT IS. SIX SIX
FOLKS IN SUPPORT SO THAT
MEASURES OUT. THANK YOU MISTER.
I JUST. COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR GATHERING- WE'RE HOPING
MISS THEM ON WILL JOIN US
MOMENTARILY BUT- LET ME JUST
START BY THINKING- EVERYONE
WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IN TODAY
STARTING WITH MY STAFF- MY POOR
STAFF HAVE BEEN TOILING-
BURNING THE MIDNIGHT OIL FOR
MANY MANY WEEKS- GOING THROUGH
MANY MANY BILL'S GOING THROUGH
MANY MANY VERSIONS MANY
VERSIONS OF AMENDMENTS AND
GIRAFFES AND- YOU GUYS HAVE
DONE AN AMAZING JOB SO I JUST
WANNA. AT LEAST GOAL THE WORTH
AND SANDRA. AND ALL THE WORK IN
THIS BEING AND ALL THE WORK
THEY'RE COMMITTEE HAS DONE-
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
SERGEANTS- FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
DURING THIS AND I PARTICULAR
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
MODERATOR. MODERATE TOWARDS-
FOR THEIR ALL THEIR WORK DURING
THIS AND AS WELL AS- THANK YOU
TO OUR MEMBERS. I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF MOVING PIECES
WITH THE BILLS AND APPRECIATE-
YOU'RE ENGAGED ON THIS SO. AT
THIS MOMENT LET ME JUST SEE IF
WE'RE EXPECTING HIS LIMON
ANYTIME SOON. YEAH YES- I'M
ABOUT TO DO ADAMS I'M JUST
HOPING SHE'S GONNA RUN AND SO
WHEN I HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN BUT-
IF YOU. LOOK AT THAT. RIGHT ON
TIME. OKAY. ALRIGHT LETS US
START WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA
WE'VE NOT ACTUALLY MOVED AS SO
COULD I TAKE. A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY ON
ITEMS- LINE OUT OF FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE TING
LINE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX GABRIEL FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY NINE SHE-
THE MOTION ON ITEM FOUR AND
NINE IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE MOTION ON ITEM
TWENTY ONE IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CALENDAR Q. HI CHU I. DEEP
CONSENT HI DEEP I GAVE EL HI
ZERO FIVE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE THE MOM. LIMON
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I.
GREAT CONSENT IS PASSED LET'S
GO TO THE TOP THE ORDER
ANYTHING FILE ITEM ONE WE DON'T
HAVE QUORUM WHEN WE STARTED SO-
LET ME ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR-
AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX. WEEKS
SIR SECOND OKAY MADAM SECRETARY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SHE'LL TRY TO
I'D DEEP NO. DEEP NOW GABRIEL
GIVE FOR A AYE GLORIA. GLORIA
AYE AYE KILEY KILEY NO LIMON.
THE ONE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE THE BILL HAS.
SIX VOTE SITS OUT THE BILLS OUT
FILE AND TO HAVE ALREADY HAD A
MOTION AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE GONZALEZ- PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE MOM THE MAN
I MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN NOT
VOTING. BILLS OUT DO I TELL YOU
THE NUMBER SURE. SEVEN SEVEN
I'VE ONE NOT VOTING HI- FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FIVE BURKE. TWENTY FOUR OUT OF
FIVE- GABRIEL. GIVE A I. THE
AMOUNT THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. THE VOTE IS HAS
SEVEN VOTE SEVEN EYES AND ONE
NOT VOTING THE BILL IS OUT-
FILE AND FIVE A. B. THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO TEN. THE EIGHT. NO
DEEP NOW. MAIENSCHEIN MAIN
CHINA I. THAT BILL HAS FIVE ICE
AND SHE KNOWS THE BILL'S OUT
FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EGGMAN. KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA I. THE
BILL HAS SEVEN ICE. AND ONE NO
THE BILL'S ARE FALLEN EIGHT AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NO.
THAT BILL HAS FIVE ICE WHO
KNOWS ONE NOT VOTING. FOLLOW IN
TEN EIGHTY THIRTY THREE A WEEK
APRIL. STEVE HI STEVE I GLORIA
GLORIA HI THE MOM. THE ONE I AM
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. THE
BILL HAS EIGHT FIVE THE BILLS
OUT FILE ITEM. ELEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TO STAY. CABLE
GABRIEL I LIMON THE ONE I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. THE
BILL HAS SIX EYES TO KNOWS THE
BILL'S OUT FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY NINETY FIVE QUIRK
SILVA. DEEP. GLORIA. HI GLORIA
I THE MOM AND- THE ONE I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NO. THE
BILL HAS FIVE EYES ONE NOT
VOTING TO KNOWS THE BILL'S OUT
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY GIPSON. LEON THE ONE
I MAIENSCHEIN. MENTION I GLORIA
WAY UP HIGH THE BILL HAS EAT
ICE THE BILL IS A FELON SIXTEEN
AB THIRTY ONE OH SEVEN BLOOM.
STEVE NO. GLORIA. THE MON RIGHT
THE ONE I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO. THE BILL HAS
FIVE EYES. TO KNOWS ONE NOT THE
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
ROBERT RIVAS. DEEP NOT VOTING.
GLORIA. LIMA HI LIMON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NOT
VOTING. THE BILL HAS FIVE EYES.
THREE NOT VOTING THAT BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN TV THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED SANTIAGO. DE.
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN THE MONARCH
HI LEON I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. THE BILL HAS SIX
EYES ONE NOT VOTING ONE NO THE
BILL'S OUT FOLLOWED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THIRTY THREE FIFTY TWO
FRIEDMAN. DEEP NOT VOTING.
GLORIA HI GLORIA HI KILEY LEE
MOM THE ONE I MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I. THE BILL HAS SIX
EYES ONE NOT VOTING. I KNOW.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB THIRTY
FORTY CHIU. WE MONTH. THE ONE I
MAIENSCHEIN. HI MAIENSCHEIN I.
THE BILL HAS. SEVEN ICE. FOLLOW
NOT ONE NOT VOTING THE BILLS
OUT FILE AND TWENTY THREE AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT CHIP. THE
AMOUNT. THE ONE I. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN ICE ONE NOT VOTING AND
FINALLY FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
A. B. THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE ALSO
DAVID CHIU. AMOUNT THE MAN I
MAIENSCHEIN. IT'S FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. OUR AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY NINE DAVID CHIU. IT IS
INDEED IT'S A GOOD IT'S A GOOD
BILL SUPPORTED BY THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO BUT WHOSE DISCOUNT. I
MAIENSCHEIN I. SO THAT IS. SIX
HIGHS. ONE NOT VOTING ONE NO.
MESSAGE HERE YES- CAN CAN YOU
GO BACK TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY- HOW TO RIVAL IN THE-
FILE FILE AND TWENTY WE DIDN'T
VOTE BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO. NOW
HAPPY FEASIBLE FOR IF YOU WANT.
THE BOOK ALL RIGHT- THAT IS IT
UNLESS ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE ANY VOTES. OKAY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK THIS ENDS THIS PHASE OF
OUR LOGISTICS PROCESS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE I WILL SEE BACK IN
THIS COMMITTEE- LIKELY A FEW
WEEKS WAS SENATE BILLS. AND
WITH THAT AT THIS TIME AGAIN
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE INVOLVED
PARTICULAR STAFF- IT IS FIVE
FORTY WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.